David Boder: [In English] Geneva, August...August 27th, 1946. We are starting a new interview with Abraham Kimmelmann at eighth minute or so...seven and a half minutes of the spool.
David Boder: [In German] Also Herr Kimmelmann, wollen Sie mal,...also Herr Kimmelmann, wollen Sie uns wieder sagen, wie heißen Sie, wie alt Sie sind und wo sind Sie geboren.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich heiße Kimmelmann, Abraham, geboren am Zehnten (10.), Zehnten (10) neunzehn hundert acht und zwanzig (1928).
David Boder: In welchem was?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Am Zehnten (10.), Zehnten (10).
David Boder: Na ja, also, das ist am zehnten (10.) Oktober.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Am zehnten (10.) Oktober neunzehn hundert acht und zwanzig (1928).
David Boder: Ja, wo sind Sie geboren?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich wurde geboren in Polen...In Polen...
David Boder: In welcher...?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . in Oberschlesien in einer kleineren Stadt Dabrowa-Wolnitzek.
David Boder: Dabrowa-Wolnitzek?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Dabrowa-Wolnitzek.
David Boder: Also nun wollen Sie...Sie sagten mir, Sie wollen eine kleine Einleitung machen
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Ich sage es deshalb, weil ich weiß, worum es da eigentlich geht. Sie sind da her nicht gekommen nur um sich zu beschäftigen, was wir heute eigentlich tun, sondern ein bisschen wie es war in unserer Vergangenheit, nicht wahr?
David Boder: Ja natürlich!
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, also, wenn ich...und hauptsächlich vom Krieg?
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie haben uns gesagt, als wir beim Essen waren, dass Ihnen schon einige Jungs von dem Lager erzählt haben und zwar auf verschiedene Weise. Und zwar: Einer hat erzählt, dass es ihm ziemlich gut war, der Andere hat erzählt, dass es ihm sehr schlecht war und trotzdem haben sie beide die Wahrheit gesagt.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Da müssen Sie sich klar...im Klaren sein, dass die Burschen nicht nur glauben, dass sie die Wahrheit gesagt haben, sondern dass Sie unmöglich im Stande...die sind nicht im Stande, alles so zu erzählen wie es war.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Da müssen wir in die Geschichte einsehen oder wenn man ein Buch schreibt, oder etwas, da sagt man, man schreibt immer mehr als es war. Und da in diesem Falle ist es gerade umgekehrt. Man kann niemals so viel erzählen und so die Sachen herstellen, wie es in Wirklichkeit war.
David Boder: Na ja, sehen Sie, darum rede ich mit Vielen. Sehen Sie, darum will ich, dass viele die Sache erzählen sollen, dann kann man von jedem ein bisserl, das ganze Bild, das Mosaik, das ganze Bild zusammenstellen, sehen Sie. Nun verstehen Sie den Zweck, warum ich zwei hundert (200) Spulen von diesen ganzen Reden sammeln will, weil Keiner das Ganze erzählen kann. Verstehen Sie? Also erzählen Sie mir mit vielen Einzelheiten, Sie brauchen sich nicht zu sputen, wir haben genug Draht und genug Zeit, sehen Sie. Ich höre besser weniger Leute, die viel erzählen, denn viele Leute, die wenig erzählen. Also wo waren Sie, wenn der Krieg anfing und was hat Ihnen passiert? Und erzählen Sie mir, wo möglich, Tag für Tag, Woche für Woche was vorgegangen ist.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also bis zum Krieg habe...hatte ich nur die Möglichkeit—was die Volksbildung anbelangt—hatte ich nur die Möglichkeit einige Klassen zu lernen, das heißt bis zur fünften (5.) Klasse.
David Boder: Bis zur fünften (5.) Klasse. In was für einer Schule waren Sie?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also, dass...da mein Vater religiös war, hat er mir nicht erlaubt in die Volksschule zu gehen., sondern in ein Privat Cheder, ein jüdisch Cheder...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . und man hatte dort einen polnischen Lehrer gehabt, der uns in diese Gegenstände unterrichtet hat.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und da der Krieg ausgebrochen ist, hatte ich keine Gelegenheit mehr zu lernen.
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Damals war ich zwölf Jahre.
David Boder: Und warum hatten Sie keine Möglichkeit mehr zu lernen, wie der Krieg ausgebrochen ist?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Als der Krieg ausbrach, wissen Sie bestimmt...wissen Sie ganz genau, dass schon nach Polen die Deutschen eingezogen sind. Und...und was für Gedanken sie sich schon vorher gemacht haben, und was für Pläne, das ist auch heute allen Leuten bekannt. Sowie sie eingetreten sind nach Polen, war das Erste gegen die Juden etwas zu machen. Was es nur nicht sein soll. Selbstverständlich konnten sie nicht auf einmal alle Juden erschießen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie haben aber alles so eingerichtet, dass sie alles systematisch gemacht haben, dass es niemand so genau merken sollte und dass niemand fliehen konnte.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und so—als die Deutschen rein kamen, wurde sogleich eine...spezielle Stunden—eine Ausgangszeit für die Juden verordnet und dann durften wir nicht raus gehen.
David Boder: Haben Sie Zeichen tragen müssen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war...das war noch nicht zuerst...
David Boder: So wie hat man gewusst, wer spät ausgeht, dass er ein Jude war?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also in der ersten Zeit hat man gleich legitimiert, denn sie hatten Angst, vielleicht findet sich jemand von einer Partei oder so, sie haben doch solche Leute gesucht.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und deswegen haben sie die Verordnung raus gegeben und da jedermann Angst hatte, dass man von ihm einen Ausweis verlangt—auf den Ausweisen waren doch immer geschrieben, was für ein Glauben man ist, ob Moses...Moses oder christlich, das hat man gleich bemerkt. Die zweite Sache war, dass man...wie heißt.. das?...dass man das Ritual verboten hat, man darf nicht schlachten...
David Boder: Oh, man hat das Schlachten verboten?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . ja, man hat das Schlachten verboten. Und dann durfte, ein Jeder durfte nicht mehr haben als tausend (1000) Mark, das heißt zwei tausend (2 000) Zloty. Den Rest muss er abgeben. Was Gold und Silber anbelangt, das ist schon selbstverständlich, dass man das abgeben muss.
David Boder: Das ist nicht selbstverständlich! Man hat bekannt gemacht, dass man was?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hat bekannt gemacht, dass man das Gold und Silber abgeben muss.
David Boder: Nun.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war zuerst. Nun wollten sie uns den Kopf verdrehen und...[beide sprechen]
David Boder: Haben die Leute denn Gold und Silber abgegeben?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das hat jeder gemacht, wie er das gefühlt hat. Wenn man sehr ängstlich war und man konnte die Dinge nicht behalten, der hat sie abgegeben. Aber wer mehr abenteuerlich war und hat es riskieren wollen, dann hat man es auch versteckt. Denn von dem ist auch...war auch abhängig das Leben von den Menschen, denn wenn man kein Geld hatte, konnte man sterben von dem Hunger.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das Schlimmste was noch von Anfang an war,...
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . das war, wir haben Brot Coupons bekommen—also es war alles rationiert. Aber...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . es hat sich grundsätzlich um Brot gehandelt, andere Sachen konnte man noch so...hm, hm,...
David Boder: Bekommen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . bekommen.
David Boder: Weiter! Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber wenn wir auch schon die Brot Coupons hatten, war es doch nicht ganz leicht sie zu bekommen. Man konnte nicht einfach ins Geschäft rein gehen oder zum Bäcker und sagen:“ Ja, da haben sie die Coupons, geben sie mir das Brot.“ Man musste von zehn (10) Uhr nachts bis morgen um fünf (5), sechs (6) Uhr stehen und warten, ob es kalt war oder heiß, ob es geregnet hat, bis man zum Fenster endlich hin gekommen ist, um das Brot zu bekommen. Aber öfters...
David Boder: Waren da auch jüdische Bäcker?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also, ich werde alles erzählen. Öfters war es aber so, dass die Polen haben die Juden erkannt, sie haben sie noch von vor dem Krieg gekannt, und da sie das Brot...die Menge Brot haben wollen, sagten sie den Deutschen: „Ja, das ist Jude.“ Und sie haben auch mit dem Finger gezeigt: Jude. Das eine Wort, dass sie im Deutschen gelernt haben, das haben sie gesagt. Und auf diese Weise haben sie verraten den Juden, der schon zwölf (12) Stunden in der Reihe gestanden ist und als er zum Fenster kam, sagte man ihm: „Jude weg!“. Und in solchen Zuständen hat man gelebt gleich am Anfang, als die Deutschen rein kamen. Aber es war doch noch in Polen vom Anfang, es waren doch alle Juden...doch fast alle Juden und da haben sie gemacht, dass sie jüdischen Bäckern Konzessionen gegeben haben und sie haben das Brot für die Juden gebacken. Also in dieser...in dieser Hinsicht war es schon ein bisschen leichter, dass man wenigstens nur zwischen Juden gestanden ist. Die Zeit des Stehens war genau die selbe von Anfang an, aber wenn man schon endlich zum Fenster gekommen ist, hat man uns das Wort „Jude weg“ nicht gesagt, weil wir an und für sich alle Jude waren, die sich angestellt. Das war nur der Anfang—was die Deutschen gemacht haben, als sie rein kamen. Es ging aber immer weiter. Man hat uns aus verschiedenen Strassen ausgewiesen und sogar verboten, dass man...dass kein Jude darf nicht die Strasse betreten. Und so war es immer mehr und immer mehr und man hat uns immer mehr zusammen gepresst in einem Viertel, wo die Juden gewohnt haben. Nun damit war angeregt, man musste die...die Gassen putzen und dazu nimmt man, nimmt man einfach Juden.
David Boder: Wieviel Juden waren hier?
Abraham Kimmelmann: In unserem Städtchen waren ungefähr fünf tausend (5 000) Köpfe.
David Boder: Nun...nun, wie hat man die genommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also in dieser Zeit ist schon...ist gegründet worden die jüdische Kultusgemeinde. Also die jüdische Kultusgemeinde war deswegen...haben sie deswegen gemacht, deswegen gegründet, dass sie sich nicht selber mit den Juden zu beschäftigen haben sollen. Wenn sie irgend...die Polizei oder einen besonderen Auftrag von der höheren Macht bekommen haben oder selber etwas ausführen wollten, dann haben sie einfach die Kultusgemeinde [Tonband unverständlich; starkes Rauschen, kein Ton]...und gerade diese Arbeiten hat die Kultusgemeinde gemacht. Dann haben sie der Kultusgemeinde gesagt, dass man an jedem Tag so und so viele Arbeiter haben muss; haben aber nicht gesagt in welcher Weise sie es machen würden. Die haben schon gewusst, wenn man so einen Befehl an die jüdische Kultusgemeinde gibt, dann wird es auch gemacht.
David Boder: Und war die jüdische Kultusgemeinde gerecht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also, wenn ich schon jetzt auf die jüdische Kultusgemeinde eingehen soll, das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen zu früh.
David Boder: Gut, wie Sie wollen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Denn das ist nicht das Einzige, was die jüdische Kultusgemeinde gemacht hat.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ob sie gerecht waren oder nicht, das werden Sie erst später selber sehen, wenn ich meine Meinung äußere.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Jetzt kann man das noch nicht beurteilen auf der Basis, was ich Ihnen bis jetzt erzählt habe. Nun die jüdische Kultusgemeinde hat bekommen so einen Aufruf von der Polizei, da haben sie genommen die Liste, die Kartothek von jedem einen Bewohner, von jedem jüdischen Einwohner und haben dem ein Papier geschickt, dass er sich an diesem und diesem Tag, zu dieser und dieser Stunde an diesem und diesem Platz stellen soll, um diese und diese Arbeit auszuführen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Der, der viel Geld gehabt hat, der hat einen armen Juden genommen, hat ihm bezahlt für den Tag, den sie verabredet haben und der hat für ihn gearbeitet.
David Boder: Hat die Kultusgemeinde das erlaubt? Das Einer so arbeitet für den Anderen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie haben sich darum nicht gekümmert; hauptsächlich es hat sie nur interessiert, dass die Zahlen der Arbeiter stimmen sollen. Sie haben nicht nach dem Gesicht herum geschaut, nur nach der Zahl, nach der allgemeinen Zahl.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und so...die ganze Szene hat sich abgespielt in der Stadtverwaltung, dort hat man sich versammelt und dort wurden man aus...dort haben die Meister ihre Gruppen bekommen, also jeder Meister hat eine Anzahl von Juden bekommen.
David Boder: Der Meister war jüdisch?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, der Meister war deutsch. Also von Anfang an die meisten waren Polen. Und so hat man die härteste und die schlimmsten Arbeiten gemacht, die...welche niemand eigentlich zuvor zu machen...zu machen hatte. Denn vor dem Krieg waren solche Arbeiten auch zu machen, aber es waren keinen Mann dazu da, niemand hat sich für solche Sachen interessiert.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also zum Beispiel: das Erste—irgendwo ein Feld oder eine Strasse, wo es keine Häuser gibt, ganz frei. Da musste man in dem größten Frost oder beim größten Wind musste man da Schnee abschaufeln, um den, um den Weg zu reinigen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das ist das Erste. Dann hat man, als es ein bisschen wärmer war, hat man verschiedene Kanäle und verschiedene Bassins, wo es voll Leim war oder Wasser. Aber es hat keine Rolle gespielt, es war keine [unverständlich] die schwere Arbeit,...wenn man gesagt hat die Arbeit muss gemacht werden, man hat dafür einen deutschen Meister verantwortlich gemacht und der hat schon dazu gesehen, dass es...dass es geleistet wird, wie er es eigentlich will.
David Boder: Wie hat er das gemacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es waren verschiedene Meister. Es waren Einige, die nur geschrien haben, es durfte gar nicht so weit kommen, dass sie schlagen sollen. Denn es hat nur ein Wort gegen um schnell an die Schaufel...also die Schaufel zu ergreifen und arbeiten wie am besten, wie man nur am besten kann. Es waren aber auch Einige, die solche Sadisten waren, die gar nicht gesprochen haben, die haben einfach geschlagen. Und das war eigentlich ihr Leben. Und sie waren nicht als Meister eigentlich angestellt, deshalb weil sie das Geld verdienen wollen und nachher, um es aushalten zu können—einfach weil sie sich dort amüsiert haben—es war für sie das größte Vergnügen, das größte Erlebnis, dass sie jetzt jeden Juden schlagen können und mit ihnen machen, was sie wollen.
David Boder: Waren das Deutsche oder Polen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es waren Polen und auch Volksdeutsche und am Anfang hat man noch nicht so viele Deutsche bei uns gesehen.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war auch ein großer Teil von die Polen, die sich als Volksdeutsche gleich ausgegeben haben.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun, so der erste Winter ist so immer gegangen, dass man...viel...viel Zeit für die Staatsverwaltung gearbeitet hat und zwar...
David Boder: Hat man für die Arbeit bezahlt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also von Anfang an hat man überhaupt nicht bezahlt. Es war Zwangsarbeit und zwar „Lohnlos“. Man hat nicht bezahlt. Nachher aber, dann...hat man eine (1) Mark siebzig (70) pro Tag bezahlt einem Arbeiter, der acht (8) Stunden oder sogar zehn (10) Stunden auf diese Weise gearbeitet hat. Aber Sie können sich vorstellen, was man für eine (1) Mark siebzig (70) bekommen hat oder was man dafür auslegen kann.
David Boder: Wieviel hat Brot gekostet?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das kommt darauf an was für ein Brot. Wir haben bekommen pro Tag zwei hundert fünfzig (250) Gramm Brot pro Tag...haben wir bekommen.
David Boder: Pro Person.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Pro Person.
David Boder: Und das hat gekostet wie viel?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das hat gekostet, hm, hm, fünf und zwanzig (25) Drachmen, fünf und zwanzig (25) Pfennig.
David Boder: Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja das wäre schon gut, da hundert fünfzig (250) Gramm Brot genügen kann. Aber wenn man nur das Brot bekommen hat, wenn man keine Kartoffeln bekommen hat und keinen Reis und kein Fett, kann man da leben von hundert fünfzig (250) Gramm Brot täglich? Man musste es eben durchstehen und helfen. Man kann doch nicht hungern. Wenn der Mensch hungrig ist, dann macht er alles. Was machte man? Man suchte, wer so auf schwarz Brot gebracht hat oder Mehl, man hat das teurer bezahlt. Und um das teurer zu bezahlen, da muss man eben Geld haben und dafür war eine (1) Mark siebzig (70) nicht genügend.
David Boder: Nun—so, was hat man getan?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hat...man hat angefangen sich in verschiedener Weise durchzuschlagen. Einer hat gehandelt schwarz und einer hat Überstunden gearbeitet und Einer hat...hat...man hat einfach das Leben riskiert, nur um sich durchzuschlagen. Und der, der das nicht machen konnte, weil er zu wenig Mut hat oder der, der viel...der viel Angst hat, der musste ein...leider hungern. Und so sind Viele kaputt gegangen und gestorben einfach vor unseren Augen. Also es war sozusagen, im ersten Winter vom Krieg hat man noch das Schlimme, ich meine, wenn ich jetzt...wenn ich jetzt zurück schaue, dachte ich, dass im ersten Winter vom Krieg hat man noch nicht die Grausamkeit der Deutschen noch nicht so...
David Boder: Gesehen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . bemerkt. Denn man ist noch—wie gesagt, mit der Familie zu Hause, gewesen. Man hat noch manchmal Karten gespielt, man hat noch gelacht...man hat es noch nicht so...so bemerkt. Man hat noch von vor dem Krieg etwas Geld gehabt, so dass man sich doch ein wenig durchstehen konnte, aber...
David Boder: Man hat doch das Geld abgeben müssen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hat aber zum Grossteil nicht abgegeben. Denn das ist eine Sache, die man eigentlich behalten kann und im Anfang war es nicht so streng, dass man in jedes Haus suchen gegangen ist. Denn das war nicht so genau, das war eine kleine Sache, sie haben nicht gesagt, es wird raus gegeben, weil sie das Geld brauchen.
David Boder: Und?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und sie konnten so viel Geld haben, wie sie wollten. Sie haben es selbst gemacht. Aber nur deswegen, weil sie wollten die Juden wieder etwas unterdrücken mit dem Geld Abgeben. Aber es ist in erster Zeit nicht so schlimm gewesen. Der Zweck war eigentlich nicht das Geld zu nehmen, es war uns alle zu vernichten.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: So ist es durch den ersten Winter des Krieges [unverständlich]...so hat man manchmal mehr gegessen, manchmal weniger gegessen, man ist durch gekommen. Im Sommer hat man angefangen die deutschen Städte zu bombardieren. Und trotzdem, hm, hm, haben noch viele Deutsche...haben sich bereichern wollen, das die Juden [unverständlich] haben, man hat das Vermögen weg genommen und da sind sie eben nach Polen gekommen...von verschiedene, hm, Ecken Deutschlands. Sie sind gekommen und in erster Zeit war es so, dass sie in ein jüdisches Geschäft als Treuhänder eingetreten sind.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie haben das Geschäft geleitet...
David Boder: Das nennt man in Amerika Trustee.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Trustee, ja.
David Boder: Ja, sie haben das Geschäft geleitet.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie haben das Geschäft geleitet und die Firma war noch am Anfang die alte Firma. Aber es kommt doch nicht auf die Firma an, es kommt auf den, der, hm,...der davon das Geld zieht. Das waren eben die Deutschen.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber das war von einer Seite gut, dass man die Juden noch einigermaßen in den Geschäften gelassen hat und ein Mensch...
David Boder: Wie war das? Das war ein Treuhänder, aber der Jude war im Geschäft.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Richtig. Der Jude war im Geschäft. Aber, aber es hat auch Einzelfälle gegeben, wo man den Juden überhaupt raus geschmissen hat und ein Deutscher hat das Geschäft übernommen. Aber zum großen Teil...zum größten Teil kann man sagen, am Anfang sind die Juden weiter geblieben, aber der Deutsche...
David Boder: Aber der Deutsche hat verwaltet
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . aber der deutsche Verwalter, der hat das Wort gehabt.
David Boder: Und wer hat das Geld genommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Der Jud...der Deutsche hat das Geld genommen. Ich bin nicht so ganz informiert, wo das eigentlich Geld hingekommen ist. Ich weiß nur, dass die Juden nur ein Gehalt,...ein monatliches Gehalt bekommen haben...
David Boder: Das hat er bekommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das hat er bekommen.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber sie haben es auch bekommen nach Vorschriften, das heißt es war...es war überall—überhaupt...in Deutschland war es so, dass man einem Juden so und so viel gezahlt hat. Und das haben sie bekommen und das haben sie unterschrieben. Man hat es nicht so nach der Arbeit bezahlt, es war sehr formell geführt.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und es war auch für eine Sache gut, denn...denn so viele Deutsche waren nicht innen Deutsche, sondern nur mehr von außen Deutsche gewesen und [unverständlich] nicht so innerlich und wenn sie mit den Juden zusammen waren, da konnten sie sich vertragen und man hat auch...
David Boder: Hat Ihr Vater auch ein Geschäft gehabt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, wir hatten kein Geschäft.
David Boder: Was hat Ihr Vater getan?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Mein Vater hat mit...mit Essig gearbeitet.
David Boder: Er hat Essig gemacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Er hat Essig gemacht und in der Fabrik verkauft und in kleineren Geschäften.
David Boder: Und das ist weiter gegangen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, seit dem Krieg hat er nicht mehr das produziert. Wir haben es in einer Fabrik gekauft und haben es kleineren Geschäften verkauft. Aber das war nicht mehr erlaubt.
David Boder: Von zu Hause?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Von zu Hause. Wir haben es von Anfang des Krieges einige Zeit gemacht, dann hat es sich nicht mehr gelohnt. Man hat zu viel riskiert, also wir haben das aufgegeben.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, also. Soll ich Ihnen alle Einzelheiten erzählen?
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Hm, da hat es wieder so eine Zeit gegeben, man hat sichergestellt, dass man so durchkommt. Dann—im Sommer—hat es wieder geheißen, dass man Arbeiter in Deutschland braucht. Und in erster Reihe sind die Jugendlichen, das heißt von achtzehn (18) bis zirka fünfzig (50) Jahre an die Reihe gekommen.
David Boder: Haben sie gesagt bis fünfzig (50)?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja fünfzig (50), bis fünfzig (50). Die durften nach Deutschland gehen.
David Boder: Dürfen oder müssen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wir müssen! Sie durften, wenn sie nicht wollen, dann müssen!
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber man hat es wieder so gemacht, dass man die jüdische Kultusgemeinde eine Mitteilung geschickt hat, oder so gesagt hat, dass man so und so viele Arbeiter nach Deutschland, denn sie hatten doch Angst, dass so eine Sache...da könnten sie der jüdischen Kultusgemeinde nicht trauen. Und da haben sie es selber durch geführt und zwar in dieser Weise, dass sie morgens früh, das war um halb fünf (5) Uhr, haben sie eine große Zahl von Polizisten—die Schupos—geschickt in die Stadt und ihnen die Adressen, jüdische Adressen, gegeben und man hat uns einfach von den Betten geholt. Ich erinnere mich noch, als sie zu uns herein kamen—mein Vater war gerade nicht zu Hause. Er war zufälligerweise und glücklicherweise war er in Sosnowiec.
David Boder: In Sosnowiec? Sind Sie von Sosnowiec?
Abraham Kimmelmann: In Sosnowiec.
David Boder: Waren Sie nicht weit von Sosnowiec?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein zwölf (12) Kilometer.
David Boder: Oh, das war nicht weit von Bendzin?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Fünf Kilometer von Bendzin.
David Boder: Von Bendzin?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, von Dabrowa.
David Boder: Nicht weit von Myslowice.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, und nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und da kommen sie herein und deckt mir das Überbett auf und sagt: „Wie alt bist Du denn?“ Sag ich „Neunzehn hundert acht und zwanzig (1928) geboren“. „Oh“, haben sie gesagt: „Schlaf weiter!“
David Boder: Wann sind Sie geboren?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Neunzehn hundert acht und zwanzig (1928) geboren.
David Boder: Ja. Und das war in welchem Jahr?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war neunzehn hundert vierzig (1940).
David Boder: Da waren Sie zwölf (12) Jahre alt.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja.
David Boder: Und da haben sie gesagt: „Schlaf weiter!“
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, „Schlaf weiter!“ Denn damals sind solche Jungen nicht an die Reihe gekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also das war die erste...die erste—wie heißt das...hm, Razzia.
David Boder: Ja, die erste Selektion?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, das war keine Selektion, das war eine Razzia, man hat doch rund herum um die Stadt...
David Boder: Nun ja, das ist gut, wir nennen es Razzia, in russisch oblawa.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Oblawa, ja, in polnisch heißt es auch oblawa.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die Erste...damals hat das noch einen sehr schrecklichen Eindruck gemacht, denn solche Sachen war man noch nicht gewöhnt. Man hat sozusagen...ich habe...ich habe eigentlich jetzt vergessen Ihnen was zu erzählen, aber hier in der Mitte kann ich es wieder erwähnen. Dass in die ersten Zeiten, als der Krieg aus...ausbrach, evakuiert sind wir bis nach Mekhov und es war noch viel mehr Menschen, die weiter als bis Warschau bis zur Mitte von Poland evakuiert sind. Aber es hat uns nicht interessiert weiter zu gehen und wir sind nur so weit als Mekhov gekommen.
David Boder: Wer hat Sie evakuiert?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Selber sind wir...
David Boder: Sie sind selber allein weg gegangen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, wir sind geflüchtet. Es sind tausende Leute geflüchtet, weil wir alle in der Nähe der deutschen Grenze gewohnt haben.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und als die Deutschen rein kamen und wir wollten zurück, hatten wir...mussten wir laufen zu Fuß. Es war keine Bahn, es waren keine Autos, wir mussten zu Fuß laufen mit den Sachen, die wir noch mit gehabt haben.
David Boder: Und wie bald war das nachdem der Krieg angefangen hat?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war sieben (7) Tage.
David Boder: Sieben (7) Tage. Und sind Sie nach der alten Wohnung zurück gekommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Wir wollten...und nach sieben (7) Tagen als die Deutschen rein kamen, kamen wir wieder zurück, denn überall waren sie. Was konnten wir tun? Und als wir vor Swaskow waren, ein kleines Dorf auch in der Nähe von uns, hat man gehört, dass man alle Juden auf einer Brücke ins Wasser schmeißt. Und das ist die reine Wahrheit. Wenn man einen Juden gesehen hat, und damals waren die Juden kennbar, denn die Juden haben damals noch die Bärte getragen und waren auch jüdisch gekleidet, eben wie es in Polen war.
David Boder: War Ihr Vater chassidisch?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Und man hat überhaupt...oder man hat Ausweise verlangt. Wenn er ein Jude war hat man ihn entweder erschossen oder ins Wasser geschmissen. Und wir hatten noch Glück, dass wir das vorhin gehört haben und wir haben diese Krise...hm, hm,...
David Boder: Abgewartet.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . abgewartet und dann sind wir nach Hause gekommen.
David Boder: Ja. Haben Sie Ihre Wohnung gefunden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, wir haben alles gefunden, waren nicht so sehr reich, dass man womöglich Angst haben sollte.
David Boder: Nun? Ja, also.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also wir haben da, ja, ich komme jetzt wieder zurück auf die Razzia.
David Boder: [unverständlich; von 26:32 Minuten bis 27:09 ist das Tonband nur unverständlicher Lärm. Dann Stille.]
David Boder: [In English] August...Geneva, August 27, 1946, Spool 84. Eh, Abraham Kimmelmann...Abraham Kimmelmann continues the report which we started at about the 7 minute position of Spool 83.
David Boder: [In German] Also Abraham, gehen Sie mal weiter. Nun? Also Sie haben gesagt, man konnte sich für Geld, für zehn tausend (10 000) Mark auskaufen, dass man vom Lager zurück kommt, ja? Nun weiter.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und das haben nicht nur die reichen Leuten einreden können.
David Boder: Einreden können oder durchsetzen können?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also sie konnten sich das einreden und durchsetzen.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also Sie werden mich fragen, woher, woher, wir waren noch damals bei den Deutschen reiche Juden?
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Woher haben sie noch so viel überhaupt Deutsche Mark?
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also wie ich Ihnen schon gesagt habe, solange die Juden in Kontakt mit den Deutschen gekommen sind, da haben sie sich so geholfen, dass sie haben auf links haben die Ware gekauft und auch auf links verkauft.
David Boder: Den Deutschen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Den Deutschen und auch privat verkauft, denn der Mark hat keinen Wert gehabt. Die Ware ist immer in die Höhe gegangen und die Mark ist gefallen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: So vielleicht zehn tausend (10 000) Mark war damals nicht so viel.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war nur so ein Begriff. Es war nur ein Begriff von zehn tausend (10 000) Mark, es war nicht so viel. Aber...und gerade dadurch, weil man auf uns alles verkauft hat, dadurch haben manche Leute so, so erreicht, dass sie...dass sie zehnte von tausenden Mark gehabt haben, so dass sie dachten...damals haben sie gedacht, ja, wenn wir schon das Geld haben, sind wir gerettet. Denn der Mann...der Mensch konnte...er hat sich einfach das niemals vorstellen können, da hat sich niemand vorgestellt, dass es dazu kommen wird, dass das Geld und dass eine Persönlichkeit oder ein, eine Kenntnis keinen Wert haben wird. Dass man einfach alle Juden vernichten will, das hat sich damals noch niemand vorgestellt. Man hat gesagt: „Man wird einen Teil nehmen, man wird so viel nehmen, man wird eine gewisse Kapazität nehmen“. Aber später hat man gesehen, dass das alles nur so eine systematische Ordnung war.
David Boder: Was hat man gedacht, dass die Reichen oder die Intelligenten nicht gehen werden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, es hat sich nicht nur um Geld gehandelt oder wer Geld hat und eine gute Stelle gehabt hat, zum Beispiel: ein guter Fachmann oder ein guter Ingenieur oder so weiter, der den Deutschen nützlich war, den haben sie noch bis zum letzten Moment behalten.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und da er mit den Deutschen gelebt hat und die haben ihm immer wieder versprochen: „Ja, wir werden alles Menschliche für Dich tun, da haben sie gedacht, die Leute hier seien schon diese, die das alles zu bestimmen haben.
David Boder: Ja nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und es hat wieder eine Zeit gedauert so, dann hat man wieder Razzien gemacht und so weiter und so weiter. Schließlich hat sich die Polizei auch überlegt, wozu sollen sie in der Nacht auf sein und sich selber um die Juden kümmern und sie auf dem Polizeirevier zu bringen und ihnen Essen zu geben. Sie haben eine jüdische Miliz geschaffen, das heißt jüdische Ordner...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . jüdische Ordner, die über die jüdische Allgemeinheit zu sagen gehabt hat, hm, sie haben sich gekümmert über die Organisation und mit allem. Sie haben alles selber geleitet.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Jüdische Miliz war erstens, um auf den Strassen Ordnung zu halten. Zum...in erster Linie der jüdischen Kultusgemeinde zu dienen. Zum Bewachen von Allen, denn Sie wissen ja, in so einer Zeit die Menschen bewegen sich viel und man sagt, wenn Jemand etwas tut, sagt man, er ist ein schlechter Mann. Man geht nicht ein in seine Situation, ob es...ob es zu machen ist, ob er es gemacht hat, weil er will. Man sagt einfach, es ist auch kein Wunder, denn man ist eben...man ist nicht zufrieden, wenn man einen Menschen schlecht tut...man überlegt es sich. Deswegen haben sie auch die jüdische Miliz geschaffen, dass sie ein bisschen mehr [unverständlich].
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: In zweiter Linie war die jüdische Miliz, dass sie das alles übernommen haben, was die deutsche Polizei vorher machen musste. Es waren die Razzia, die haben jetzt schon die jüdische Miliz gemacht.
David Boder: Das heißt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wenn sie also eine Verordnung bekommen haben, dass so und so viele Juden nach...in ein Arbeitslager gehen müssen oder nach Auschwitz, es hat schon damals Auschwitz begonnen und wir haben über Auschwitz erzählt bekommen, dann haben sie eine Liste an die jüdische Kultusgemeinde geschickt und haben gesagt, dass diese die Liste zusammen stellen wird und sie haben das alles in bester Ordnung erledigt. Es war so eingerichtet, sie waren schon so raffiniert in einer Sache, dass wenn es zu einer Razzia gekommen ist, haben sie die Polizei, die Sonderpolizei von...von...von der Zentralleitung, von der Zentralgemeinde von Sosnowice geholt...
David Boder: Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . die das alles erledigt haben. Und zwar haben sie es so eingerichtet, dass sie jeden Mann, den sie geholt haben, hat eine jüdische Miliz unter dem Arm genommen und haben ihn geführt und extra ein ganzer Kordon ist mit gegangen, der die ganze Umgebung bewacht hat. Der Kordon war dazu da, dass es zu keiner Unruhe kommt.
David Boder: Ein jüdischer Kordon?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ein jüdischer Kordon, ja, damit es zu keiner Unruhe dazu kommt.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun—bevor es noch dazu gekommen ist...
David Boder: Und wer hat die Stelle bekommen der Miliz? Was für Leute hat man ausgewählt für den Miliz?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die Miliz ist nicht von der jüdischen Bevölkerung gewählt worden. Denn in so einer Zeit hält man nicht...nur man nimmt einfach den, den, den...der es passt.
David Boder: Und wer hat sie genommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die jüdische Kultusgemeinde hat das bestimmt. Die jüdische Kultusgemeinde hat bestimmt einen gewissen Monek Merin. Der Monek Merin, der war der Leiter vom ganzen Kreise, von der ganzen Umgebung bis Lodz. Der hat die ganze jüdische...hm,...jüdische Gemeinde verwaltet. Er war ein Jude.
David Boder: Wer hat ihn dazu bestimmt gehabt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Er war Jude, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es dazu gekommen ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Dass er sich so, so herauf gearbeitet hat. Aber er hat eine hohen Einfluss bei der Gestapo gehabt und hat überall gehabt. Er hat sein Auto gehabt, er hat seinen Chauffeur gehabt. Und er hat so ein Leben gehat, welcher ein Mensch vor dem Krieg nicht erlauben konnte. So ein Leben hat er nicht gehabt.
David Boder: Was hat ihm nachher passiert?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das weiß ich nicht. Aber seine Frau und Tochter habe ich in Buchenwald getroffen.
David Boder: Wurden die befreit?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und da schon Einer von den Deutschen bestimmt war eine jüdische Kultusgemeinde zu gründen, da hat er solche Leute herein genommen, die er noch von vor dem Krieg kannte, seine Kameraden und so weiter. Er war kein speziell intelligenter Mann, vielleicht war er ein bisschen gebildet, aber der Charakter was nicht speziell. Das hat sich nachher ausgewiesen in den Taten, die er gemacht hat und, hm, das alles was der Mann auf dem Gewissen hatte und es bis zum letzten Moment ertragen konnte, das hat...das ist ein Beweis, dass der Mensch nicht zu den...zu den Edlen gehört. Und so hat er überall...seinen besten Kameraden hat er gute Stellen gegeben, gute Posten. Und diese Kameraden haben wieder ihren Freunden, Bekannten und so weiter Protektion gegeben, und so weiter. Diese Leute haben sich, hm, hm,...in die jüdische Kultusgemeinde eingeschoben—dort haben sie gearbeitet und sie haben auch gut gearbeitet. Und das ganze Gute was für die Juden gekommen ist, in Anführungsstriche kann man sagen „von dem konnten sie gut leben“. Weil wenn eine, hm, Zuteilung für fünf tausend (5 000) Mann kommt, Essenswaren, dann kann man doch von jedem etwas runter nehmen und dann hat man viel zu viel. Und so hat eben die jüdische Kultusgemeinde gelebt. So haben sie nicht viel von Einem runter nehmen brauchen, um...um ein gutes Leben zu haben. Und mit der jüdischen Miliz war genau dasselbe. Wenn schon jüdische Beamten in der Kultusgemeinde waren, haben sie ihre Kameraden als Kandidaten auch gegeben, man hat sie nur angeschaut, ob man kräftig ist und gesund und robust und ob er sich nicht genieren würde, wenn er einen Juden auf die Strasse schleppen soll und in das Gefängnis—denn da war ein jüdisches Gefängnis auch—oder wenn er einem Juden Eine herunter hauen darf, dann soll er sich auch nicht genieren. Solche Juden, solche Leute hat man in erster Linie gesucht. Man hat auch nicht weit suchen müssen, denn solche Leute gibt es genug.
David Boder: Und was hat dem Rabbiner dieser Stadt passiert?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Der Rabbiner bei uns in der Stadt, der hat es ziemlich gut gehabt, da er noch von vor dem Krieg durch den jüdischen...durch den Kultusgemeinde-Beamten gewählt worden war. Denn die alle haben alle gehört in den [unverständlich; polnisches Wort], das war eine Arbeitsorganisation—[unverständlich; polnisches Wort]...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . und die, die haben für ihn gestimmt. Also sie haben ein bisschen [unverständlich] gehabt. Der hat...selbstverständlich moralisch, der hatte, hm, bestimmt viel gelitten. Ich kann nicht wissen welcher Massen, denn das ist seine Sache, was sich in einem selbst abspielt, das kann man nicht wissen, aber im Allgemeinen war er ziemlich gut. Er hat noch seinen Gehalt bekommen und er hat nicht so...so...von dem Krieg am Anfang so gelitten, wie die ganze Bevölkerung, die jüdische Bevölkerung.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also wie die jüdische Miliz das übernommen hat, ist es noch viel schlimmer geworden als vorher. Es war—für diese war es am schlimmsten, die kein...die keine Bekanntschaft unter der Miliz gehabt haben und das war natürlich der größte Teil der Bevölkerung. Weil ein Militant der hat seine Familie nicht brutal behandelt, er hat dazu gesehen, sie zu verschonen.
David Boder: Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie zu warnen und sie verstecken zu können, wie weit das nur in seinem Amt möglich ist. Aber im Allgemeinen war es für die Bevölkerung negativ.
David Boder: Und warum?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ein deutscher Polizist, der hat eine Adresse bekommen von einem Juden. Und das erste Mal, dass er dort hin kam, kannte er den Mann nicht, er weiß nicht wo er sich verhält und so weiter. Wenn er nur so, so formal ist, dass wenn er...wenn er einen Befehl bekommt, dann führt er es aus. Er geht hin und wenn er niemanden findet, dann kommt er wieder zurück, belegt den Rapport und damit ist Schluss. Wenn ein jüdischer Miliz Mann einen Auftrag bekommen hat, da hat er den Juden beobachtet, er hat ihn gekannt—schon vor dem Krieg und hat schon gewusst, wo...wo er ist und wo er sich verstecken kann. Und er hat ihn schneller gefunden als die Deutschen und daher war er viel schlimmer.
David Boder: Nun.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun also, dadurch schafft man noch einen grösseren, revolutionären Geist in jeder Person. Weil wenn man sagt, ein Deutscher schlagt mich, weiß ich die Deutschen...die Deutschen...ich...ich kann von ihnen nichts verlangen. Ich kann von ihnen so viel verlangen, wie ich von der ganzen Welt verlange. Das ist genau das Selbe, wenn man in einer Familie lebt und...und man hat auch Kameraden, auch Leute, die man von weitem kannte. Wenn man solche Leute um etwas bittet und sie es nicht machen, so kann man sagen, „er ist ein schlechter Mensch“, oder da kann man sagen, man kann für ihn Verständnis haben und man kann sagen „Er kann es nicht machen“. Und man kann auch sagen „Er ist ein schlechter Mann, er will mir diesen Gefallen nicht machen.“ Dagegen wenn ich von einer Schwester oder von meiner Mutter oder von einem Verwandten etwas verlange und er mir da nichts macht, da bin ich traurig und ich fühle, dass ich das Recht habe ihn zur Rede zu stellen. Und genau das Selbe war es bei uns. Wenn ein Deutscher etwas zu tun hatte, nun da wussten wir, wo wir uns verstecken und er hat uns nicht gefunden, da hat man gesagt „Gott lob, dass er uns nicht gefunden hat“. Wenn aber ein jüdischer Miliz so etwas machen wollte, da war man schon verstört und hat gesagt“ Ein Jude will dem Anderen das machen? Das ist doch...das ist doch etwas Grausames.“ Aber wir haben sich dazu auch gewöhnt. Wir waren vor der Miliz mehr auf der Hut als vor den Deutschen, oder vielleicht noch mehr. Ich will nicht...ich will Ihnen nicht viel mehr erzählen, aber ich will Ihnen nur eine kleine Geschichte erzählen, der ich selber beigewohnt habe. Es ist nur ein Beispiel, um zu sehen, für was...was...wozu das alles geführt hat. Die jüdische Miliz, die sich nicht nur als Beamten gefühlt haben, sondern ausführen das was man von ihnen verlangt und was man ihnen befohlen hat, sondern dass sich diese auch als bessere Herren gefühlt haben. Das war bei diesem Fall der Fall. In Dabrowa-Wolnitza...
David Boder: Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . war ein „Shop“, das ist so ein Werk, wo man Schuhe...Schuhe...Schuhe zusammen gearbeitet hat.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war gegründet von einem Deutschen, das war der Chef und es haben dort nur Juden gearbeitet.
David Boder: Haben die bezahlt bekommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, sie haben bezahlt bekommen, aber ich habe Ihnen schon gesagt...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . was man bekommen hat. Man hat...man hat nur gearbeitet, um noch ein bisschen zu Hause zu bleiben. Man hat doch immer gedacht, wenn man für die Wehrmacht arbeitet zum Beispiel, dass man ihn zu Hause lässt. Also ein großer Teil ist gekommen...von Bensburg gefahren. Man hat auch speziell jüdische Trams gehabt...
David Boder: Ja, jüdische, elektrische Trams.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, elektrische Trams. Man hat die bekommen von der Bahngesellschaft jüdischer Bahnen. Und jede zwei Stunden ist ein Tram gegangen, speziell für die Juden. Es durften keine Deutschen, keine Polen rein gehen, nur Juden. Und es waren jüdische Kondukteure und jüdische Miliz hat immer die Wagons kontrolliert, ob niemand etwas schmuggelt, ein Brot und so weiter. Denn es war immer so, dass...das der Unterschied auf dem Preis war von einer Stadt zu der Zweiten. Meistens in Dabrowa—das Essen war billiger als in Bensburg. Und daher haben sie immer die Trams kontrolliert, damit niemand etwas schmuggelt. Sie haben auch sonst Wachen gehabt auf dem Tram. Da war ein jüdischer Miliz Mann, der war hochgewachsen und ein starker Kerl—und es war morgens ganz früh, wenn die Arbeiter zur Arbeit fahren. Es ist verständlich, wenn es nur jede zwei (2) Stunden ein Tram gegeben hat, dass es war überfüllt. Der jüdische Miliz hat sich aber als besserer Herr gefühlt und wollte, dass man für ihn Platz machen sollte. Aber es war so gestopft, dass man auf die Treppen gestanden ist.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und was hat er gemacht? Er sagt Einem, er soll ein bisserl Platz machen. Der ist auf den Treppen gestanden und hat gesagt: „Ich kann doch nicht, es ist voll hier, wir sind sowieso schon so gepresst, wie die Heringe hier“. Der Milz hat nicht viel gesprochen, aber hat ihm eine runter gehauen. Nun der Mensch denkt nicht im ersten Moment, was für Konsequenzen es gab und man davon ziehen konnte und hat ihn wieder zurück gegeben. Der hat...der war aber viel kräftiger und er hat ihn so geschlagen, dass es sich eben nicht mehr gelohnt hat. Und nachher, der hat sich aber damit nicht begnügt und als sie nach Dabrowa kamen, nimmt er den einen Juden auf das jüdische Polizei Revier und man hat ihn so geschlagen, dass man den Mann hinterher nicht mehr erkannt hat.
David Boder: Die Juden haben das getan?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die Juden, also der, der jüdische Miliz, der Eine. Er hat ihn so geschlagen, er hat ihm blaue Augen gemacht und er war ganz geschwollen. Aber es hat sich gleich,...es sind draußen noch einige Juden gestanden. Man hat dagegen protestiert, aber was konnte man machen. Man muss nur den Mund schließen. Und der hat sich damit nicht begnügt, er ist gleich auf die Polizei in Bensburg, die jüdische Polizei gefahren und hat mich sich gebracht gleich viele Miliz und die wollten in den Shop rein und den Juden holen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber das Glück war, dass sie gleich den deutschen Chef angerufen haben; der hat einen Befehl gegeben, niemand hat das Recht da herein zu kommen. Und der Pförtner darf Niemanden rein lassen. Ds war ein Glück, sonst bin ich nicht sicher, dass wir den Juden nie mehr lebend gesehen hätten. Also, das ist nur ein Beispiel...ein Beispiel, was da alles dazu geführt hat. Ich meine, wenn man Leute nimmt und die haben eben nur diese genommen, die, die nicht sehr moralisch waren, die nicht sehr viel Gefühl gehabt haben. Sie haben nur für Leute geschaut, die nicht...nicht sehr viel gehabt haben.
David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 85, at 10 minutes. We continue last night’s interview with Abraham Kimmelmann, who wishes to be permitted to give his evaluation of events together with the enumeration of facts.
David Boder: [In German] Also Abraham fangen Sie an. Wir haben über die jüdische Polizei gesprochen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Eben damals, als ich das alles gesehen haben, habe ich angefangen zu denken, was eigentlich der Mensch ist. Ich habe gehört, ich habe damals etwas nur gewusst, Menschen geben...verschiedenartige Menschen und auch [unverständlich]. Und ich habe mich gefragt, eben ob es wirklich so ist, dass jemand von Geburt an einen Charakter...einen bestimmten Charakter hat und ob der Charakter sich jemals im Leben ändert. Ich bin aber dazu gekommen, dass der Grundcharakter sich niemals ändert. Aber die Nebensachen, die ändern das Bild. Ich habe zum Beispiel genommen, wie zum Beispiel einen Baum. Der Wurzel, der Baum ist immer eingebunden im Grund und der Grund vom Baum ist Baum. Aber der Baum geht aber nach dem Wind. Wenn der Wind blast von dieser Seite, da wollen sich die Zweige so biegen. Also so betrachte ich auch den Charakter des Menschen. Die Bedingungen schaffen, dass der Mensch seinen Charakter ein bisschen biegt und er neigt sich den Bedingungen das zu suchen. Da hat man gesehen Leute, intelligente Leute, gebildete Leute, gelernte Leute, die...von welchen man überhaupt nicht gedacht hätte, dass sie so was etwas machen können. Aber trotzdem die Bedingungen und der Nazi Terror hat dazu geführt, dass sie ganz anders geworden sind. Sie haben sich ganz anders aufgeführt, wie man eigentlich von ihnen erwartet hat. Und wie sie vielleicht überhaupt...
David Boder: Wie man nicht von sie erwartet hat.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wie man nicht von sie erwartet hat und sie selber haben vielleicht auch niemals früher gedacht, dass sie so etwas machen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich möchte noch darauf eingehen, auf das was ich im Lager gesehen habe, aber um das noch besser zu begründen, will ich auch das vermerken, dass in Dulag war genau das Selbe. Das war erst, die so was gemacht haben und manche [unverständlich] waren schlimmer als die Deutschen selber. Und kann man...kann man...wenn ich so einen Menschen beurteilen will, stelle ich mich in seine Situation. Also ich stelle mir vor, was hätte ich gemacht, wenn ich an seiner Stelle wäre. Und deshalb sage ich—ja heute kann man sagen, wenn man mir eine Frage stellt—wenn man Dich als Militär, wenn man dir angeboten wäre ein Miliz Mann zu werden, was hättest du gemacht? Es ist schwer...heute kann man sagen, wenn man nicht aufrichtig sein will, kann man sage: „Ja, ich hätte das bestimmt abgelehnt. Ich hätte mich nicht mit so einer schmutzigen Arbeit beschäftigt.“ Aber man kann niemals sicher sein, wenn es dazu gekommen wäre, dass man einfach gesagt hätte „Nein, ich will das nicht machen.“ Denn ein Mensch ist ein Mensch und wenn man...ihn vor...vor ihm mit einem Gewehr steht und man droht ihm, „wenn Du das nicht machst, verlierst Du das Leben“—ist man nicht verantwortlich für die Taten, die man macht. Und in diesem Licht muss man auch berechnen die jüdische Miliz. Es ist wahr, sie haben...sie haben Furchtbares gemacht, aber jeder Mensch, glaube ich, ist derselbe. Es gibt nur Einzelne, die den Mut haben, um das, und so einen starken Willen habe, um das nicht anzunehmen. Aber wenn man den Durchschnittsmenschen betrachtet, da ist es im Allgemeinen so, dass ihm sein Leben mehr wert ist. Wenn ich vielleicht nicht sagen soll, dass es mehr wert ist, aber er hat nicht den Mut, er hat nicht so einen starken Willen, um das abzulehnen.
David Boder: Also wollen wir jetzt zu den Fakten kommen. Was hat weiter passiert?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also.
David Boder: Sie waren noch zu Hause.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich war noch zu Hause. Ich möchte nicht mehr eingehen auf die Einzelheiten, die jetzt weiter vorgekommen sind, ich möchte so einen Überblick machen bis ich ins Lager gekommen bin. Die Razzien haben sich immer mehr vermehrt und sie haben einen immer ärgeren Charakter angenommen. Man hat immer mehr und mehr Juden genommen und schließlich einmal ist es dazu gekommen, dass man ältere Leute, Kranke und solche, die keine Beschäftigung hatten—hat man Listen, hat man Zettel dazu gegeben, dass man sie an einem Samstag, Nachmittag war das, dass sie sich in der jüdischen Synagoge erscheinen sollen. Die Synagoge, sie war schon nicht mehr eine Synagoge damals, sie war nur ein leeres Haus, später hat man sie als Pferdestall verwendet. Und damals hat es wieder so einen schlechten Eindruck gemacht, also man hat schon gedacht jetzt kommt das Ärgste, denn man hat schon gewusst, warum die Leute nach Auschwitz fahren. Die Leute, die nix machen können—Kranke, alte Leute und Kinder—da hat man gewusst, dass man diese gleich zum Tod führt. Der, der nur eine Chance hatte, der hat sich versteckt. Aber Viele hatten Angst sich sogar zu verstecken. Soweit waren die Leute von...von der Angst übernommen, dass sie sogar wussten, dass sie in den Tod gehen, aber sie hatten Angst sich zu verstecken.
David Boder: Sie hatten Angst sich zu verstecken?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie hatten Angst—sie wussten wohl, dass sie auf den Tod gehen.
David Boder: Ah so, aber warum hatten sie Angst sich zu verstecken?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das kann man nicht erklären, es ist eine Gefühlssache von einem Menschen, welche man nicht übergehen kann...
David Boder: Was haben sie mit den Leuten gemacht, die man gefunden hat, wenn sie sich versteckt haben?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es kommt darauf an. Viele hat man erschossen und viele hat man wieder auf den Platz genommen und man hat sie nach Auschwitz geführt.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war erstens und zweitens hat man die Leute so „vermasst“ sozusagen, das heißt, es sind...man hat...man hat die jüdische...man hat den jüdischen Beamten gesagt, dass sie ein bisschen die Bevölkerung beruhigen sollen und sie sollen nicht sagen, dass sie nach Auschwitz gehen.
David Boder: Wieso?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, man hat sie betrogen. Man hat gesagt, sie kommen an einen Ort, wo sie leichte Beschäftigung haben werden, die je nach dem wie er die Arbeiten ausführen kann, so werden sie interniert während des Krieges sein. Denn...denn von einer Seite wollten sie, dass...dass es ein bisschen ruhiger wäre. Und das hat auch dazu geführt, dass sich viele Leute nicht versteckt haben. Da haben sie schon gedacht auch, ich habe jetzt schon das Leben verloren; so vielleicht kann ich doch den Krieg überleben. Und so...damals an diesem Sonntag war der erste Transport...der erste Transport ist abgegangen nach Auschwitz. Von diesen Leuten hat man keine Nachrichten mehr und ich glaube kaum, dass noch jemand von diesen Leuten lebt.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Dann hat man wieder...dann hat man wieder...dann war es so; hat man zwei Organisationen, zwei deutsche Organisationen, die den ganzen...sich mit der ganzen jüdischen Bevölkerung beschäftigt haben. Und zwar—Eine hat geheißen die Sonderbeauftragung, Sonderauftrag und die Andere die Gestapo. In der Ersten kamen die Alten, die Kranken, wie ich schon vorher erwähnt habe. Aber da diese ausgewählt haben, sind sie auf diese Idee gefallen. Sie haben einfach jeden Mann, der nur eine Strafe oder etwas einmal gehabt hat—das heißt, wenn er auf der Strasse durchgekommen ist—nicht nach den Regeln, die für die Juden bestimmt waren, da musste man Strafe bezahlen. Wenn er, zum Beispiel, das Geld nicht an sich gehabt hat, dann ist ein Protokoll geschrieben worden und dieses Protokoll ist auf das Polizeipräsidium gegangen. Von dort aus ist eine Liste an die jüdische Kultusgemeinde geschickt worden, dass die Leute Verbrecher seien. Und an dem musste man unterschreiben, dass sie als Verbrecher nach Auschwitz gehen. Solche...so hat man die Leute...solche Tricks hat man angewendet. Die Leute einfach schikaniert sozusagen.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun hat man ja nicht gewusst, wie man sich aufzuführen hat, also das Beste war schon, also das Beste von dem Schlechten, wenn man es sagt...wenn es hat geheißen, man muss zu Hause bleiben. Man darf sich nicht auf der Strasse zeigen. Wie man das nun nicht gemacht hat, so war es schlimm. Denn wenn man etwas finden will, dann kann man es immer finden. Da hat man gesagt, der David Stern ist nicht gerade angenäht oder ein Eck ist aufgetrennt und das...und da hat man den schon als Verbrecher betrachtet und nach Auschwitz geschickt. Schließlich hat der Sonderauftrag auch gesehen, dass...dass sie werden gleich nichts zu tun haben. Sie haben sich dann auch darum gekümmert, dass sie Arbeiter haben—jüdische Arbeiter haben sollen, so dass sie nicht zurück nach Deutschland und in den Krieg gehen müssen...gehen sollen. Das wäre passiert, wenn sie alle nach Auschwitz geschickt hätten. Aber diese hat gehabt—der Sonderauftrag hat gemacht Arbeitslager [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Also wenn man nachher Nachrichten von denen allen gehabt hat, so war es sehr schlimm und es sind gleich viele Leute nur von Hunger...hat man noch gehört, dass sie leben. Aber sonst sind alle kaputt gegangen. Und ich hatte damals Glück. Zwei Tage bevor die Razzia war, wurde ich in einem Metall...in einem Metallwerk aufgenommen. Also es hat damals geheißen „auf Probe“, ob ich mich für die Arbeit eigne. Ich wollte damals arbeiten und es gibt keine Lehre, man musste leisten. Es gibt nicht zu lernen, man muss leisten.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war ein Rüstungsbetrieb. Man hat mich damals aufgenommen und hat mir eine Bescheinigung gegeben, dass ich bin hier zur Probe aufgenommen. Und auf diese Bescheinigung hat man damals frei gelassen, da das der Betrieb von einem Deutschen war. Also mir war zugeteilt eine blaue Karte, das heißt eine Bescheinigung, dass ich bei Deutschen beschäftigt bin. Diese Personen sind zu Hause geblieben und man hat zu dieser Zeit gesagt, dass sie auch zu Hause bleiben. Und ich war glücklich, dass ich in so einem Betreib aufgenommen wurde. Dann haben die rosa Karten auch erst gefehlt und man hat alles nach Deutschland geschickt und dann kamen die Anderen wieder an die Reihe. Da hat man genommen solche Leute, die trotzdem dass sie bei Deutschen beschäftigt waren, aber es waren keine Rüstungsindustrie, sondern zum Beispiel, ein großes Geschäft, die nur für so Privatunternehmen und so weiter...die sind wir an die Reihe gekommen, man aber keine Razzia gemacht, sondern man hat gemacht in einem bestimmten Platz—das war...hm, dort war in einem Waisenheim, das war der Sammelpunkt, dort musste jeder Chef, der deutsche Chef mit seinen Arbeitern kommen und die Kommission, die von dem Sonderauftrag aufgestellt wurde, die hat das untersucht und jeder Chef musste einen gewissen Prozentsatz seiner Arbeiter abgeben, um sie nach Deutschland zu schicken. Ich glücklicherweise bin damals gerade sehr gut durch, da ich in einem Betrieb war, der ein Rüstungsbetrieb war. Und er hatte nicht mehr als einen Juden, das heißt mich, und das hat nur einige Minuten gedauert und ich gleich befreit worden. So Sie können sich vorstellen, meine Mutter war damals überglücklich, wie sie gehört hat, dass es mir so leicht war. Und der Chef sagte mir so damals: „Ja, Abraham, Du brauchst keine Angst zu haben, so lange Du bei der Firma Walter Hefke arbeiten wirst—die Firma hat so geheißen Walter Hefke—brauchst Du keine Angst zu haben, dass Du deportiert wirst. Wir haben einen guten Betrieb und Du bist ein guter Arbeiter und ich werde Dich immer gut behandeln.“ Nun ein Mensch ist ein Mensch, überhaupt, wenn man sich in einer schlechte Situation befindet und jedes gute Wort, was man von einem Menschen hört, ist etwas was man dran glaubt. Das gehört auch so zu den Eigenschaften von den Menschen. Ich glaube an das Wort.
David Boder: Ja, das stimmt!
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und ich habe noch damals, das war schon neunzehn hundert zwei und vierzig (1942), ich habe damals weiter in dem Rüstungsbetrieb gearbeitet. Ich habe mich bemüht am meisten zu leisten und ich dachte immer, das wird mir helfen, das ich zu Hause bleiben werde. Und der erste Transport von den blauen Karten ist da nach Deutschland abgefahren. Es hat sich alles ein bisschen beruhigt.
David Boder: Wo war in dieser Zeit Ihr Vater?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Der Vater war noch damals zu Hause. Er war krank.
David Boder: Was hat er getan?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Er hat nichts getan. Er war krank. Aber da meine Mutter und meine Schwester und ich beschäftigt waren, das ist die Mehrheit der Familie, da hat man ihm erlaubt zu Hause zu bleiben.
David Boder: Mit was war Ihre Mutter beschäftigt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Meine Mutter ist wieder aufgenommen worden in einem Rüstungsshop, der hat geheißen...ich habe den Namen vergessen.
David Boder: Was hat sie dort getan?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie haben dort an Uniformen für die Wehrmacht gearbeitet.
David Boder: Aha! Und die Schwester?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und meine Schwester auch.
David Boder: Wie alt war Ihre Schwester?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Meine Schwester war...geboren acht und zwanzig (28)...war damals dreizehn (13) Jahre alt, nein vierzehn (14) Jahre, ein Jahr älter als ich. Nun diese Sache hat sich wieder geregelt und man hat sich wieder zu den Mädchen genommen. Denn bis damals waren es wegen den Mädchen still. Man hat noch keine Mädchen in Arbeitslager geschickt.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und dann haben sie begonnen, sie haben gedacht junge Mädels können auch arbeiten und es ist einmal ein Befehl ausgegeben worden, dass alle Mädels von sechzehn (16) bis fünf und zwanzig (25) Jahren—also die haben sich auf der Bundesgemeinde stellen müssen zur Untersuchung, ob sie gesund genug sind, um da in ein Arbeitslager zu kommen. Also damals hat man noch auf den Gesundheitszustand geschaut und die, die nicht ganz gesund waren, denen haben sie gesagt, sie können noch zu Hause bleiben und arbeiten. Aber nur unter der Bedingung, dass sie weiter arbeiten. Es hat...es hat sich auch niemand von der Arbeit gedrückt. Ob er es gewollt hat oder nicht, es musste jeder arbeiten, um...um eben zu Hause zu bleiben. Und damals hat dieser Shop, wo meine Mutter und Schwester gearbeitet haben, der hat schon einige Zeit existiert, aber es haben nicht viel Mädels gearbeitet. Da mein Cousin den ganzen Shop organisiert hat und er hat bei ihnen gleich als erstes meine Schwester aufgenommen. Und auf diese Weise ist sie zu Hause geblieben.
David Boder: Was für ein Shop war das?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Der selbe Shop von dem Wehrmachtsbetrieb, wo man die Wehrmachtsuniformen...
David Boder: Bearbeitet hat.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . bearbeitet hat. Sie ist zu Hause geblieben, denn einige hundert Mädel sind damals nach Grünberg gefahren. Grünberg das war ein Frauenlager. Von dort habe ich schon von Vielen gehört, sie sind dort gestorben. Im allgemeinen sind Frauen nicht gewöhnt an so eine Arbeit und ein Mädel kann nicht so viel aushalten, wie ein Mann und sie können sich nicht fügen diesen Bedingungen.
David Boder: Was für ein Lager war das?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also ich kann ich nicht genau sagen, was für eine Arbeit, sie haben in Werke gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Was die produziert haben ist für mich nicht ganz klar. Also wir hatten noch ziemlich Glück, wir sind immer...immer von den Razzias zu Hause geblieben, weil wir die guten Karten gehabt haben. Wir haben auch immer wieder gesagt, ja, vielleicht wird es so bleiben bis zum Kriegsende. Vielleicht gelingt es doch, dass wir zusammen bleiben. Eines Tages, das war an Shibur, dem jüdischen Feiertag Shibur, es war nachts—es war vielleicht zwölf Uhr, da ist die jüdische Miliz gekommen. Sie haben [unverständlich]...dann haben sie meinen Vater aus dem Bett geholt. Und ich habe damals am Morgen gehört, dass die Kultusgemeinde in Dabrowa haben sie ihn zur polnischen Polizei im weißen Haus in Bensburg geführt. Von dort habe ich ihn durch das Fenster gesehen und ich habe ein paar Worte mit ihm gesprochen. Dann ist ein SS Mann gekommen und wir durften schon nicht mehr dort stehen, sonst hätte man uns zur Arbeit geholt.
David Boder: Zum arbeiten?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und im Keller ist es ja so auch...
David Boder: Im Keller?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . wenn man in den Keller gegangen ist, da hat man morgens keine Kräfte zu arbeiten.
David Boder: Waren die Keller versiegelt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, die Keller waren versteckt. Wir hatten das Zutritt nur von dem Zimmer.
David Boder: Aber warum hat man morgens nicht arbeiten können?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Stellen Sie sich vor einen Keller, was für ein Keller war das? Der war entweder aus Ton oder aus Sand und wir hatten dort doch gar nichts. Wir durften die Betten vom Zimmer doch nicht raus nehmen, sonst hätte man gleich gesehen, dass da etwas vorkommt.
David Boder: Wer hat diese Keller gebaut? War das ein alter Keller?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, das war ein alter Keller noch von bevor dem Krieg. Aber man hat es so versteckt. Man hat Decken drauf gelegt, dass sie es nicht merken sollten.
David Boder: War der Keller unter dem Boden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, unter dem Boden. Aber die waren schon so raffiniert, die haben versucht, ob es hohl ist unter dem Boden. Es war kein besonderes gutes Versteck, aber der Mensch denkt immer—vielleicht doch, vielleicht doch. Es war kein besonderes Versteck. Es gab manche Leute, die spezielle Keller gebaut haben. Solche Keller, die richtig versteckt waren, aber wir konnten uns das nicht leisten. Also...so ist wiederum eine Zeit vorbei gegangen mit diesen allen Sachen. Schließlich bedeutet das Leben nichts. Man ist einfach pessimistisch und man glaubt schon niemals, dass es einmal besser gehen wird. Aber man muss, wenn man auch nicht will, man lebt automatisch. Man geht automatisch zur Arbeit, man isst automatisch...ohne dass der Mensch selber will. Bei mir besonders war es so, weil ich habe es noch relativ gut gehabt. Ich bin damals auch an die Reihe gekommen, man hat schon nach Leuten wie ich gesehen. Ich habe es—ich weiß nicht—von irgend einer Quelle habe ich erfahren, dass es in einer Nacht eine Razzia geben wird in Dabrowa und ich habe es dem Chef erzählt.
David Boder: Ihrem eigenen Chef?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Der Chef war ein SA Mann, ein großer Antisemit. Wenn er einen Juden auf der Strasse gesehen hat, hat er ihn totgeschlagen. Und ich hatte Glück, ich habe sehr gut gearbeitet und mich hat er gern bevorzugt. So war es gleich am Anfang.
David Boder: Was war Ihr Chef—ein SA Mann?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja.
David Boder: [In English] Geneva, August the 28th, 1946 at the ORT Shops. Abraham Kimmelmann reporting from Spool...from Spool 84 and 85.
David Boder: [In German] Also, Herr Kimmelmann, Sie sagten Ihr Chef war ein SA Mann, der sehr schlecht zu die Juden war, der aber sehr nett zu Ihnen war.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja.
David Boder: Nun weiter.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und wie ich ihm erzählt habe, dass die Gefahr besteht, dass man mich eines Tages davon schleppt, hat er mir gesagt, dass ich nachts kommen soll und am Tag schlafen, denn meistens waren die Razzias, wie ich Ihnen erzählt habe, in der Nacht. Und das ist mir auch gelungen, denn eines Tages, wo ich um 6 Uhr früh nach Hause kam, erzählte man mir, dass man mich gesucht hat. Und ich...ich war damals ganz benommen davon. Und mein Blut [unverständlich], denn es handelt sich nicht um mich alleine. Ich war immer bereit schwer zu arbeiten, ich war immer mutig und habe mir immer das Schlechteste vorgestellt, weil man sich immer das Schlechte vorstellt, so ist es viel leichter auszuhalten, wenn einem das Gegenteil passiert. Aber das Schlimmste war für mich, dass ich mich von meiner Mutter und Schwester trennen sollte. Und das hat mich bewahrt von allem. Ich war bereit alles zu machen, denn ich habe gewusst dass meine Mutter wird nicht die Trennung überleben.
David Boder: Hat sie sich das denn nicht gedacht, wenn sie die Dinge gesehen hat? Man hat ja schon den Vater weggenommen und sie hat es überlebt.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das ist keine logische Frage. Ich habe Ihnen schon gesagt, man gewöhnt sich an Sachen, gut und schlecht, vor allem wenn man das selbe Schlechte oft genug sieht. Ich habe noch nie so was Schlechtes mitgemacht [unverständlich sehr schlechter Ton, Rauschen im Tonband]. Ich war immer zusammen mit meiner Mutter. Die Trennung von ihr kann nur einmal passieren und jetzt habe ich große Angst [unverständlich]. Man hat mich drei (3) Mal gesucht.
David Boder: Und nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Drei Mal habe ich mich versteckt. Ich habe immer nachts gearbeitet. Und wenn ich bin zur Arbeit gegangen, man hat mich drei Mal gesucht. Zum dritten Mal als ich nach Hause kam, sah ich die Tür war aufgebrochen, die Betten umgekehrt, sie haben überall gesucht.
David Boder: Hat nicht Ihre Mutter gesagt, wo Sie waren?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, entschuldigen Sie, meine Mutter und meine Schwester haben auch in der Nacht gearbeitet. Sie hatten keine Angst, sie haben sich nicht versteckt, denn damals ist ihr Shop noch nicht an die Reihe gekommen. Es war so angeordnet im Shop, dass sie zwei (2) Schichten gehabt haben, das heißt eine Schicht am Tag und eine Schicht in der Nacht. Jede zwölf Stunden, so hat man jede Woche die Gruppen wechseln können. Es hat es nicht gegeben, dass eine Gruppe immer am Tag gearbeitet hat und die Andere in der Nacht—man hat immer gewechselt. Und damals waren meine Mutter und meine Schwester waren auch nachts in der Arbeit.
David Boder: So Sie haben gefunden, dass alles umgedreht war?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja und ich habe nur gewartet bis meine Mutter nach Hause kam...gekommen ist und bin wieder in die Fabrik zurück. Ich war dann dort eine ganze Woche. Ich habe eine Tante in Bensburg, bei der habe ich gegessen und ich habe in der Fabrik geschlafen und bin nicht nach Hause gekommen. Dann hat es sich wieder ein bisschen beruhigt und man hat nicht erzählt, man hat nichts gehört und niemand hat etwas gesagt. Bei Leuten ist es so. Man erzählt—man erzählt immer etwas und dieses „Etwas“ macht immer Angst. Es war aber eine ruhige Zeit und es ist niemand mit Geschichten gekommen und ich bin wieder nach Hause und habe zu Hause geschlafen. [Eine Unterbrechung]
David Boder: Ja, Sie haben dann in dem Shop geschlafen und bei der Tante gegessen...
David Boder: [In English] We are having quite a bit of interruptions here.
David Boder: [In German] Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wenn es sich beruhigt hat, bin ich wieder nach Hause gekommen. Eines Abends, die Schwester ist gerade zur Nachtschicht gegangen, das war um sieben (7) Uhr ist sie zur Nachtschicht gegangen und bis neun (9) Uhr konnten die Juden raus gehen. Kommt sie fünf (5) vor neun (9) kommt sie vom Laden wieder nach Hause. Ich war schon im Bett und sagt mir, sie hat gehört es kommt wieder ein Razzia und ich muss mich verstecken. Alle solche Jungen, die so alt waren wie ich und mit den gleichen Karten, die ich habe. Ich habe nicht lange gedacht, ich habe angezogen, was mir gerade in die Hand gekommen ist. Ich bin zu einem Kameraden rauf in so einen Boden und wir haben uns versteckt in einem Heuboden hinter einem hohen Stapel. Es war [unverständlich] und wir haben dort geschlafen. Es war Winter und es war kalt, Sie können sich vorstellen, dass wir nicht schlafen konnten vor Kälte, aber die Nacht ist auch vorbei gegangen. Also ich erzähle Ihnen nur das, um ein Beispiel zu geben. Um eine Übersicht zu geben mit was für Schrecken wir gelebt haben. Sie waren niemals sicher...nicht in dem Moment, nicht in der Stunde. Wir haben uns niemals vollkommen zu Hause gefühlt, es war immer der Schreck, dass ein SS Mann oder eine Gestapo herein kommen kann oder dass ein jüdischer Miliz dich wegschleppen kann.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Dann ist wieder eine Zeit vergangen; ich habe gearbeitet und Geld verdient und eines Tage höre ich wieder, dass es wieder vorkommen wird. Und ich bin wieder zu der Nachtschicht und am Tag schlafe ich. Die Mutter hat da gerade auch nachts gearbeitet. Mein Schwester war auf der Tagschicht und wir beide haben fest geschlafen.
David Boder: Wo sind Sie schlafen gegangen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Zu Hause, weil am Tag war es nicht so gefährlich zu Hause zu schlafen. Es war zwölf Uhr mittags und man hat an das Haus geklopft. Ich habe einen sehr harten Schlaf, ich habe nichts gehört. Meine Mutter war auch sehr müde von der Arbeit und sie hat auch geschlafen. Und dann hat sie—sie hat aber gedacht sie träumt—hat sie gedacht, dass jemand geklopft hat. Und bei uns war es so, da sind immer die Kunden gekommen, weil meine Mutter hat auch zu Hause arbeiten müssen, denn von dem Lohn, was man bekommen hat, hat man kein Brot zu kaufen gehabt.
David Boder: Was war sie—eine Schneiderin?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, sie war eine Miedermacherin, eine Miedermacherin.
David Boder: Was ist eine Miedermacherin?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Korsett—Korsettmacherin.
David Boder: Wer in dieser Zeit hat ein Korsett getragen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Damals war es so. Es war schon...es war schon ein Ghetto, das heißt, die Juden müssen konzentriert wohnen auf einem kleinen Gebiet, aber sie durften nicht auf die Strassen gehen, wo Nichtjuden gelebt haben.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber die Polen konnten rein gehen ins Ghetto. Sie hat für Christen gearbeitet. Das war nicht erlaubt für Christen zu arbeiten.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber die Polen, für die war es erlaubt, die durften spazieren durch diese Strassen und daher konnte man für sie arbeiten auch. Also während ich Ihnen alles erzähle, werde ich Ihnen auch erzählen, wie die Arbeit vor sich ging. Wenn meine Mutter tags gearbeitet hat, da ist sie nach Hause um fünf (5) Uhr gekommen und dann hat sie bis eins (1), zwei (2) Uhr in der Nacht gearbeitet. Wenn sie die Arbeit fertig gehabt hat, dann hat sie die Maschine versteckt, weil wir durften keine Nähmaschine haben. Die Maschinen mussten abgegeben werden. Aber sie hat genäht und von der Maschine war wieder abhängig unser Leben. Wenn wir nichts zu essen haben, müssen wir sowieso sterben. Das Risiko mussten wir eingehen, ob wir wollten oder nicht. Nach der Arbeit haben wir die Maschine im Boden oder im Keller versteckt. . Und damals hat meine Mutter auch gedacht, es ist vielleicht ein Kunde, der kommt und etwas abholen will oder etwas bestellen...und wir wollten doch etwas verdienen...und da hat sie schnell die Tür aufgemacht und gefragt: „Wer ist da?“ aber sie hat da niemanden gesehen. Aber der Polizist, der schon draußen war, hat gehört eine Stimme und er war froh, dass er jemanden getroffen hat und er kommt herein...
David Boder: War das ein jüdischer Polizist?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, das war ein deutscher Polizei...Polizist. Und ich werde Ihnen sagen, warum eigentlich die Polizei gekommen ist. Er kommt herein und fragt für mich, wo Abraham Kimmelmann wohnt. Und meine Mutter war schon [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Sie hat schon gewusst, was passieren wird und dass die letzte Minute gekommen ist—die entscheidende Minute. Und dann hat er gesagt, wo ist er—„Das bin ich“ und er hat gesagt, ich soll mich sofort anziehen. Ich hatte meine Arbeitskleider noch am Stuhl, die voll Fett waren, denn ich habe an einer Stanzpressmaschine gearbeitet immer mit Öl, sehr schmutzig, nur zur der Arbeit. Sonst konnte man die nicht tragen. Man wird ganz ölig und schmutzig von dem schmutzigen Öl. Ich wollte mir was anderes anziehen, weil ich wusste, dass ich schon nicht mehr nach Hause nicht komme, aber er hat es nicht erlaubt. Ich soll das anziehen und ich soll mit ihm kommen. Und während ich mich angezogen habe, hat er was Anderes gemacht und das war, er hat gesucht, ob wir nicht etwas Lebensmittel haben. Denn die waren so raffiniert, die haben gewusst, dass wir nur die eine Karte bekommen, die uns das Minimale gibt zum Leben. Es war, wie man sagt, nicht zum Leben und nicht zum Sterben. Und wenn sie etwas mehr Speisen oder irgendwelche Lebensmittel gefunden habe, dann haben sie sofort wissen wollen, wieso wir das haben. Das hat man als Grund gegeben Einem zu bestrafen oder jemanden als Verbrecher zu betrachten und dann haben sie wieder einen Grund gehabt, jemanden nach Auschwitz zu schicken. Er hat Bohnen gefunden in unserem Haus und da hat meine Mutter erklärt, dass wir haben einige Wochen keine Bohnen gegessen haben und wir haben das gesammelt, um nachher ein richtiges Mahl zu kochen. Ich weiß nicht, was nachher passiert hat, vielleicht hat er es aufgeschrieben oder nicht, denn ich war damals ganz närrisch. Ich habe nicht an solche Dinge gedacht, wir haben nur gewusst, dass jetzt die Zeit gekommen ist, wo ich meine Mutter nicht mehr sehen werde. Ich habe gleich gewusst, dass ich nicht mehr zurück komme und als ich fertig war mit dem Anziehen, sagte er, ich soll mit kommen und wie wir gegangen sind hat meine Mutter angefangen zu schreien; also das war etwas Furchtbares. Ein Mensch, der nichts über diese Sahen weiß und eine Frau so schreien hört, der denkt sie ist einfach verrückt. Und es ist kein Wunder, wenn man so hysterisches Schreien hört. Aber wenn...wenn man es sich auch nicht vorstellen kann, sollte man sich das zu Gewissen nehmen, was das ist, wenn man ein Kind von der Mutter weg reisst und man genau weiß, dass man sein Kind nicht mehr sehen wird. Das ist nicht zu vergleichen damit, wenn ein Kind stirbt, wenn es krank ist und stirbt im eigenen Bett. Das ist ganz anders als wenn man weiß, das das Kind vollkommen gesund ist und mit der Mutter zusammen ist und dann...auf einmal...sozusagen in den Tod geschickt wird. [unverständlich; spricht zu schnell und Tonband rauscht] Und wenn ich heute lebe, weiß ich bis heute nicht, wie ich eigentlich...von dem allen gerettet worden war. Aber damals war ich...war ich überzeugt, dass ich auf den Tod gehe. Und meine Mutter auch. So soll man sich nicht wundern, dass meine Mutter so geschrien hat. Der hat es von draußen noch gehört und ich weiß nicht, wie das...wie er das übernommen hat—aber es hat einen Eindruck auf ihn gemacht. Und er ist wieder mit mir reingekommen und hat meine Mutter gefragt, warum sie so geschrien hat. Aber sie hatte Angst zu sagen, warum sie schreit.
David Boder: War das ein SS Mann?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, das war ein Schupo, es war kein SS Mann—nur ein Schupo, ein einfacher Polizist.
David Boder: Ein Deutscher?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, ein Deutscher. Ich werde Ihnen auch erzählen, wie er ist dahin gekommen. Und er hat die Mutter beruhigt, dass ich wieder komme, dass das nur eine Formalität wäre, man muss etwas nachschauen, man muss mich sehen. Und das hat ein bisschen die Mutter beruhigt, weil da gibt es einen Spruch: Wenn man im Wasser ist und ertrinkt und man sieht ein Stroh...
David Boder: Wenn man ertrinkt...
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . wenn man ertrinkt, dann greift man nach einem Stroh. Und sie hat diese Worte gehört von dem Deutschen, von dem sie konnte gar nichts erwarten, und trotzdem hat sie das ein bisschen getröstet, weil sie geglaubt hat, vielleicht sagt er ihr doch die Wahrheit. Sie hat sich ein bisschen beruhigt...ich habe gewusst, dass es nicht lange dauern wird. Es war eine Sache, die sich in ein paar Stunden ent...ent...
David Boder: Entscheiden.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . entscheiden kann—was kann man da machen? Er hat sich auf sein Fahrrad drauf gesetzt und hat mir gesagt, ich muss daneben laufen. Je schneller ich gelaufen bin, desto schneller hat er sein Fahrrad gefahren.
David Boder: Er ist auf dem Fahrrag gesessen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie nicht weglaufen können von ihm?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja...weglaufen, aber er hatte da so eine Waffe, die mich von Weitem töten konnte, Sie wissen ja, dass sie alle Gewehre getragen haben. Und sie haben nur gewartet auf den Moment eine Gelegenheit auszunützen, dass sie einen Juden erschießen konnten. Das habe ich gerade nicht gewollt. Auch wenn ich gewollt hätte, ich habe Ihnen schon gesagt, man hat nicht den Mut—man hat nicht den Mut. Man hat immer die Hoffnung—vielleicht doch...vielleicht wird doch ein Wunder geschehen. Man denkt nur an eines, man denkt nur an ein Ding. Ich bin gelaufen und ich habe schon keine Kraft mehr gehabt. Wenn ich zur Polizeirevier gekommen bin, das war ungefähr ein ein halb (1 ½ ) Kilometer von uns, da bin ich gerannt. Er war auf dem Fahrrad und hat mir gesagt, ich soll das Fahrrad abstellen. Ich war das erste Mal auf dem Polizeirevier. Ich habe nicht gewusst, wo ich soll das Fahrrad abstellen und er hat mich sofort eine Ohrfeige gegeben und dann noch eine.
David Boder: War das der selbe Mann, der Ihre Mutter beruhigt hat?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, der selbe Mann, der meine Mutter beruhigt ist. Und er hat das Fahrrad dann dahin gestellt und hat mich in das Polizeirevier rein geführt. Wie ich rein kam, sind sie da gesessen diese Herren—Einer hat geraucht eine Zigarette, wie ich Ihnen schon gesagt habe, es war zwölf (12) Uhr. Also ich bin zur Mittagszeit gekommen und sie hatten—wie soll ich sagen Mittagszeit bis zwei (2) Uhr. Die Polizisten sind herein gekommen für Briefe und Pakete und ich stehe da. Dann kommt Einer herein und schaut mich so an und sah den David Stern und da hat er gleich gewusst, dass ich Jude bin. Und es hat ihm nicht gefallen , dass ich mein Gesicht zu ihm gedreht habe. Dann hat er mich in einen Winkel gestellt—mit dem Gesicht zu der Wand und Hände nach unten, genau wie ein...
David Boder: Verbrecher?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . ja, wie ein Verbrecher, stimmt. Und ich durfte mich nicht rühren. Wenn ich nur eine kleine Bewegung gemacht habe, habe ich eine Ohrfeige bekommen oder einen Fußtritt mit einem Schuh. So bin ich ein ein halb (1 ½ ) Stunden gestanden und dann haben sie zwei (2) polnische Frauen herein geführt in das Revier, das waren solche die schwarz gehandelt haben. Die haben Eier und Butter und verschiedene Sachen mitgebracht—Essenwaren—und mit denen zusammen sind nach Bensburg, also auf das untere Polizeirevier.
David Boder: Welches Polizeirevier?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das untere Polizeirevier. Es war—das Hauptrevier war in Sosnowice. Auf dem Tram, da haben sie noch so einen Trick gemacht. Sie wollten mich nicht führen in einfacher Weise und weil sie sich nicht geniert haben, aber sie haben es noch besser gemacht. Sie haben genommen alle Pakete, die die zwei (2) Frauen gebracht haben und haben sie mir zum Tragen gegeben, dass die Leute meinen sollen, ich hab etwas geschmuggelt, ich habe schwarz gehandelt. Und deswegen haben sie mich verhaftet. Ich war trotz allem...ich mich geschämt und zweitens waren es ziemlich schwere Pakete, die die zwei (2) Frauen getragen haben [unverständlich]. Als wir dorthin kamen, hat man mir die Pakete abgenommen und man hat mich nicht Jemandem vorgestellt, sondern gleich in einen Keller. Dort waren viele hundert Juden versammelt, also einige hundert Juden und wir waren dort einige Stunden. Jetzt möchte ich zurück gehen und erklären, wie es kommt eigentlich dazu, dass sie mich in der Mittagszeit zu Hause abgeholt haben und warum. Gerade der Schupo...
David Boder: Was ist ein Schupo?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ein Schupo, das habe ich Ihnen schon gesagt, ist ein Polizist, ein Wachmann. Und es war so: man hat mich damals in der Nacht gesucht, aber es war niemand...Aber mich hat man gesucht in Bensburg, weil ich war registriert, weil ich in Bensburg arbeite. Aber da ich in Bensburg nicht gewohnt hab, haben sie mich in Bensburg nicht gefunden, weil es ist ihnen nicht eingefallen, dass ich nachts im Werk schlafe. Sie haben nur solche genommen, die zu Hause waren, die geschlafen haben. Als aber der Polizist zum Polizeipräsident...
David Boder: Zum was? Wen haben sie genommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . die, die zu Hause geschlafen sind. Also die Polizisten, die Schupos zum Polizeipräsidenten kamen und ich dazwischen nicht war, so haben sie nachgedacht, wo ich sein kann und sie haben in den [unverständlich] nachgeschaut und haben gesehen , dass ich gar nicht in Bensburg wohne—ich wohne in Dabrowa. Da haben sie schnell telefonisch das Polizeirevier in Dabrowa angerufen und man hat mich tagsüber zu Hause gesucht. Und ich hab damals gerade Pech gehabt, denn ich habe geschlafen. Und das war, was passiert ist, denn sonst wäre ich noch geblieben ein Zeit zu Hause...bis zur allgemeinen Deportation—bis es Juden-frei war. Ja, das Schicksal lenkt die Menschen und man kann nichts dagegen tun. Und dann bis ich damals auf den Polizeirevier ins Bensburg gewesen—zusammen mit allen Juden. Sie haben uns nicht zu essen gegeben und auch gar nicht raus gelassen, wenn man zur Toilette musste. Und abend haben sie ein Polizei Kordon gebracht, das uns nach Sosnowice bringen sollte. In Sosnowice war ein...Durchgangslager, in der Abkürzung so hat man es genannt Dulag, ein Durchgangslager. Alle die nach Deutschland gefahren wurden, das ist in ein Arbeitslager, wurden ins Dulag geschickt. Andererseits die nach Auschwitz gegangen sind, sind nach Bensburg gegangen in das Waisenhaus Sirotinez. Da ich noch gesund war und jung, haben sie mich zur Arbeit genommen und ich bin eben ins Dulag gekommen. Man hat uns zu Fuß geführt, man musste laufen. Sie hatten keinen Transport angefordert und wir mussten acht (8) Kilometer laufen. Und Sie können sich vorstellen, dass jede...auf jede fünf (5) Mann—wir sind zu fünft (5.) marschiert—waren 2 Soldaten und ein Hund. Das heißt von beiden Seiten, also, jede Reihe von fünf (5) Mann.
David Boder: Ja. Zwei Polizisten?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Zwei Polizisten und ein Hund. Woher sind so viele Hunde gekommen?
David Boder: Was waren die—Polizeihunde?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, Polizeihunde waren es, speziell große Hunde.
David Boder: Die Hunde haben doch essen müssen!
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, für diese Hunde haben sie eher Essen gehabt als für die Juden. Sie haben gesagt, wenn sie einen Juden erschossen haben, sie haben jetzt ein Brot mehr und das könnten sie den Hunden zum Essen geben. Übrigens für die Deutschen war das damals wurscht, dass man das sagen kann, man hat etwas nicht, sie haben alles Menschenmögliche gehabt. Und Essen haben sie genug gehabt, denn sie konnten es von uns weg nehmen. Und wenn den Deutschen etwas gefehlt hat, dann hat man den Juden die Ration gekürzt und die Frage war erledigt. Niemand hat sich darum gekümmert, ob ein Jude von Hunger stirbt.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war ihre Aufgabe, aber sie konnten uns ganz einfach nichts zu essen geben, sonst könnte schon vielleicht eine Epidemie ausgebrochen—Tuberkulose oder Typhus, die ihnen auch schadet. . Das war der einzige...das war der einzige Grund warum sie Juden Essen gegeben haben. Sonst hätten sie gleich alle verhungern lassen. Als wir ins Dulag kamen, hatten wir den ganzen Tag kein Essen, dass heißt ich habe unter tags geschlafen und wenn man schläft, isst man doch nicht. Und zehn (10) Uhr nachts hat man uns zwei Kartoffel—zwei Pellkartoffel gegeben und das war das ganze Nachtmahl. In dem Durchgangslager war es so: Die Beamten des Lagers waren Juden. Sie waren frei, denn in Sosnowice waren noch damals viele Juden. Sie durften abends nach Hause gehen, sie waren einfach im Lager fungiert. Als Beamte sind sie dort gesessen, sie haben alles geordnet, ja sie haben gesehen, dass es Ordnung gibt. Dann gab es auch zehn (10) West Juden, das waren welche Juden, die schon einmal im Lager waren und ich weiß es nicht mehr—ich kann mich nicht mehr erinnern, warum sie in diesem Durchgangslager waren. Auf jeden Fall sind sie Angestellte im Durchgangslager geworden...man musste fegen, man musste sauber halten, man musste die Küche mit den Esswaren versehen und das wurde von dem zehn West Juden gemacht. Sonst war man gut bewacht von dem Sonderkommando der Polizei. Ich habe Ihnen schon gesagt, das Sonderkommando war verantwortlichlich für die Arbeiter—also, die haben uns bewacht. Und dort war ein Lagerleiter, nicht der Lagerführer, ein Deutscher, ein Offizier, das war ein Kerl,...damals...bis damals hab ich noch keinen Schlimmeren gesehen. Und er war auch ein Sadist, ein Sadist in der Größe, dass man es sich nicht vorstellen kann.
David Boder: Was nennen Sie einen Sadisten?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ein Sadist heißt ein Mann bei mir, der überhaupt kein menschliches Gefühl hat. Ich meine, ich will mich da...ich kann von diesen Fällen, die da gesehen habe, kann ich diesen Mensch nur beurteilen als nicht nur ein Judenfeind, sondern ein Menschenfeind. Der war gerade da ein Lagerführer, wo nur Juden da waren, aber ich bin überzeugt, wenn auch andere Leute da rein gekommen wären, hätte er das Selbe gemacht. Es war ein Mensch ohne Gefühl, einfach ein Mörderer. Und ich werde Ihnen nachher erzählen von einem Fall. Dort haben wir zwei (2) Mal täglich bekommen das Essen. Die Einteilung war so: morgens sind wir aufgestanden, wir haben ziemlich lange schlafen können. Wir haben geschlafen auf solchen Buchsen, auf solche Pritschen. Haben Sie gehört von solche Pritschen?
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also dort waren sie noch ziemlich anständig die Pritschen, es war ein Abstand bis zur Zweiten, das war ein Meter vielleicht
David Boder: Wie viele Leute auf jeder Pritsche?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das ist darauf angekommen, wieviel Leute gerade damals im Lager waren.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel...
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wenn es ein großer Transport war, dann hat man einfach alle dort rein gestopft. Ob Einer Platz gehabt zum Schlafen, niemand hat sich darum gekümmert, denn dort haben wir nicht gearbeitet. Es war nur ein Durchgangslager für einige Tage. Wenn wieder weniger waren, dann hatte man Raum zum schlafen. Wir waren damals nur ein paar Hundert, der Saal war ziemlich gross, also wir hatten da wirklich ziemlich viel Platz.
David Boder: Was heißt das ziemlich viel Platz? Wie viele Leute waren auf eine Pritsche?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich kann Ihnen das nicht genau sagen, aber es war gut Platz...es war genug Platz, vielleicht ein Meter in der Breite für einen Mann. Es waren wenig Leute, so war das...
David Boder: Und auf was hat man geschlafen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Auf einfachen Brettern.
David Boder: Keine Matratzen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Keine Matratzen, gar nichts. Aber es war so heiß, denn alles war abgeschlossen und man durfte kein Fenster öffnen. In der Nacht hat man sogar die Tür abgeschlossen und man konnte nicht ins Abort gehen, denn die Herren wollten sich nicht den Schlaf stehlen. Denn wenn man auf den Korridor geht, hört man das unbedingt. Wir waren dort zwei (2) Tage da hört man—ich weiß nicht von woher das gekommen ist—es muss wahrscheinlich von dem Personell des Lagers—da waren Juden—wahrscheinlich haben sie das von den Deutschen vernommen, dass heute Abend ein Transport aus Grenau kommen soll. .
David Boder: Von wo?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Grenau ist auch ein polnische Stadt. Da war ein großer Rüstungsbetrieb, also dort hat man Lokomotiven fabriziert.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Dort waren viele Juden, die Meisten waren beschäftigt in diesen Werken und dort waren auch Shops. Jetzt habe ich mich erinnert. Der Chef aller dieser Rüstungsschoppen, wo man Wehrmachtsuniformen ausgearbeitet hat, was Rosnel. Der Rosnel war ein Deutscher.
David Boder: Wie hat er geheißen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Rosnel.
David Boder: Rosnel.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Er war ungefähr fünf und zwanzig (25) Jahre alt, er hat gehinkt auf einem Bein, deswegen ist er auch nicht zum Krieg gegangen. Er hat ein Bein im Krieg verloren, also man hat ihn belohnt, indem man ihn Leiter über alle Schoppen gemacht hat und er hat das geleitet. Wenn man an ihn überdenkt, weiß man, dass er ein sehr guter Mann war. Er hat sehr, sehr Vieles für die Juden getan. Aber dann von Grenau, Grenau ist gekommen ein Befehl, dass es Juden-rein sein muss und er konnten schon nichts mehr machen. Also man hat gedacht an diesem Abend kommt ein ganzer Transport von Grenau. Meistens junge, junge Männer und Frauen, denn in Grenau hat man gleich sortiert die einzelnen—die alten Frauen, Männer und Kinder, die wurden gleich nach Auschwitz geschickt. Aber die Jüngeren, die waren sortiert für ein Arbeitslager und die wurden in das Durchgangslager Dulag bei Sosnowice geschickt. Als sie kamen...und es waren einige hundert (100) Personen...können Sie sich vorstellen, wie es eng...
David Boder: War.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hatte wirklich nicht genug Platz zum schlafen. Nachts hat man abgesperrt die Türen und es war furchtbar alles. Es war schon sozusagen keine gute Luft. Wir haben nur gewartet bis man die Tür öffnet wieder und als man die Tür aufgemacht hat, da sind die Leute gesteckt in der Türe und man konnte nicht mehr raus. Sie werden ich vielleicht fragen „warum“? Aber wenn die...wenn die Leute sich dort gedrängt haben, um Luft zu schnappen, dann sind sie alle stecken geblieben, denn es war eng und sie konnten nicht weiter und dann hat man von hinten gedrückt. Also es ist kein Tag vergangen, wo man nicht Einen getreten hat oder kaputt geschlagen. Sie haben ihn geschlagen und haben gesagt „Warum gehst Du nicht vorwärts, warum gehst Du nicht raus, Mensch.“ Denn unter solchen Umständen will man nur Luft, man will raus und man denkt nicht, dass es nicht ihre Schuld ist, dass doch die Deutschen an dem allem Schuld haben. Er man überdenkt das nicht, man ist kein Mensch mehr. Und solche Dinge sind jeden Morgen passiert. Nach Grenau...also von Grenau sind gekommen meistens junge Leute. Aber das es so bei jedem Transport war, haben verschiedene Leute sich mitgerissen, das heißt, wenn, zum Beispiel, in Grenau hat eine Selektion gemacht und die alten Leute nach Auschwitz geschickt, da waren noch einige kleine Kinder und Frauen, die sich unbemerkt unter die Anderen gereiht haben, die in ein Arbeitslager gegangen sind und so sind sie nach Sosnowice gekommen. Sie haben gesagt: „Ja, wir sind schon gerettet, sie werden in ein Arbeitslager kommen.“ Aber in dem Durchgangslager war eine neue Selektion geführt und tagtäglich kommen Autos von der Gestapo und man hat gleich nach Auschwitz gegeben. Diese Selektionen waren etwas Furchtbares, denn man hat uns jeden Tag...jeden Tag hat man uns raus gestellt auf den Platz und gezählt, ob jemand fehlt und dann die Gestapo...die Gestapo ist herein gegangen und hat geschaut. Und dann...wenn ihm wer nicht gefallen hat, den hat er den einfach nach Auschwitz geschickt.
David Boder: Er hat ihm gefallen, was heißt das? Oder nicht gefallen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nicht gefallen. Ich kann Ihnen nicht sagen, warum er ihm nicht gefallen hat oder nicht. Es hat ihm niemand gefallen. Er hat einfach einen Blick auf den Menschen geworfen und hat schon gesagt: „Komm raus!“ Ich weiß nicht, ob er ihm gefallen hat oder nicht, ich drücke mich nur so aus, weil es hat ihm Keiner gefallen. Er hat keine Juden mögen...Ja., ja. Ich habe noch vergessen vorhin zu erzählen eine ganz...eine ganz wichtige Sache...man kann vergessen, wenn man nicht vorbereitet ist.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, dann komm ich zurück und ich werde nachher dann da anfangen. Bevor ich von zu Hause weg war, ist einmal ein Gesetz raus...
David Boder: Also bevor sie weg waren...
Abraham Kimmelmann: Einige Wochen vorher ist ein Gesetz raus, wir haben nicht gewusst was das heißt, der ganze Bezirk Dabrowa, Bendzin und Sosnowice, dass alle Juden an einem Tag, zur selben Stunde müssen sich alle an bestimmten Plätzen stellen. Es gibt keine Privilegierten, alle Leute, Jedes Lebewesen, jedes jüdische Lebewesen. Ein Kind, das ist einen Tag alt und ein alter Mann, der nicht auf die Beine stehen kann, der muss auf den Platz raus und die Lichtbild Identitätsausweise musste bewiesen werden...gestempelt werden.
David Boder: Mit Lichtbild?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Ich werde Ihnen noch sagen was diese Lichtbild Ausweise sind. Man vergisst immer Sachen zu erzählen, die erst nachher eine große Bedeutung haben. Aber ich kann da nichts machen. Man ist nicht vorbereitet und man spricht einfach...
David Boder: Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also mit den Lichtbildausweisen war es so. Zur ersten Zeit als die Deutschen rein kamen, hat man die ganze polnische Bevölkerung, Juden oder Nichtjuden—man hat Fingerabdrücke gemacht. Das war das Erste. Dann haben sie aber einen Unterschied zwischen den Polen und den Juden machen wollen. Da haben sie für die Juden spezielle Lichtbildausweise gemacht. Alle mussten sich fotografieren lassen und die Photographie ist auf den Ausweis geklebt worden, so dass, wenn man von einem Juden einen Ausweis verlangt hat, hat man sofort gesehen, ob es die betreffende Person ist oder nicht. Denn mit den Fingerabdrücken hat man verschiedene Experimente machen müssen, um zu kontrollieren—das war aber für sie viel leichter.
David Boder: Das Bild war nicht angeklebt, nicht wahr, es war drauf photographiert?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es wurde nur drauf geklebt, aber sie haben...es war so, dass es nachher von der Polizei gestempelt wurde auf dem ersten Teil der Karte und halb auf dem Bild—eben so, dass man nicht schwindeln kann.
David Boder: Ja, ich verstehe, das heißt...
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun dass Sie verstehen was ein Lichtbildausweis ist, kann ich Ihnen weiter erzählen, von...dem was ich tatsächlich mitgemacht habe.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Da haben sie so einen Trick gemacht. In Wolbronn, das war nicht weit von uns, waren noch...haben dort noch Juden gewohnt. Da haben sich alle zusammen versammelt auf einem Platz und haben die Lichtbildausweise noch einmal abstempeln lassen von der Gestapo—von einem Sonderkommando und die haben sie wieder nach Hause geschickt. Und nachher hat sich das ausgewiesen, dass das nur ein Trick war, weil in Wolbronn haben nicht viele Juden gewohnt. Aber in Dabrowa, Bendzin und Sosnowice waren damals noch zirka fünfzig tausend (50 000) Juden, vielleicht noch mehr und die alle wollte sie in einem Tag bekommen. Darum haben sie von Wolbronn alle Juden frei gelassen, dass wir keine Angst mehr haben sollen. Und dann haben sie Zettel in die Strassen gehängt, dann an diesem und diesem Tag sollen sich alle Juden auf den Plätzen versammeln. Sie werden nur die Ausweise stempeln und dann können wir nach Hause gehen. Es war uns...es hat uns nicht ganz so gefallen.
David Boder: Sind Sie auch nach Hause gegangen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, ich bin dorthin gegangen und ich [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Also...—also um uns etwas zu beruhigen, ist gekommen der Monek Merin, was ich...was ich schon vorher von ihm erzählt habe, ich habe erzählt, das war der Hauptleiter der Kultusgemeinde für die ganzen Kreise da. Und er hat eine Rede gehalten, dass wir keine Angst haben sollen, in Wolbronn war das auch so und man hat alle frei gelassen [kein Ton am Tonband—Bruch oder nur übersprungen?]...dann mussten wir noch einmal vor der Kommission stehen und die Dritte war nach Auschwitz gegangen. Also der hat nicht gesprochen, der hat nur die Miliz hingestellt—es war im Platz...außen war deutsche Polizei, die haben uns bewacht und innen war die jüdische Polizei, die haben alle geordnet, dass es still sein soll. Und der hat mit dem Finger gezeigt—Gruppe eins (1), Gruppe zwei (2) und Gruppe drei (3). Ich will nicht viel sagen, was passiert hat, bis ich an die Reihe gekommen bin.
David Boder: Waren Sie mit Ihrer Mutter zusammen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, ich war mit der Mutter zusammen, die Anzeigen haben uns auch gesagt, das sich Familien stellen sollen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und nachher hat sich auch gezeigt, warum sie das gemacht haben. Also, ich will nur kurz da erzählen, was da vorgegangen ist. Also das Schreien war furchtbar, denn man hat einfach die Familien getrennt.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und man hat junge Männer, die eine bunte Karte gehabt haben, dahin geschickt und die Mutter hat man dahin geschickt und die Familien, wo eine Minderheit beschäftigt war, da hat man die ganze Familie genommen. Das war auch der Grund warum man gesagt hat, dass sie sich familienweise stellen sollen, damit auch diejenigen, die Beschäftigung haben, aber in der Minderheit sind in der Familie, auch dran kommen.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und als wir drankamen, also zuerst komm ich, die Schwester hatte eine gute Karte, meine Mutter auch und ich auch, ich hatte auch eine gute Karte, aber meine Mutter hat damals sehr schlecht ausgesehen, denn wir haben nicht viel verdient und sie konnte nicht gut essen [Tonband unverständlich]...und da hat er sich gedacht, so eine Frau kann nicht mehr arbeiten, obwohl sie vielleicht mehr geleistet hat, als derjenige, der besser ausgesehen hat als sie.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 86 of Kimmelmann, we are going over to Spool 87. Geneva, 28th of August 1946.
David Boder: Geneva, August 28th, 1946 at the Shops of the ORT. Abraham Kimmelmann continues.
David Boder: [In German] Nun Sie haben mir erzählt, wenn in einer Familie Wenige gearbeitet haben, dann hat man die ganze Familie weg geschickt. Nun weiter.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also bei uns war es halt, dass wir alle beschäftigt waren und ich habe Ihnen schon vorhin erzählt, hm, meine Mutter und meine Schwester haben in einem Rüstungsbetrieb gearbeitet—ich auch. Als wir soweit kamen—zu demjenigen, der unser Leben bestimmt hat, hat der...als Erste ist meine Schwester vorbei und die haben sie gleich befreit. Sie haben sie geschickt zu Nummer eins (1). Aber sie ist dort gestanden, als ob sie gewusst hätte...sie ist nicht gleich dorthin gegangen, sie hatte noch immer aus...es war so instinktiv bei ihr...so ein Angstgefühl ist über sie gekommen und sie hat noch gewartet. Sie hat etwas gefühlt was nicht gut sein wird. Und eben...man hat die Mutter gleich auf Nummer drei (3) geschickt...das war das Schlimmste und mich mit.
David Boder: Warum?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Mich mit, weil ich, wenn ich das jetzt so betrachten sollte, weil ich noch damals war...ich war noch ganz wenig entwickelt, ich habe damals so mehr als ein Kind ausgesehen.
David Boder: Oh!
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich habe mehr kindlich ausgesehen und weil er doch damals meine Mutter hingeschickt hat, hat man gesagt, ich glaube der hat sich gedacht: ‚Was kann er schon machen?’ und man hat mich dort hin geschickt. Ich habe aber eine sehr eine gute Karte gehabt und als wir dort hin kamen ist der, der Präsident der jüdischen Kultusgemeinde gestanden und er hat mich angeschaut und ich habe noch so meine Karte in der Hand gehalten. Sagt er im Polnischen noch: „Was ist denn los? Warum bist Du da gekommen?“ Und ich habe es selber nicht gewusst, also ich hab...so viel Glück gehabt, das ist gar nicht zu beschreiben, denn die jüdische Miliz hat so gemacht. Wenn er mit dem Finger gezeigt hat...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . dass, da jemand zu der Gruppe gehört, so hat der Mensch keine Sekunde Zeit gegeben, um sogar jemandem Ade zu sagen. Er hat ihn gleich hin geschleppt, er durfte nicht mehr schauen, ob der Vater dort hin ist und der Sohn da, sie durften nicht mehr ein Wort mit sich sprechen. Aber mich hat man gelassen, ich weiß nicht wieso. Man hat meine Karte angeschaut und sie haben [unverständlich]...die Gestapo, wenn sie das gesehen hätten, hätten sie ihm eine Ohrfeige gleich gegeben oder angeschrien oder sonst was. Aber mich hat man noch einmal zurück geschickt in der Reihe, also nochmal stehen. Und meine Mutter war damals glücklich, sie hat nicht mehr an sich gedacht, dass sie jetzt in so einer Gefahr ist...und sie ist schon in Gefahr. Sie hat nur gedacht mich zu retten.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und als ich nochmal vorbei kam, da hat er mich befreit und ich bin zu Gruppe eins (1) gekommen.
David Boder: Und Ihre Mutter ist dort geblieben?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Meine Mutter ist dort geblieben.
David Boder: In Nummer drei (3)?
Abraham Kimmelmann: In Nummer drei (3) und ich hab den ganzen Tag nicht mehr von ihr gehört. Wir hatten dort eine Bekannte von, von den Beamten der Kultusgemeinde und wir haben sie gebeten, vielleicht sehen sie meine Mutter und dann sollen sie ihr sagen, sie soll sich trösten. Aber wer...wer hatte den Kopf für Fremde? Jeder hat mit sich zu tun. Niemand war sich sicher mit dem Leben. Wir sind gestanden dort stundenlang, es hat Stunden gedauert, so viele Leute durch zu sehen und ihnen zu sagen, wohin zu gehen. Um zwei (2) Uhr war es fertig. Es war so heiß bis zwei (2) Uhr.
David Boder: Am Tage?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, am Tage. Und auf einmal um zwei (2) Uhr hat ein Gewitter gemacht. Es hat angefangen zu donnern und zu regnen, es war einfach furchtbar. Da hat man Kinder, solche jungen Kinder, die noch in den Kinderwagen gelegen haben und da hat es so angefangen zu regnen. Und niemand hat es etwas mitgenommen...wer hat sich gedacht, dass es an so einem schönen Tag so zu regnen anfangen wird. Aber die Eltern haben sich einfach auf den Kinderwagen rauf gelegt, damit der Regen nicht rein kommt. Und der Regen hat uns noch mehr traurig gemacht. Wir haben angefangen so zu heulen und so zu jammern und die Schreie waren bis zum Himmel. Also...also es war so wie ein Chor...alle haben plötzlich angefangen, mit dem Regen zusammen man hat angefangen so zu schreien. Und wir haben geheult. Plötzlich steht auf ein Mann, er war Jude, er hat geheißen Smetana, er war auch Einer von den sogenannten Prominenten, in der Sosnowice jüdischen Zentrale. Und er hielt eine Rede und hat gesagt: „ Nun ist die Selektion fertig. Die, die in Gruppe eins (1) sind, die noch frei sind, die gehen noch an einem Tisch durch und die lassen sich den Lichtbildausweis stempeln. Und die Anderen, die in Gruppe zwei (2), die bleiben noch vorläufig in der Kultusgemeinde in Dabrowa. Die wird man dann noch mal untersuchen. Die dritte (3.) Gruppe geht nach Auschwitz.“
David Boder: Hat er gesagt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, hat er gesagt und zwar so: „Es soll es niemand wagen, sich jetzt auf der Strasse zu zeigen und wer sich auf der Strasse zeigt, der kommt mit Nummer 3, das heißt zum Evakuieren.“ Das war aber—obwohl man es vorher auch gewusst hat—dass wenn man es zur Sprache bringt, dass man vielleicht einen grösseren Eindruck auf den Menschen macht—die Leute haben angefangen zu Schreien, aber so arg, dass die Deutsche haben gedacht, es wird etwas vorkommen und die haben angefangen zu schießen in die Luft. Nun, man hat uns beruhigt mit Schießen, man hat sich vollkommen beruhigt. Sie haben die Lichtbildausweise abgestempelt und wir sind durch eine andere Strasse nach Hause gekommen. Wir haben so einen Halbkreis gemacht.
David Boder: Und Ihre Mutter ist dort geblieben?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Meine Mutter ist dort geblieben und dann habe ich nichts mehr gewusst von ihr. Nur Nummer eins (1) frei gelassen worden, wir sind nach Hause gegangen. Also wir waren nur junge Leute und nur Kräftige. Ich...ich mein...
David Boder: War Ihre Schwester auch dabei?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, meine Schwester auch. Da war ein Junge, der vielleicht fünf und zwanzig (25) Jahre alt war, der war so aufgeregt, er ist vielleicht nervös...oder vielleicht nervös krank gewesen...und er ist vorbei an einem Zaun, verstehen Sie...
David Boder: An einem Zaun.
Abraham Kimmelmann: An einem Zaun, da waren längliche Pfähle an der Erde eingebaut und ich weiß nicht, woher er die Kräfte gehabt hat, aber das...aber das haben nicht seine Kräfte gemacht, sondern seine Nerven, da bin ich überzeugt, denn da gibt es keine menschliche Kraft, die das im Stande ist...so war seine Kraft, man hat gar nichts gemerkt. Er hat einfach seine Hand dort hin und er hat den Pfahl heraus gezogen...vor Aufregung.
David Boder: Und nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und wir sind so zurück gegangen, wie vom Friedhof. Wir haben so geheult. Als wir nach Hause kamen, war die Tür abgeschlossen. Wir haben vergessen den Schlüssel...von der Mutter den Schlüssel zu nehmen. Die Tür war abgesperrt. Wir haben eine Scheibe ausgeschlagen und wir sind rein. Was kann man machen, man durfte sich nicht auf der Strasse zeigen. Aber es hat uns doch, es hat uns doch nicht folgen lassen. Ich bin bald wieder raus. Ich habe nur einen einzigen Juden gehen...gehen gesehen und ich wollte zur jüdischen Gemeinde laufen. Ich weiß nicht warum, denn ich habe gewusst, dass meine Mutter doch nach Bensburg gekommen ist, denn sie war Nummer drei (3). Aber ich habe es versucht und ich bin gegangen. Die Polizei war überall und wir haben uns versteckt...sind von einem Haus zum Zweiten gelaufen, so dass sie uns nicht gesehen haben. Endlich war ich bei der jüdischen Kultusgemeinde. Oben war so ein Balkon und da waren sie alle abgesperrt, aber man hat ihnen den Gefallen gemacht, man hat sie auf den Balkon raus gelassen. Und plötzlich höre ich meine Mutter rufen meinen Namen. Ich schaue hoch und ich seh meine Mutter. Und ich sah meine Mutter. Sie hielt den Schlüssel in der Hand und schmeißt ihn von der Weite. Ich habe nicht gewusst, was mir passiert. Ich habe nicht gewusst was passiert ist. dass sie in Nummer zwei (2) kommt, denn sie war doch Nummer drei (3). Also ich war wirklich—man hat doch gesagt, dass die Nummer zwei (2) über Nacht in Dabrowa bleiben wird und danach werden sie nochmal untersucht. Ich bin nach Hause gegangen, ich habe das gleich meiner Schwester gesagt.
David Boder: Dass sie in Nummer zwei (2) ist?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Das habe ich gleich meiner Schwester erzählt, weil ich wusste, dass sie Nummer zwei (2) ist und dass sie ein bisschen Freude hätte. Aber es hat keine Stunde gedauert und da hat man sie alle...alle Leute genommen und meine Mutter war auch dabei und man hat sie zu Fuß nach Bensburg getrieben. Als wie ich nachher erfahren habe, hat man sie wie...wie Vieh getrieben. Sie mussten Einer dem Zweiten auf die Beine treten. Und so hat, was ich gehört...
David Boder: Männer und Frauen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Männer und Frauen. Und wenn sie es nicht gemacht haben, da haben sie gleich den Stock mit genommen...mit welchem...also das war ihr Dolmetscher. Sie wollten sich nicht, hm...sie haben gesagt: „Sie würden weder das Maul noch die Hand schmutzig machen.“ Sie haben den Stock als Dolmetscher genommen und wenn jemand sich nicht ordentlich unterworfen hat, dann hat er es mit dem Stock bekommen. Wir sind zu Hause geblieben, wir durften doch nicht raus gehen. Und wir haben auch nicht genau gewusst wohin man die Leute geführt hat. Doch haben wir vermutet, dass sie doch auch nach Bensburg geschafft wurden...in die...das Waisenheim. Als es morgens sechs (6) Uhr...ich habe Ihnen vorhin erzählt, dass ich eine Erlaubnis nach Bensburg gehabt habe—um dorthin zu gehen, weil ich dort gearbeitet habe. Da hab ich den ersten Tram genommen und ich bin nach Bensburg gefahren. Ich komme hin zu dem Waisenhaus, also eine Strasse,die zu dem Waisenhaus geführt hat. Da hat mir ein Jude gesagt, ich soll nicht hin zu dem Waisenhaus, denn dort stehen die Gestapo Leute und wenn die mich sehen, dann werd ich mitgenommen. So habe ich gedacht: ,Ich will mit meiner Mutter zusammen sein, aber wenn ich frei bin, kann ich vielleicht doch etwas tun, um sie zu retten. Wenn wir beide drin sind, dann haben wir keine Hoffnung’. Ich hab die Tram genommen und bin weiter gefahren, ohne dass ich an mich gedacht hätte. Und das alles hat zur gleichen Zeit in Dabrowa, Sosnowice und Bensburg stattgefunden. Der einzige Unterschied war der, dass in Dabrowa ist es in nur einem Tag erledigt worden, weil es nur fünftausend (5 000) Köpfe waren, in Bensburg und Sosnowice hat es noch bis morgen auch gedauert. Es war am Mittwoch und am Donnerstag hat es noch immer gedauert...nachdem die Selektion hat stattgefunden, hat es noch immer gedauert. Ich habe die Tram genommen und bin gefahren—ohne dass ich ein Ziel habe. Und da war eine Haltestelle und ich steige aus, ohne dass ich wusste, was ich mache und ich gehe und da stand ich vor einem Haus, wo meine Tante gewohnt hat. Also ich bin gelaufen, als ob ich geschlafen hätte. Und ich komme hinauf und meine Kusine weint. Ich durfte sie nicht mehr fragen über gar nichts. Ich habe ihr auch nicht erzählt über meine Mutter, [unverständlich; starkes Rauschen im Tonband]. Ich habe ihr gar nichts erzählt.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich habe ihr nichts erzählt, ich habe nicht geweint und ich ging hinaus. Ich ging hinaus, da ich selbst nicht [unverständlich; Tonband sehr schlecht] und ich habe wieder die Tram genommen. Da habe ich wieder eine Kusine von mir gesehen, aus Sosnowice. Also ihr Eltern haben auch in Dobrowa Konijia gewohnt. Genau an dem Tag der Selektion haben sie bei uns gewohnt. Bis eine Woche zurück haben sie bei uns gewohnt, weil man sie von einer Strasse ausgewiesen hat . Und sie hatten keine Wohnung mehr und da haben sie mit uns gewohnt. Ich habe gewusst, dass ihre Eltern auch zu Nummer drei (3) gekommen sind. Ich habe nichts erzählen wollen, aber ich hab gleich gesehen, dass sie schon davon weiß, weil sie hat schrecklich geweint. Ich habe sie nur begrüßt, aber wir haben kein Wort mehr gesprochen. Sie hat aber große Protektion der Kultusgemeinde gehabt. Und ich habe gedacht nun eigentlich sie zu fragen um Hilfe, aber da ihre Eltern auch in der selben Lage waren, hätte sie doch bestimmt...und das hätte ich auch an ihrer Stelle gemacht, zuerst ihre Eltern zu retten versucht. Ich habe nichts gesagt, nur dass meine Mutter auch dort ist in dem Waisenhaus und ich bin wieder nach Hause gefahren. Als ich nach Hause kam, stand beim Tram alle...alle Juden, die zu Hause geblieben sind. Und die haben gebeten die Miliz vielleicht kann man das machen und vielleicht kann man das machen. Und am selben Tag hat ein...ein, ein Jude hat zwanzig tausend (20 000) Mark gegeben...
David Boder: Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . einen jüdischen Miliz, dass er seinen Vater retten soll. Also, ich muss Ihnen sagen, es war die Möglichkeit eines [unverständlich] nur einzelne Personen zu retten. Das heißt, dass nachts hat die jüdischen Miliz Wache gehabt. Nachts, so dass man...dass man, dass sie nicht Jedem auf die Finger geschaut haben. Wenn jemand [unverständlich], dann haben sie nichts gesagt. Also das war für Geld. Aber das war nur ein einzelner Fall, wo der Sohn den Vater gerettet hat mit zwanzig tausend (20 000) Mark. Und so wenn ich wieder nach Dobrowa kam, haben die Leute auf die Miliz gewartet, wo die haben das gemacht. Wenn man einen Brief aufgegeben hat, kostet das ungeheuer viel Geld oder nur um ein Paketchen abzugeben. Was kann ich erwarten? Wir hatten kein Geld. Ich hab...ich hab nichts Anderes tun können, als hoffen. Ich hab damals noch ein bisschen gehofft, aber ich hab es selber nicht glauben wollen, dass ich noch meine Mutter sehen werde. Ich komm nach Hause und erzähle alles meiner Schwester und ich werd...ich fühle...ich werd...ich gehe wieder nach Bensburg. Ich gehe hinein in die Fabrik, wo ich war, wo ich gearbeitet habe. Als ich rein kam, stand der Chef und sein Gehilfe und ich habe plötzlich nur angefangen zu schreien und zu weinen. Und er hat gesagt: „Ja, was ist denn los?“
David Boder: Ja. Was haben Sie gesagt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sag ich: „Ja, wieso soll ich nicht weinen, wenn meine Mutter zu dem Tod genommen wird?“ Sagt er: „Wer? Sie müssen mir das verständlich sagen, sie müssen [unverständlich]. Wer?“ Sag ich: „Meine Mutter“. Sagt er: „Warte zu, wenn der Matischa kommt—das war sein Vertreter—wird er mit Dir auf die Sonderpolizei gehen. Vielleicht wird er was machen.“ Ich habe ihm gesagt: „Wenn ich meine Mutter nicht mehr hab, dann komm ich nicht mehr zur Arbeit. Es ist mir gleich!“ Er hat es nicht aus Angst vor mir,...weil er Angst vor mir gehabt hat, gemacht. Vielleicht hat er Mitleid mit mir bekommen.
David Boder: Sie haben mir vorher gesagt, er war ein sehr schlechter Mensch.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, er war auch ein sehr schlechter Mann, auch zu mir hat er sich sehr hässlich benommen. Und ich habe gewartet, ich bin vor dem Tor gestanden, ich habe auch gewartet auf den Matischa, den Vertreter a, wie die Juden auf den Messias gewartet haben. Ich bin dann wieder zurück und hab mich hin gesetzt und habe geweint. Dann ich war auf den Platz hingegangen hinter der Fabrik und ich habe geweint. Dort ist gewesen das WC und einige Arbeiterinnen von der Fabrik sind auf das WC gegangen und wenn sie gesehen haben, dass ich weine, haben sie gesagt
David Boder: Zu der Toilette?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . ja, zu der Toilette. : „Abraham, was ist los, warum weinst Du denn?“
David Boder: Waren das Christen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, das ware Christliche, ich war nur ein einziger() Jude. Was waren fünfzig (50) Arbeiter und ich war der eine Jude. [unverständlich; Rauschen im Tonband] Und sie haben nur den Kopf geschüttelt, was konnten sie eigentlich machen? Wie sie sind dann reingegangen, haben sie es dem Meister erzählt. Er ist sofort heraus gekommen und hat gesagt: „Warum weinst Du, Deine Mutter ist doch oben bei Derawisch bei der Familie Derawisch ist Deine Mutter oben.“
David Boder: Was hat er gesagt von Ihrer Mutter?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Deine Mutter ist doch oben bei Derawisch. Also ich werde Ihnen das erzählen, wer die Familie Derawisch war. In diesem Platz, wo ich gearbeitet habe, das war vorher ein Magazin für,...hm, wie heißt das, für Pferde...Essen...
David Boder: Futter.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, Futter für Pferde, Pferdefutter. Und dann lag natürlich alles brach. Und dieser Eigentümer dieses Magazins hatte viel Geld und hatte einige Maschinen eingekauft und wollte sich eine Werkstatt eröffnen. Aber die Deutschen sind gleich wieder gekommen und haben das konfisziert.
David Boder: War der ein Jude?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Er war nicht Jude, er war ein Pole. Sie haben diesen Platz gefunden, der war gut für ein Werk. Sie wollten es vergrößern, sie haben grossartige Pläne gemacht, sie wollten noch bauen und mehr Maschinen einsetzen. Also sie haben es mittlerweile konfisziert, das ist das Geschäft und zwar, dass es auf den Namen des Deutschen übertragen ist und der Pole ist dort als so ein Anschaffer geblieben, das heißt, er hat Materialien angeschafft und er hat sich um die Arbeit gekümmert, dass es geleistet wird, und so weiter. So ein Aufseher.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber er hat nur ein Gehalt bekommen, mehr nicht. Und in diesem Haus, wo er vorher gewohnt hat, haben auch seine Schwiegereltern gewohnt. Die waren sehr ältlich und weil ich in diesem Werk gearbeitet habe und meine Mutter öfters herüber gekommen ist, obwohl sie durfte nicht nach Bensburg gehen, aber die Leute sind zu Fuß durch die Felder gelaufen. Manchmal war es nötig, wenn ich noch dazu dort geschlafen habe, wie ich Ihnen vorher erzählt habe. Also sie haben sich ein bisschen kennengelernt [unverständlich]. Und er hat gesagt: „Sie ist oben!“ Ich hab damals nicht gewusst momentan, was er zu mir spricht. Ich habe gedacht...ich wollte, wenn ich zu Bewusstsein gekommen bin, was er da gesagt hat...ich wollte ihn küssen...ich weiß einfach nicht, was ich damals machen wollte. Und ich lasse ihn da sehen und ich laufe hinauf. Als ich hinauf kam, sah ich meine Mutter da im Bett und der alte Herr legt Kompressen da auf, auf die Knie...und die alte Frau macht ihr Essen, und so. Sie können sich vorstellen, was ich damals gemacht habe...ich habe meine Mutter geküsst und eben, was man in so einer Situation macht. Und ich hab noch damals...ich bin gar nicht dazu gekommen, sie zu fragen, wieso sie eigentlich hier ist. Ich habe sie stehen gelassen, liegen gelassen. Ich bin gleich nach Hause gefahren und habe die Schwester benachrichtigt und gleich wieder die nächste Tram genommen und habe ihr etwas zu essen mitgebracht. Als ich rauf kam, habe ich sie gefragt: „Mutter, wie hast Du das gemacht? Wieso bis Du hier her gekommen, wieso?“ Und sie hat mir Folgendes erzählt. Diese Nacht hat man sie auf den zweiten (2.) Stock des Waisenhauses hinauf geführt. Also ihre Gruppe Nummer zwei (2). Dagegen Nummer 3, die bestimmt waren weg zu fahren, die waren auf dem dritten (3.) Stock.
David Boder: Und wie ist sie in den zweiten (2.) Stock gekommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ein Moment. Ich habe sie eben das gefragt. Wie bist Du eigentlich in Nummer zwei (2) gekommen? Sie hat mir dies gesagt. Also wenn ich befreit worden war, hat sie angefangen zu denken an sich. Sie hat gewusst, dass es nicht nur um sie geht, sondern dass sie von uns getrennt sein wird. Und als der Regen anfing...anfing und es war schon fünf (5) und die Leute begannen zu weinen, hat die Miliz geschaut, die Leute zu beruhigen. Und damals hat sie die Gelegenheit ausgenützt und sie ist zu Nummer zwei (2) rüber. Sie konnte aber damals auch in Nummer eins (1) rüber, aber sie wusste noch nicht, was das Eins und das Zwei ist. Man hat es nicht gewusst, denn es waren verschiedene Leute dort in jeder Gruppe. Denn ich habe Ihnen ja erzählt, dass wenn in einer Familie eine Minderheit nur gearbeitet hat, dann wurde die ganze Familie ausgewiesen, ja. Aber wir haben das damals noch nicht gewusst, und wir haben nicht gedacht, dass sie nach dem Alter und dem Aussehen schauen und dadurch waren viele verschiedene Leute in einer Gruppe drinnen. Zum Beispiel, in einer Familie, wo nur ein Sohn gearbeitet hat und der Sohn war ein sehr Schöner, gut entwickelt, er war trotzdem in Gruppe 3. Und wir haben damals noch nicht gewusst, dass es sich da um die Minderheit handelt. Aber meine Mutter hat gedacht zwei (2) sei gut und so ist sie dorthin gegangen. Also damals ist es ihr gelungen, sich in Gruppe zwei (2) rüber zu schmuggeln und sie hat gemeint, das wäre ich sicher, da wäre ich frei. Aber sie hat sich gewundert, warum dass die Schwester und ich nicht dort waren und sie hat gesehen, dass sie einen großen Fehler gemacht hat. Aber dann konnte sie nicht mehr weiter und sie ist in Nummer zwei (2) geblieben. Also auf diese Weise hat sie sich vorläufig von drei (3) gerettet. Also als sie...wenn sie in den ersten Stock rauf kam, versuchte sie alles zu machen, um von dort zu entrinnen...zu entkommen. Aber die ganze Nacht sie sind gesessen und die Leute sind heraus durch die Tür und wollten durch das Tor heraus. Und wenn man so Einen geschnappt hat, dann hat man ihn rauf in den dritten (3.) Stock. Also das hat auch schon [unverständlich] mitgemacht, da haben sie ihn auf den dritten (3.) Stock geführt. Also das war schon ein großes Risiko zu versuchen von Nummer zwei (2) weg zu kommen, die Leute hatten sich gewünscht Nummer zwei (2) zu sein auf dem ersten (1.) Stock, das sind alles die, die auf dem dritten (3.) Stock waren. Schließlich was sich da an diesem Abend abgespielt hat, diese Schlägereien und so weiter, das will ich nicht, das ist jetzt nicht hier zu betonen. Aber ich will Ihnen erzählen, wie meine Mutter von dort gerettet worden ist. Schließlich es war fünf (5) Uhr in der Früh...
David Boder: Abends oder in der Früh?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war fünf (5) Uhr morgens und um halb sechs (6) sollte die Gestapo die Wache übernehmen. Aber es hat kein Mensch gewusst, das hat sich erst später ausgewiesen. Es war fünf (5) Uhr und da hat meine Mutter bemerkt, dass ein Mann einen Riemen...den Riemen von den Hosen nimmt, hat den ans Fenster und schwupps—raus aus dem Fenster.
David Boder: Ein Mann?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ein Mann und er ist runter gesprungen. Und sie hat nicht gesehen, ob er entflohen ist oder nicht. sie hat nicht viel nachgedacht . Der Riemen ist aber noch hängen geblieben. Und sie hat gar nicht nach gedacht und sie hat etwas Angst bekommen, weil das gar nicht zu einer Frau gehört. Und sie hat das Selbe gemacht.
David Boder: Wie hoch war das?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war der erste (1.) Stock.
David Boder: Ja, aber das war wirklich der zweite...[beide sprechen]
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, und es war ziemlich hoch, denn der Parterre war ziemlich hoch. Es war nicht so ein einfaches Haus, der Parterre war auch so wie ein halber Stock. Es war ziemlich hoch. Man musste viel Mut haben, das zu machen. Und da sie niemals solche Sachen gemacht hat und weiß nicht, wie man das machen soll. Und statt auf die Zehen zu landen, ist sie auf den ganzen Fuß gesprungen und sie hat Fußverletzung gehabt, das Band...[unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und es hat geplatzt...
David Boder: Das Gelenk?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das Gelenk hat geplatzt und sie konnte schon nicht mehr laufen. Sie konnte nicht mehr aufstehen. Und das hat eine Wache—ein Miliz—bemerkt und er wollte sie wieder hinein schleppen—und zwar in Gruppe. Und da ist ein Mädel gekommen, die mit uns zusammen...die mit uns zusammenwohnt, also ein Nachbarin von uns, auch eine Jüdin, der...wo auch ihre Mutter im Waisenhaus war. Auch sie wollte etwas für ihre Mutter machen. Wenn sie sieht, dass er meine Mutter wieder in das Waisenhaus schleppt, da hat sie einfach Mut bekommen und sie war stark und da hat sie es...da hat sie gesagt zu ihm, wenn er meine Mutter nicht frei lässt, dann wird sie da etwas machen. Und ich weiß nicht wieso und meine Mutter weiß es auch nicht, aber er hat sie frei gelassen und ist wieder zum Tor gegangen und hat wieder seine Wache aufgenommen und hat sich um die Mutter nicht mehr gekümmert. Und meine, Mutter ist auf die Knie gelaufen, weil auf die Beine konnte sie nicht mehr gehen und das war einen Kilometer entfernt von der Fabrik, wo ich gearbeitet habe. Und sie ist dort hinaus und mittlerweile hat sie sich gerettet. Wir haben sie gebracht wieder zurück nach Dobrowa, sie konnte nicht gehen. Aber sie konnte nicht, denn sonst hätten wir gedacht, dass wir dort über die Felder laufen und es sieht uns niemand. Aber sie konnte nicht laufen. Ich habe mich an meinen Chef gewendet. Ich habe ihn gefragt um einen Rat. Vielleicht könnten Sie mir eine Bescheinigung geben, dass meine Mutti hier beschäftigt ist, damit sie [unverständlich] tun kann, wenn sie jemand sieht. Also sagte er, ich soll den Kutscher holen, er soll die Pferde spannen, einen vollen Wagen mit Heu und die Mutti darunter. So habe ich es gemacht und ich habe meine Mutter nach Hause gebracht. Fünf (5) Wochen ist die Mutter zu Hause gelegen.
David Boder: Sie war zu Hause, obwohl sie dort auf der Liste war?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich versteh nicht, was sie meinen.
David Boder: Hat man Ihre Mutter nicht in Nummer 2 reingenommen, ja eigentlich Nummer 3. Haben die keine Liste gehabt, wer dort war?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, es war gar keine Liste. Die, die man gehalten hat, die hat man gehalten. Die brauchten keine Liste, denn sie haben die Leute so bewachen können, dass fast niemand entfliehen konnte, nicht sehr Viele konnten flüchten.
David Boder: Aber hat man dort keinen Appell gehabt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, nein, nein, kein Name war auf einer Liste. Es war nur das Einzige, dass der Lichtbildausweis meiner Mutter nicht gestempelt war. Nun in diesem Zusammenhang möchte ich Ihnen noch etwas erzählen von diesen Lichtbildausweisen. Meine Mutter hatte einen Regenmantel angehabt. Und als sie oben war, hat sie den Regenmantel ausgezogen, denn es war so heiß. In diesem Regenmantel hat sie alle ihre Ausweise gehabt, die Sonderausweise und den Lichtbildausweis. Nun wie wir nach Hause gekommen sind, haben wir immer Angst gehabt ohne die Ausweise weg zu gehen. Erstens muss man die Ausweise an sich haben...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . und zweitens musste der Ausweis gestempelt sein. Die alle, die zu Hause geblieben sind, haben sie doch die Ausweise gestempelt gehabt. Aber sie hat den Regenmantel verloren und ohne Ausweis durfte man sich nicht auf der Strasse zeigen. Sogar zu Hause war man nicht sicher. Nur wenn ein Beamter dich angehalten hat und gesagt hat: „Zeig mir Dein Lichtbild.“ Und wenn man den nicht hat...so sind man schon ohne...
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also wir haben versucht zu fragen verschiedene Beamten, vielleicht können sie das holen, aber er hat sich darum gekümmert. Sie hatten natürlich selber ihre Sachen zu erledigen. Die Mutter ist vier (4) Wochen im Bett gelegen und sie hat...man hat ihr das Bein gegipst.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das hat getan ein...ein Arzt.
David Boder: Ein jüdischer Arzt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, das war ein polnischer Arzt, der ist auch so illegal gekommen. Er durfte nicht. Man hat ihn gut bezahlt, er ist gekommen.
David Boder: Woher haben Sie das Geld gehabt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, wir haben Vieles verkauft. Man hat einfach vom Anziehen verkauft, man hat weniger gegessen und fertig, wenn es sich um so eine Sache handelt. Eines Tages kommt Einer...ein gewisser Jütkevidz hat er geheißen, auch von Bensburg, kommt zu meiner Mutter und sagt, dass ich, hm, oder meine Schwester hinkommen sollen nach Bensburg, um den Lichtbildausweis und den Regenmantel meiner Mutter...
David Boder: Abzuholen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . abzuholen. Da haben wir die Augen aufgestellt, denn wir haben nicht gewusst, was er zu uns spricht. Also ich bin gleich nach Benzburg gefahren und als ich hinkam erzählte mir meine Kusine Folgendes: sie hat einen Bekannten, einen Miliz, der zu ihr rauf kommt—also sie war schon verheiratet—das war nur so ein Freund und der ist raufgekommen und erzählte—er sagte ihr, dass ein Lichtbild gefunden hat und er weiß nicht, wem es gehört. So nimmt er heraus den Lichtbildausweis und wie meine Kusine das Photo darauf sieht, hat sie meine Mutter erkennt und hat gesagt: „Das ist doch meine Tante.“ Also auf diese Art und Weise hat meine Mutter den Lichtbildausweis zurück bekommen. Also ich mein...und den Mantel auch. Also...die ganze Sache, es klingt mehr...als, als ein Märchen, wie eine Legende, denn es hat sich alles so zusammen gestellt...der Ausweis...und dass wirklich durch eine Nachbarin von uns, die das in den Händen der Miliz gefunden hat und dass sie ihren Ausweis zurück bekommen hat. Das ist doch unglaublich! Mir selber ist es auch so, so etwas sehr Wunderliches vorgekommen. Also ich meine, wie eine Sache sich zusammen stellen kann.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun ja, also das war alles von dieser Evakuation! Den Rest hat man nach Auschwitz geschickt. Und damals sind ganz große Transporte nach Auschwitz gegangen. Sie können sich nicht vorstellen, was damals am Bahnhof war, wenn man die Leute nach Auschwitz transportiert hat. Man hat, man hat so Viele zusammen gestopft—Kinder und alte Frauen und Männer...alles in einem Wagon, ohne dass man wenigstens zum Stehen Platz hat. Viele sind gleich kaputt gegangen schon während des Fahrens. Die Türen waren zugenagelt, Essen hat man ihnen nicht gegeben. Und es war noch damals zwar Sommer, es war nach der [unverständlich; polnisches Wort]—es war im zehnten (10.) Monat.
David Boder: Ja, im Oktober?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Im zehnten Monat, ja im Oktober. Also wir sind zu Hause geblieben und man hat damals schon so...man hat so sehen können, wie Viele fehlen. Weil bis damals hat man nur Stückerlweise genommen, nicht wahr, einige Wenige. Obwohl insgesamt, wenn man es zusammen rechnet, hat man eine ganze Menge schon weg geschickt. Aber man hat...man hat es so systematisch gemacht. [unverständlich] genau wie ein Mensch. Wenn man mit ihm zusammen lebt, merkt man nicht, wie er sich entwickelt. Wenn man aber einen Menschen nach zehn (10) Jahren sieht, kann man ihn fast nicht erkennen. Man sieht den Unterschied,...den kolossalen Unterschied. So war es auch bei diesem. Man hat auf einmal gesehen den Unterschied, wie Viele gefehlt haben. Man hat nur junge Leute gesehen, weil die Alten hat man alle weg geschickt. Also die Stimmung war furchtbar und wir haben etwas bemerkt und zwar, dass das lange nicht halten wird. Man hat gesehen, dass alles schon so zugrunde geht, man hat nur so gelebt. Man hat schon keine Lust. Bis damals hat man noch das gehabt, dass man sich ein bisschen anzieht, dass man so einen guten Eindruck macht, darauf hatte man dann gar keine Lust. Man ist zur Arbeit gegangen, weil man musste, man hat gearbeitet und man hat gehandelt, weil man leben muss und weil man essen muss. Aber sonst mit jedem Interesse hat man das nicht gehabt. Und dann habe ich Ihnen schon erzählt, was nachher passiert ist. Man hat mich genommen und schließlich...war ich bei den Leuten von Renow. Die sind gekommen, es war so furchtbar eng, wir haben gleich durch den Schmutz Läuse bekommen. Es war furchtbar.
David Boder: Läuse?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, Läuse. Und es war so. Es war ein Transport von Mädels und von Jungen, die gekommen sind in den Dulag. Die Mädels haben im Parterre und ersten Stock gewohnt. Wir haben im zweiten (2.) und dritten (3.) Stock gewohnt. Wir durften die Mädels nicht sehen. Und ein Mädel hatte dort einen...einen Kavalier, einen Verlobten und Sie wissen ja, dass man schon in so einem Fall resigniert. Sie hat die Chance genommen und sie ist rauf gegangen und der Lagerführer hat sie geschnappt. Und dadurch sehen Sie den Sadismus dieses Mannes. Der hat nicht geschaut, dass es eine Frau ist und zwar ein Mädel und er hat sie so lange geschlagen, er hat ihr die Augen ausgeschlagen mit einer Peitsche. Das habe ich das erste Mal in meinem Leben gesehen, so was...so ein Schlagen. Und ich habe gedacht, das sei schon das Schlimmste.
David Boder: Sie haben das selbst gesehen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das habe ich selbst gesehen. Und ich habe gedacht, das sei schon das Schlimmste. Und ich habe mir damals nicht vorstellen können, dass es etwas Schlimmeres gibt. Obwohl bis damals habe ich immer gemeint, das sei schon das Schlimmste.
David Boder: Wie alt waren Sie da?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war schon Ende neunzehn hundert zwei und vierzig (1942), also ich war schon vierzehn (14) Jahre, schon vierzehn (14) Jahre.
David Boder: Vierzehn (14) Jahre.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, ich habe schon damals gedacht, das sei schon das Schlimmste. Aber nachher habe ich eben heraus gefunden, dass es noch so viel Stufen über diesen liegen, dass man es sich gar nicht vorstellen kann. Und von diesen Einzelheiten, die hier waren...man war schon...man hat schon Hunger bekommen und das Essen war nicht immer so, dass man es essen konnte. Dann hat man sich daran gewöhnt. Man hat immer gesehen, dass man einen zweiten Teller Suppe bekommt, man hat riskiert, dass man auch eine Ohrfeige bekommt, es hat nichts ausgemacht. Wir waren dort sieben (7) Tage. Unter diesen schrecklichen Bedingungen waren wir sieben (7) Tage. Dann ist gekommen...man hat gesagt, dass hundert...hundert neun und zwanzig (129) Mann nach Markstadt gehen, in ein Arbeitslager in Markstadt. Wenn Sie wollen wissen, wo Markstadt ist, das ist in der Nähe von Breslau. In der Nähe von Breslau da war eine Baustelle von Krupp. Man hat dort die Krupp Werke hergestellt. Dort waren schon zwei tausend Juden, als ich hin kam. Man hat noch viele Arbeiter gebraucht. Die Arbeit hatte begonnen für die Firma und man brauchte noch viel mehr. Aber da sie keine deutschen Arbeiter hatten und die Polnischen waren auch alle beschäftigt, also sie müssen Juden haben. Man hat von uns hundert neun und zwanzig (129) Mann hin geschickt, dazwischen waren neun und zwanzig (29) Frauen. Die neun und zwanzig (29) Frauen waren Deutsche zum größten Teil die, die jemand von die Männer gehabt haben. Das heißt, Verheiratete, Verlobte oder einen Bruder. Also solche waren von die Frauen, es waren einige hundert Frauen, aber die sind zu anderer Zeit angekommen, wann weiß ich nicht. Aber diese neun und zwanzig (29) Frauen sind mit uns gekommen. Also fast alle waren verwandt mit den Männern von den Übrigen. Also,...wir sind damals noch in Personenzügen gefahren, wir sind nach Markstadt gekommen. Es war...es war schon damals Winter. Es war kalt und nachts haben wir nichts gesehen. Wir haben erst gesehen, wir sind da auf einem großen Feld...
David Boder: Sind Sie mit Zügen gefahren?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, mit Züge. Das ist ja ungeheuer weit, das haben sie vielleicht wegen der Entfernung gemacht. [unverständlich] Jedenfalls sind wir mit Zügen gefahren. Als wir dahin kamen, das haben wir noch nichts gesehen. Wir kommen hin auf den Platz und da kommt der Wachhabende raus. Also der Wachhabende hat nicht so schrecklich ausgesehen, man war schon gewöhnt an diese Uniformen. Und dann kommt ein Herr raus mit einem Ledermantel und hatte so eine harte, fest Stimme, so eine Befehlsstimme und spricht deutsch. Na und dann hab ich gleich...habe ich bemerkt einen Judenstern, es hat gezeigt, dass er Jude ist. Und er hat damals keine spezielle Rede gehalten, aber er hat nur gleich die Schieber, das heißt die jüdischen Capos gerufen, die dafür bestellt waren und er hat gesagt wohin und in welche Baracken wir gehen sollen.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie die genannt? „Schieber“?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Schieber, ja, Kolonnen-Schieber oder Kolonnenführer.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun sagte man uns aufstellen zu...zu viert. Ja, zu viert—in diesem Lager ist man zu viert marschiert. Bis dann—vom Bahnhof zum Platz sind wir zu fünft marschiert. Und dann haben sie gesagt „Antreten!“ und wir haben das nicht gewusst, dass man da zu viert geht und wir haben uns aufgestellt zu fünft. Da waren drei (3) Brüder dazwischen, die waren in unserem Transport und die wollten zusammen in einer Reihe stehen, damit sie auch zusammen schlafen gehen sollen. Aber da wir zu fünft aufgestellt waren, ist es so gewesen, dass jeder fünfte (5.) Mann weggehen musste. Und es war auch das Schicksal von einem der drei (3) Brüder, dass er auch von den zwei (2) Brüdern getrennt werden musste. Und er war noch nicht gewöhnt, dass man so...dass man so einem Capo nicht widerreden darf. Wenn er es darf, dann muss man sich einig sein und man muss es sofort ausüben. Und er hat gesagt, das ist doch mein Bruder. Und da hat er ihm Verschiedene runter gehauen, aber so arg...
David Boder: War das ein jüdischer Capo?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, das war ein jüdischer Capo. Also das nagt auf den Menschen, das macht dass man ein [unverständlich; Tonband sehr schlecht—laut und leise und viel Rauschen]. Hier ist ein Jud und er schlägt mich. Man sagt ich, er ist ein Jude und er ist genau das selbe, wie ich, aber weil er [unverständlich]...das macht etwas, das macht Angst und das macht revolutionär—man sagt, das kann ich nicht machen, ich kann das Maul nicht halten. Das macht etwas in dem Menschen. Und den Anderen macht es noch mehr als dem, der eigentlich geschlagen wird. Und ich muss es leider bedauern, ich schäme mich direkt, dass ich so eine Sache erzählen muss, aber es war so—die reine Wahrheit.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja und nachdem der Jüdische dem Mann eine runter gehaut hat, ist gekommen einer der Polizisten, die uns hier her geführt haben.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 87—we are going over to 88.
David Boder: [In English] This is Spool 91, and is a continuation of Kimmelmann’s report from Spool 88.
David Boder: [In German] Also Sie haben dort gearbeitet und haben sich an das Essern allmählich gewöhnt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun das ist...[Tonband setzt aus]...das ich so...einen kleinen Teil...von dem Essen, was ich Ihnen bis jetzt erzählt habe. Nun will ich aber...
David Boder: Sie haben erzählt, von dem Jungen, der zehn (10 Liter Suppe gegessen hat, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Nun will ich Ihnen aber die allgemeinen Bedingungen im Lager...wir man im Lager überhaupt gelebt hat, erzählen.
David Boder: Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Morgens, das heißt um fünf (5) Uhr früh „Wach auf!“ Um fünf (5) Uhr waren wir auf, das heißt man musste sich schnell anziehen und waschen, wer es gewollt hat, im Anfang haben wir uns noch alle gewaschen, weil wir waren das noch von zu Hause gewöhnt. Und um halb sechs (6) war Appell, das heißt antreten, wir mussten antreten auf dem Appellplatz. Es war so üblich in diesem Lager, dass drei (3) Mal Antreten war. Es waren Gruppen, die weit weg von dem Lager gearbeitet haben, ich habe auch dazu gehört. Wir sind um sechs Uhr vom Lager wegmarschiert. Da war noch vorher eine Frühschicht Gruppe, das heißt, die schon um sechs (6) Uhr zu arbeiten begonnen haben und die sind noch um fünf (5) Uhr angetreten. Und die letzte Gruppe war um halb sieben (7), also die, die in der Nähe vom Lager gearbeitet haben und nicht mehr als eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde dort hin gebraucht haben. Der Appell ist in dieser Weise vorgekommen, dass wir uns Gruppen-...Firmenweise, je nach Kommando, haben wir angetreten. Der Schieber hat gewusst, dass er so und so viele Leute haben muss und der Vorstand ist raus gekommen auf den Platz, da war es fünfzehn (15) Minuten vor sechs (6) und er hat schnell zwei (2) Pfiffe gegeben, dass die Schieber sich versammeln und hat ausgerufen nach der Firma. Es hat zum Beispiel gerufen die Firma Basow und dann hat der Vorstand gesagt „zwei und zwanzig“ (22) oder et cetera und dann hat er die Arbeitszettel verteilt und dann sind...
David Boder: Was heißt Arbeitszettel?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das heißt solche Zettel, die die Meister abgeben müssen und der Meister hat unterschrieben, dass alle zur Arbeit gekommen waren, nicht wahr. Dann sind die Schieber wieder zu ihrer Kolonne zurück gekommen und um sechs (6) Uhr, genau um sechs (6) Uhr ist der Wachhabende mit dem dicken Bauch, ist herein gekommen so ganz grossartig. Und der Vorstand hat geschrien, wenn er seine Meldung gemacht hat „Alles Achtung—still gestanden, Kappen ab“.
David Boder: Und war er ein Jude?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war ein Jude, ja. Er war polnischer Offizier beim polnischen Militär und hat es sehr gut gemacht—„Herr Wachhabender, ich werde gehorsam melden, so und so viel Juden sind angetreten“.
David Boder: War der Lagerkommandant ein Jude?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, der Lagerkommandant war ein doch Christ, ein Deutscher, der Lagerführer, der Vorstand war ein Jude. Er hat gesagt: „Herr Kommandant, wir haben so und so viele Juden zur Arbeit angetreten, so und so viel sind im Revier, so und so viel Frühschicht, so und so viel Tagschicht, insgesamt so und so viele.“ Also jeden Tag war der selbe Rapport und als das fertig war—es hat nur gedauert einige Minuten, oder vielleicht war es noch ein bisschen länger, wenn man früh angetreten ist, bis die Wache sich versammelt hat, dieser Wachmeister ist gekommen zu seiner Kolonne und er war bestimmt und hat uns geführt bewacht zu der Arbeit.
David Boder: Die Wachen waren SS?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein. Damals noch nicht, sie waren keine SS, ich habe Ihnen doch erzählt, es war die Wehrmacht.
David Boder: Ja, die Wehrmacht, aber es war Militär.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, es war Militär, Deutsche, die zu Urlaub gekommen sind oder solche, die ein bisschen krank waren und zur Front konnten sie nicht mehr gehen zum Kämpfen, aber für Bewachung waren sie gut...
David Boder: Ja?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . und die haben dieses Amt übernommen. Als wir zu der Baustelle kamen, sind wir in der Firma zu dem Meister gegangen, haben uns gleich wieder angetreten. Der Meister ist raus gekommen und hat uns angeschaut und hat gezeigt jeden auf seinen Platz. Also es waren verschiedene Firmen, es waren Firmen wo man nur Fach...wo nur Facharbeiter gesucht wurden. Aber diese Leute, die haben schon—was die Arbeit anbelangt—die haben es besser gehabt. Denn wenn man seine Facharbeit macht, seinen Beruf, ist das mehr interessant im Vergleich, wenn man so harte Arbeit macht, wo man kein Interesse dafür hat. Obwohl im Großen und Ganzen hat niemand Interesse gehabt für die Deutschen zu leisten. Aber wenn man schon...wenn man weiß, dass man die Arbeit machen muss, dann ist es doch viel besser, wenn man...wenn man eine interessantere Arbeit hat. Aber im Allgemeinein...die Kolonnen waren Strassenarbeit und man hat immer verteilt...die Gruppe geht da und da...so verschiedene. Und wenn es eine große Kolonne war mehrere Wachmeister sind gegangen und der Wachmeister musste den ganzen Tag stehen und uns bewachen. Ich habe eine Zeitlang gearbeitet bei dieser Firma, so Transport und Straßenbau; nach einiger Zeit bin ich dann zu einer anderen Firma übergangen und ich werden Ihnen dann noch weiter erzählen. Ich möchte Ihnen jetzt erzählen, wie die Dinge bei der Arbeit waren und dann wieder im Lager. Also wir haben gearbeitet bis zwölf (12) Uhr ohne eine Unterbrechung...immer mit dem...wie heißt das...dem Geschrei von dem Meister und so weiter...und...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . und von dem Posten, ja wir würden andauernd angeschrieen. Und wir haben einfach bei der...bei der Schaufel gezittert. Um zwölf (12) Uhr haben wir eine halbe ( ½ ) Stunde gehabt; wer...wer noch so viel starken Willen gehabt hat, um das Brot zu behalten bis zwölf (12) Uhr hat es gegessen. Und die Anderen haben zuschauen müssen und Jeder hat sich damals gewünscht, ihm das Brot auf dem Mund raus zu reißen.
David Boder: Aha.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und mit gierigen Augen haben sie selber geschaut auf das Brot. Ich weiß es selber, denn wenn ich kein Brot zu Mittag gehabt habe—und das ist sehr oft passiert, es hat nur manchmal passiert, wenn ich Eines gehabt habe, aber meistens sonst habe nichts gehabt—dann habe ich nur geschaut auf die Wenigen, die aßen. Und ich bin dann hinaus, ich hab nicht zuschauen können, wie Andere essen, weil ich furchtbar Hunger gehabt habe. Halb eins sind wir wieder zu der Arbeit gegangen und haben wieder gearbeitet und während dem Tag sind noch gekommen verschiedene Offiziere kontrollieren die Wache und zur gleichen Zeit haben sie auch uns kontrolliert. Und wenn es Einem nicht gepasst hat oder um uns Angst zu machen, haben sie die Namen aufgeschrieben und eine Meldung ist gekommen in das Lager und die Exekution haben—die jüdischen „Kats“—die jüdischen Henker, die sogenannten Henker, die haben das ausgeführt in Gegenwart von dem Wachhabenden haben sie haben die Exekution durchgeführt.
David Boder: Worüber haben sie das getan?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also, das war so. Zum Beispiel: genau wie zu Hause als wir waren, konnten wir auch nicht leben von der Ration, die wir bekommen haben. Wir mussten uns auf irgend eine Weise Essen verschaffen. Und so war es im Lager auch. Es haben viele Zivilarbeiter gearbeitet und man hat es auf irgend eine Weise gedreht. Wenn man noch ein gutes Hemd von zu Hause gehabt hat, dann hat man es verkauft und man ist ohne Hemd gelaufen. Und so...und so, wenn man eine Zigarette eben geschnappt hat, dann hat man sie für Brot vertauscht und so weiter. Das war doch ein großes Verbrechen, dafür hat man geschlagen bekommen oder wenn jemand nicht...nicht speziell gut gearbeitet hat. Also es war auch nicht...man hat es nicht so begriffen, die Leute haben das nicht verstanden oder haben das nicht verstanden oder haben es nicht verstehen wollen. Solche Männer sind tagtäglich in das Lager gekommen und dafür hat man bekommen Schläge mit der Peitsche, was ich Ihnen schon erzählt habe—und es war abhängig, hm,...das Quantum der Schläge war abhängig von der Wache...wie viele er gedacht hat
David Boder: Sind Sie mal so dran gekommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, ich hab auch schon mal Schläge bekommen, als...ich habe damals bei der Firma [Name unverständlich] Blech gearbeitet. Das ist eine Firma, welche Bahngeleise...Bahngeleise und Kommunikation—und, und im Winter, es war sehr kalt hat man eine Gruppe zugeteilt in eine fertige Halle. Das war schon damals, das war schon eine Weile später, als ich ein Jahr lange da war. Da bin ich...sind wir in eine Halle zugeteilt worden, das war schon eine fertige Halle, wo man Kanonen ausgearbeitet hat, Hamatten. Dort musste man das Geleise reparieren und ich hatte einige Zigaretten bei mir und es geht vorbei ein Tscheche, ein Ziviler, und er fragte mich, ob ich Zigaretten habe. Denn die haben schon gewusst, dass wir Zigaretten haben, denn wir haben manchmal eine Zuteilung von Zigaretten bekommen und da ich nicht geraucht habe...
David Boder: War der Tscheche ein Häftling?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, nein, er war kein Häftling. Aber da ich...
David Boder: Sie haben Zigaretten als Zuteilung im Lager bekommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, also nicht immer, aber manches Mal und da ich nicht geraucht habe, habe ich eben es...es gesammelt.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und...ich schaue mich um, ob der Wachmann nicht da ist und ich ging mit ihm auf die Toilette und ich wollte ihm die Zigaretten geben. Aber der Wachmann hat mich beobachtet und ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und als er sah, dass ich mit ihm rein ging, ist er gleich nach gekommen und hat so ganz langsam die Tür geöffnet...und, und er wollte mir Brot geben.
David Boder: Der Tscheche?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Der Tscheche, ja. Und ich habe noch meine Zigaretten in der Hose versteckt gehabt, weil man durfte sie nicht an sich tragen. Kommt er herein und er hat zu mir gesagt: „Was machst Du da?“ und ich habe gesagt: „Ich geh nur austreten.“ Sagt er: „Ja, Du gehst schwindeln, Du gehst handeln.“ Und ich habe schon kein Wort mehr sprechen können, ich habe gewusst, was mich da erwartet. Und er hat mich gleich genommen und er hat mich auf eine Stelle geführt, dann hat er mich aufgeschrieben. Dann hat er mich ausgezogen und gesucht, ob ich Geld bei mir hätte oder so, aber er hat nichts gefunden, dann ist eine Meldung gekommen ins Lager.
David Boder: Hat er die Zigaretten gefunden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, die Zigaretten hat er gefunden. Er hat sie sofort zu genommen und eine Meldung in das Lager und wenn ich zurück ins Lager kam, da hat man mich gleich gerufen. Der Vorstand hat schon davon gewusst und er hat uns in gerufen in die „Kaltverpflegungsstube“, also dort von wo man die kalte Verpflegung ausgegeben hat. Dort hat man geschlagen. Der Lagerführer ist herein gekommen, dort haben auch noch andere Jungs gewartet; es waren da noch fünf (5) Jungs, die ohne Posten ins Lager gekommen sind. Sie sind ins Lager gekommen, aber ohne Posten, denn sie waren...sie waren eine Gruppe, die in einer Werkstatt gearbeitet haben und die hatten keinen Posten und der Meister war verantwortlich für sie. Als sie mit der Arbeit...als sie die Arbeit fertig hatten, war schon der Wachmeister mit der grösseren Teil der Kolonnenzahl zu Hause, sie hatten keine Wachmeister.
David Boder: Haben sie warten müssen? Was war die Regel?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die Regel war, dass sie irgendeinen Wachmeister suchen sollen oder sich anschließen oder melden. Und sie haben das nicht gemacht. Und noch Einer, der hat auf dem Bahnhof Rüben gestohlen...
David Boder: Ja. Also was heißt gestohlen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Er hat Hunger gehabt und war froh, dass er eine Rübe gefunden hatte, die rausgerollt ist von einem Wagon. Rüben haben sie...viele, viele Rüben waren auf dem Fußboden und sind verfault geworden, da ist auch eine Meldung über ihn gekommen. Also es war so ungefähr [unverständlich] und als man nach dem Essen ihn schlug, da habe ich nicht mehr zuschauen können und ich habe die Hosen ausgezogen und ich habe mich hin gelegt. Ich hab mich damals so gefürchtet...ich habe die beiden, die mich gehalten haben, habe ich runter geschmissen. Der Stuhl, er Stuhl hat sich...ist unter dem Bauch weggerutscht und wir sind alle drei (3) umgeflogen. Nachdem ich die Schläge bekommen habe, habe ich schon nicht mehr aufstehen können. Schließlich hab ich aufstehen müssen, denn sie haben mich so lange geschlagen, bis ich von der Kaltverpflegungstube raus bin.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gesagt??
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . bis ich von der Kaltverpflegungstube raus bin, so lange haben sie mich geschlagen. Wenn man Einen geschlagen hat, dann hatte er schon keine Kraft mehr, nicht wahr. Er kann in diesem selben Moment nicht mehr aufstehen, man muss einen Moment liegen und da nützten sie weiter aus die Gelegenheit und haben weiter geschlagen. Wenn man nicht so kräftig ist, um gleich wegzulaufen, bekommt man so lange Schläge bis man einfach muss oder liegen bleiben—ja, so war es.
David Boder: Also sie haben Sie losgelassen nach so und so viel Schläge?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, nach den Schlägen haben sie mich los gelassen,...
David Boder: Aber sie konnten nicht aufstehen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aufstehen habe ich nicht können...aber schließlich bin ich aufgestanden. Ich hab mir nur die Hosen angezogen und ich bin raus u.nd als ich in die Stube kam, da haben mir Bekannte Kompressen gemacht. Und morgens hat man gesehen was ich habe, der Lagerarzt hat gesagt eine Mappe.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Da waren verschieden Striche—Schwarze und Blaue—und die haben so eine Mappe gebildet.
David Boder: Eine Karte gebildet.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, eine Karte gebildet. Nun ja, nun will ich wieder zurück zu der Arbeit. Nach Mittag haben wir wieder gearbeitet in dieser Firma, wo ich war, bis fünf (5) Uhr. Um fünf (5) Uhr haben wir wieder antreten müssen und um ungefähr sechs (6) Uhr waren wir zu Hause. Dann haben wir wieder Mittag geholt. Und es war noch in diesem Lager ziemlich gut, weil es Baderäume gegeben hat. Man konnte sich baden gehen.
David Boder: Heißes oder kaltes Wasser?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, im Winter war heißes Wasser, da war ein Bademeister eingestellt, der dafür gesorgt hat. Und dann wieder zurück in kalte Zimmer.
David Boder: Die Zimmer wurden nicht geheizt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die Zimmer wurden nicht beheizt, sie hatten keine Kohlen. Und nachdem...nachdem, als das Mittagessen fertig waren haben wir uns gebadet und jeden Tag haben zwei andere Mann Dienst gehabt, die kalte Verpflegung zu holen und das Zimmer sauber zu machen und um zehn (10) Uhr musste sein Licht aus; und jeder muss im Bett liegen. So da fing an die richtige Tragödie. Erstens, ob es Winter war, ob es kalt war, musste man die ganze Nacht im Zimmer Nachtwache halten. Also wir waren sechs und zwanzig (26) Mann auf einer Stube und wir haben es so ausgemacht, dass jede Stunde ein Anderer Nachtwache hat. Das war so ungefähr, dass jeder jeden dritten Tag Wache halten musste—jeden dritten (3.) Tag eine Stunde.
David Boder: Wie lange?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Eine Stunde. Es war nur eine Stunde, aber mitten im Schlaf—und wir haben so und so nicht so viel Stunden zum Schlafen gehabt—da musste man aufstehen, ob es kalt war oder nicht, wir hatten nichts anzuziehen und so eine Stunde zu wachen. Wenn Sie das noch nicht mitgemacht haben, da kann ich Ihnen sagen, dass ich....das ist viel, viel zu lange als man sich vorstellt.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man findet sich...
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir, was haben Sie bewachen müssen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hat auf sein müssen und es waren auch Kolonnen-Älteste, die Nachtwache gehabt haben und sie sind in alle...in alle Zimmer gegangen—und wenn so ein Kolonnen Ältester herein gekommen ist, hat man sich aufstellen müssen und melden: „Ich melde gehorsam Stube die und die“—wir hatten Stube Nummer sechs und zwanzig (26) gehabt und da musste ich sagen: „Stube 26 ist belegt von so und so viel Juden und das stimmt.“
David Boder: Sie haben nicht gesagt Menschen, sie haben immer gesagt Juden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Juden, ja. Dann hat er sich umgeschaut und wenn er nichts, wenn er nichts finden wollte, dann ist er raus gegangen. Aber das—der Kolonnen Älteste, das war meistens so, die waren nicht die Schlimmsten. Und Kolonnen-Älteste, das waren verschiedene, das waren viele Leute. Diese Kolonnen Ältesten, dadurch dass sie gute Arbeiter waren und der Meister hat sie dazu ernannt, so dass es nicht speziell ausgesuchte Leute waren. Aber die am meisten im Lager geschadet haben, das waren die drei „Kats“, also Einer—ich habe schon gesagt den Namen—Einer hat geheißen Hershel Moch, der Zweite Moishel Fonyi und der Dritte war Bozak...
David Boder: Juden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Alles Juden, nur Juden., außer die Wache. Sie sind jeden Abend durch alle Zimmer gegangen und haben geschaut, ob ein Schrank offen war, ob es Staub gibt, ob unter dem Bett kein Stroh liegt, denn wir haben auf dem Stroh geschlafen; und wir mussten es so machen, wir durften uns nicht bewegen, sonst war gleich Stroh unterm Bett. Für ein Stück Stroh hat der Stuben Älteste—in jeder Stube war ein Stuben Älteste—der für das Zimmer verantwortlich war. Er hat nix bekommen, er war nur verantwortlich. Wenn etwas nicht geklappt hat, hat er es in erster Linie bekommen. Also wenn man ein Stück Stroh, ein kleines Stück Stroh, wenn man das gefunden hat, hat man den Stuben Ältesten so geschlagen, dass er gleich am Boden liegen geblieben ist. Dann hat man genommen jeden Einen von uns fünf und zwanzig (25) und die haben ihre Portion bekommen.
David Boder: Ja, hat man das Stroh gesucht, nachdem der Raum aufgeräumt war?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, nachdem die Stube gereinigt war.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber stellen Sie sich vor, wir hatten keine guten Besen, Besen mussten wir uns selber verschaffen. Wir haben solche...das Unkraut ausgerissen auf die Felder und daraus haben wir Besen gemacht. Wir haben keine zugeteilten Besen gehabt. Man kann nicht, es geht nicht gut zusammen. Man...also, es ist so. In den ersten Tagen haben wir gemacht, wie es nur möglich war. Man hat sich unters Bett gelegt und man hat ein Stück Stroh gesucht. Aber schließlich, man gewöhnt sich, man sagt sich: „Ich bin fast ums Leben kommen, ich kann nicht mehr, ich hab...ich bin müde von der Arbeit, ich kann nicht mehr.“ Und so, wenn sie am Abend herein gekommen sind, zwei (2), drei (3) und sie haben natürlich nicht unter jedes Bett geschaut, denn sie hätten dazu zu viel Zeit gebraucht.
David Boder: Jeder musste unter seinem eigenen Bett sauber machen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, sie haben da so Stichproben gemacht und manches Mal sind sie nicht in alle Zimmer gekommen, aber die Angst war da jede Nacht. Also ich kann ich Ihnen sagen, dass ich jede Nacht bis eins (1) oder zwei (2) nicht geschlafen habe, bis ich mich dazu gewöhnt habe.
David Boder: Also wenn haben die nach Stroh gesucht? Also während der Nacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, während der Nacht. Also ich habe...
David Boder: Wenn man sich rum dreht, kann doch ein Stück Stroh runterfallen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Eben, wenn man sich ins Bett legt, ich habe immer geschaut, wenn ich im Bett lag, habe ich mich runter gedreht, um zu sehen, ob ich jetzt beim Liegen nicht etwas verschmutzt habe oder ob ein Stück Stroh runter gefallen ist. Also sie sind die erste Nacht reingekommen, wir waren noch neu, sie haben was anbelangt, was das, hm, was die Reinheit, hm, was die Reinheit anbelangt, haben sie nicht Besonderes gefunden. Sie haben gesucht und die haben nichts Besonderes gefunden. Aber sie haben etwas Anderes gefunden—dass Einer ein bisschen schmutzige Beine gehabt hat, und deswegen haben sie gleich den Stuben Ältesten so geschlagen, dass er ins Revier gebracht werden musste und jeder von uns hat Fünf und Zwanzig (25)bekommen.
David Boder: Was meine Sie—jeder?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Jeder einer von der Stube, das heißt Jeder hat Fünf-und-Zwanzig (25) bekommen.
David Boder: Warum? Was haben sie Schuld gehabt, dass er schmutzige Beine gehabt hat?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Weil man hat nie Jemanden gefragt, ob er Schuld hat und durfte man sich dann überhaupt verteidigen? Wenn Jemand nur ein Wort gesprochen hat, hat man ihn gleich verdoppelt. Wir haben versucht—in der ersten Zeit haben wir nichts gewusst davon. Wir haben versucht uns zu verteidigen, aber dann haben wir noch mehr bekommen. Dann haben wir eingesehen...
David Boder: Das war in der Nacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also das war alles in der Nacht. Man kann sagen...
David Boder: Und man hat angefangen die Leute dann zu schlagen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, auf dem Zimmer—man hat einen Stuhl genommen und man hat geschlagen.
David Boder: Sechs und zwanzig (26) Leute...
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sechs und zwanzig (26) Leute...
David Boder: . . . aber da nimmt doch auch Zeit.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja eben, aber sie haben doch nicht in jedem Zimmer so viele Leute geschlagen.
David Boder: Ja, aber Sie sagen doch, sie haben auch alle Übrigen geschlagen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, wenn man gefunden hat...wenn man etwas finden wollte. Schließlich ist es so, sie waren manchmal müde nur vom Schlagen. Wenn sie schon müde waren, sind sie nach Hause schlafen gegangen.
David Boder: Wer?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die, die, die...
David Boder: Helfer?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, die Helfer.
David Boder: Ja, und waren dies...war das unter Aufsicht der Deutschen oder die haben das von selbst gemacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war von ihrer eigenen Initiative.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war so: der Wachhabende hat verlangt, das es soll sein...dass es soll sein sauber.
David Boder: Das war der Deutsche?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, das war der Deutsche, das hat er verlangt von den Lager Ältesten.
David Boder: Und wenn es nicht sauber war, wenn der Wachhabende etwas gefunden hat, wer wurde bestraft?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Bestraft, es hat noch niemals passiert, dass jemand von den Lager Ältesten bestraft wurde, denn sie haben es so gemacht, dass es niemals dazu gekommen ist. Nun und so können Sie sich vorstellen, dass wenn man, zum Beispiel, in einer anderen Baracke geschlagen hat, so hat man doch das Jammern und das Geschrei im Bett gehört und in der ersten Zeit bin ich niemals früher eingeschlafen, als um zwei (2) Uhr. Ich habe gehört „uh...uh“ von ganz weit. Das Lager war kolossal gross...hat man, hat man das Jammern die Schreie gehört. Das macht etwas...das macht etwas. Ich kann Ihnen sagen, ich es macht etwas auf den Menschen und man...man wird wie paralysiert. Es hat es bei uns allen öfters gegeben Schläge—überhaupt in den ersten Zeiten. Sie wollten uns mehr Angst machen—die Neuen und man hat uns geschlagen, bis Einer hat geblutet...und also...die Nacht war furchtbar. Wenn ich bei der Arbeit war, habe ich gedacht, ich bin bald mit der Arbeit fertig und ich komme ins Lager. Wenn ich im Lager war, habe ich wieder gebetet, ich soll vom Lager wieder heraus. Also es war kein Platz für mich, wo ich sagen konnte, ja, da bin ich zufrieden. Es hat das überhaupt nicht gegeben, es hat keine Stunde gegeben, wo ich...wirklich der Moment war bei mir bevor ich gegessen habe, das heißt, wenn ich meine Portion Brot im Beutel gehabt hab, in dem Rucksack—wir haben uns solche Rucksäcke selber genäht—das war der—für mich der glücklichste Moment. Ich habe gewusst, ich hab noch zu essen...wenn ich essen will, habe ich zu essen. So bald ich es aufgegessen habe, da hatte ich schon verloren die Hoffnung. Und so ist es zeitenlang. Wir sind gekommen von der Arbeit und wir haben uns angeschaut und wir haben uns gar nicht mehr erkannt, weil wir uns erinnert haben, wie wir vorher ausgesehen haben.
David Boder: Hat man Ihre Haare abgeschoren?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Alles, alles hat man uns abgeschoren, wir haben nicht mehr wie Menschen ausgesehen. Die Kleider, die von Anfang an noch ziemlich gut waren, bei der Arbeit...wissen Sie, wenn man immer die selben Kleider trägt, die nützen sich ab, die gehen kaputt und so weiter.
David Boder: War dort nicht ein Schneider, der sie repariert?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war eine Schneiderei, es war...die Frauen haben dort gearbeitet, aber wenn man nur eine Hose gehabt hat und die war zerrissen, mit was soll man zur Arbeit gehen? Man hat es nur damals abgeben können, wenn man nicht zur Arbeit gegangen ist. Zum Beispiel, es waren Firmen, die sonntags nicht gearbeitet haben. Da haben sie Samstag abends in die Schneiderstube die Hosen gegeben und Sonntag abends haben sie sie wieder abgeholt. Aber...drei tausend (3,000) Mann! Wieviel können sie flicken?
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man, man...es hat fast niemand was in die Schneiderstube gegeben. In der Schneiderstube ist nur gearbeitet worden für das Lager Personal. Sie haben sich dort schöne Kleider gemacht und die Schusterei ist auch...
David Boder: Welches Personal? Die SS?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die SS und die Anderen, das andere Personal
David Boder: . . . und die Block Ältesten?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja,. Die Block Ältesten und die Kolonnen Schieber, die haben sich Stiefeln machen lassen und alles Mögliche, also...
David Boder: Haben die Deutschen ihnen das erlaubt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, das war das Prinzip und die Ausrechnung der Deutschen, sie haben gewusst so: wenn sie einem Juden gut zu essen geben und gut zu kleiden, und damit der Jude...und die betreffende Person wir dann immer Angst haben, dass er seinen Job nicht verlieren soll und von dem war auch abhängig sein Leben. Wenn er seinen Posten verloren hat, dann mus er auch zu Grunde gehen—gleich wie die Anderen. So war er bereit hundert Andere tot zu schlagen, dass er nicht seinen Posten verlieren soll. So dass sich die Deutschen überhaupt nicht um die ganze Lagerbelegschaft kümmern mussten. Sie haben nur einen Juden dafür eingesetzt und die haben schon die beste Ordnung hergestellt und wie sie es nur gewollt haben und manchmal besser als sie es gewollt haben. Das war...das war ihr Konzept in alle Lagern.
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, das ist so ungefähr ein Überblick—was ich Ihnen schon erzählt habe—über das Lagerleben, wie es gegangen ist. Sonntags...sonntags war ein spezieller Appell, die Zimmer müssen noch speziell gereinigt werden und der Wachhabende ist jeden Sonntag herum gegangen...schauen gegangen in jedes Zimmer, ob es sauber ist. Also bis zwölf (12) Uhr hatten wir kein Zimmer mehr. Ob es kalt war oder nicht, wir mussten draußen stehen und wenn sie sauber waren, dann durfte niemand mehr hinein oder betreten. Vor zwölf (12) Uhr, das heißt um halb zwölf war Appell. Wir sind angetreten, wir wurden gezählt und wieder gezählt und wir sind wieder eine halbe Stunde gestanden. Da sind wir so lange gestanden bis der Wachhabende mit dem Vorstand und noch einige von den Prominenten sind durchgegangen und haben sich angeschaut diese Zimmer. Und wenn es ihnen irgendwo nicht gefallen hat, so hat man gesagt, die Mann von der Stube, sie bleiben stehen. Die haben entweder kein Mittag bekommen oder man hat die Übung gemacht—also Übung, die nicht zu der physischen Entwicklung gehört, sondern dazu den Menschen kaputt zu machen. Strafübung wurden gemacht und das haben sie für den Sonntag vorgehabt. Da waren—also sozusagen am Nachmittag hatten wir einige Stunden Ruhe für uns. Und wenn das Lager Personal sich auch ausruhen wollte, dann haben sie uns auch in Ruhe gelassen. Das war das Einzige—Sonntag Nachmittag—sonst hatten wie niemals Ruhe. Also ich spreche jetzt vom Judenlager...
David Boder: Welches Lager war das?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war das Judenlager Martin. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr so genau erinnern an alle Einzelheiten. Aber wenn ich das in kurzen Worten zusammenfassen soll, dann muss ich Ihnen sagen, ich hätte mir niemals im Leben vorgestellt, obwohl ich habe schon der jüdischen Miliz zu Hause zugesehen—ich habe beobachtet alle schrecklichen Sachen, die diese gemacht haben—ich hätte mir niemals vorgestellt, dass ein Jude dem Anderen so etwas machen kann. Zur Zeit und da bin ich überzeugt...also ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll. Aber ich kann unternehmen zu sagen, dass die Leute wenig bewusst...bewusst sind. Denn ich hab...in der Einleitung hab ich gesagt, dass wenn ich mir vorstelle, was hätte ich gemacht an ihrer...an ihrer Stelle, so kann ich gar nicht antworten. Ich bin heute mir sicher zu sagen: „Nein, ich hätte nie...ich hätte so einen Posten nicht angenommen.“ Der Mensch ist damals nicht verantwortlich für das, was er macht. Aber es ist [unverständlich], dass es so passiert hat. Man hat uns geschlagen, man hat so Viele ermordet, dass man das nicht zählen kann. Und das war ein Judenlager, wo man nur unter Juden lebt und war. Und doch war ein Jude bereit den Zweiten totzuschlagen nur für ein bisschen Brot und [unverständlich] man hat den Zweiten überhaupt nicht als Mensch betrachtet und die Person selber war auch kein Mensch mehr.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es war also...
David Boder: Wie sind Sie dann von diesem Lager weg?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also in diesem Lager war ich, hm, ein Jahr lang...mehr...vierzehn (14) Monate, nein also dreizehn (13) Monate...im März bin ich...
David Boder: In welchem Jahr war das?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war neunzehn hundert zwei und vierzig (1942) bis drei und vierzig (43).
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und...dort waren wir in diesem Lager an das ich mich schon ein bisschen gewöhnt habe, da haben—wir haben zusammen gelebt sechs und zwanzig (26) Mann in einer Stube, also die sechs und zwanzig (26) Mann wo ich war, wir haben uns ein bisschen besser verhalten, ein bisschen menschlicher. Es waren dort Leute—mehr Intelligente, mehr, die die sich ein bisschen von den Ganzen beherrscht haben und sie haben nicht alles so aufgefasst, wie die ganze Belegschaft des Lager, man hat so ein bisschen zusammen gelebt. Es war mir wirklich...ein großes Unglück war für mich, dass wir uns jetzt...dass wir uns damals trennen mussten. Nun schließlich ist der März drei und vierzig (43) eingetroffen und man hat am Anfang März...
David Boder: Haben Sie in dieser Zeit etwas von zu Hause gehört?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, das habe ich auch vergessen zu erzählen. Also in den ersten Monaten habe ich noch Briefe von zu Hause bekommen. Also ich habe Briefe illegal bekommen. Es waren sehr viele zivile Polen, die in Baustelle gearbeitet haben zusammen mit uns, die haben—zu Hause haben sie Geld bekommen—viel Geld, um uns etwas zu benachrichtigen.
David Boder: Wie weit waren Sie von zu Hause?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also von Breslau bis Katowice—ich weiß nicht genau—ungefähr hundert (100) Kilometer. Ich weiß das nicht ganz genau, aber es war nicht so weit und sie sind immer nach Hause gefahren und haben die Adressen aufgeschrieben...
David Boder: Das waren polnische Zivilisten?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Polnische Zivilisten.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, ich kann doch...gerade habe ich vernommen—damals im Jahre drei und vierzig (43) habe ich vernommen,...nach einigen Monaten da habe ich vernommen, dass man, hm, [unverständlich; polnischer Name] Juden-rein gemacht hat und die alle sind nach Auschwitz gekommen.
David Boder: Welche Stadt hat man Juden-rein gemacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ganz Zagrumbia, das heißt Dabrowa, Bensburg and Sosnowiec.
David Boder: Ganz was?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Zagrumbia heißt das.
David Boder: Zagrumbia?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, Zagrumbia.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Von damals her, habe ich schon keine Nachrichten von meiner Familie bis heute...und ich weiß heute...[beide sprechen].
David Boder: Wer ist zu Hause geblieben? Ihre Schwester und Ihre Mutter?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Meine Schwester und meine Mutter.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, dazwischen sind noch von dort, wo man Juden-rein gemacht hat, sind Transporte von fünfzig (50) Milizsoldaten nach Markstadt in unser Lager gekommen. Dort haben sie...viele Leute haben Rache genommen. Obwohl die unter schlechten Bedingungen gelebt haben und unterdrückt, aber sie haben wenigstens das gemacht, das was sie wollten. Da heißt sie haben die Miliz geschlagen, weil sie haben doch gewusst Bescheid, was...was sie zu Hause mit ihrer Familie gemacht haben.
David Boder: Nun—wenn ein Häftling den Anderen geschlagen hat, wurde er dafür bestraft?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es kommt darauf an...es ist darauf angekommen auf die Stimmung des...
David Boder: Block Ältesten.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, des Block Ältesten.
David Boder: Man hat sich aber hin und dann herumgeschlagen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, und von einer Seite waren sie zufrieden, dass man sich schlägt und dann haben sie genommen...dann haben sie beide genommen und tot geschlagen. Es hat doch keine Rolle gespielt ein Mensch war doch nicht wichtig.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und im März drei und vierzig (43) hat man gehört, dass alle Zivillager—und es hat noch geheißen ein Zivillager, weil wir noch keine Häftlingskleider getragen haben, wir haben nur Davidsterne getragen—alle, die noch unter der Wehrmacht unter standen, die müssen ab und in neuester Zeit müssen sie der SS unterliegen. Die SS hat alle Lager übernommen und davor haben wir uns noch mehr gefürchtet als vor den Judenlagern. Denn damals—während der ganzen Zeit—dazwischen wo wir im Lager waren, haben sie noch ein Lager gebaut. Wir haben nicht gewusst für wen des Lager eigentlich gebaut wurde und was für ein Lager das sein wird. Und dann haben wir uns überzeugt, dass wir selber für uns das Lager gebaut haben. Das war das Konzentrationslager Fünfteichen.
David Boder: Wo?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Fünfteichen.
David Boder: Wie hat das geheißen in polnisch?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also polnisch...das war ein deutsche Stadt...
David Boder: Fünfteichen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, Fünfteichen.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war fünf (5) Kilometer weg von Markstadt.
David Boder: Ja und?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, eines Tages—ich weiß nicht mehr genau das Datum, aber ich weiß jedenfalls, dass es im März war, sind einige...
David Boder: Im Jahre drei und vierzig?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. Da sind einige Obersturmbandführer gekommen von der SS und man hat eine Selektion durchgeführt. Das heißt, es ist gekommen ein Arzt und wer nicht sehr gesund war, den hat man gleich nach Auschwitz geschickt und der Rest...den Rest hat man in das Konzentrationslager Fünfteichen geschickt. Also wir waren damals achtzehn hundert (1800) Mann, die ins das Konzentrationslager gekommen sind. Nun da hat wieder angefangen ein anderes Leben. Was sich von dem Tag an...
David Boder: Haben Sie noch weiter in der Fabrik gearbeitet?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, also die Baustelle war dieselbe. Wir haben, hm, wir haben weiter auf der selben Baustelle gearbeitet, denn ich habe Ihnen gesagt, es war nur fünf (5) Kilometer entfernt. Und deshalb haben sie ja das Lager so in der Nähe gebaut, dass wir weiter arbeiten, weiter auf dieser Baustelle arbeiten können, weil sie haben uns gebraucht. Wir haben sehr viel dort geleistet. Aber am selben Tag als sie die Selektion gemacht haben, haben sie es in dieser Weise eingerichtet. Es war, nicht wahr, im März.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es hat geschneit, es war furchtbar kalt. Da waren zwei (2)...zwei (2) Blocks. Wenn ich mich noch gut erinnere, war es Block neun (9) und Block zehn (10). Im Block neun (9) haben wir uns ausgezogen ganz nackt,
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . und ganz nackt müssen wir...
David Boder: Ohne Schuhe?
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . ohne Schuhe, ohne Hemd, ganz...wie man geboren ist, so musste man da laufen bis in den zweiten (2.) Block. Dort war der Arzt und dort hat er nur so geschaut—er hat uns auch gar nicht untersucht, es liegt ihm auch gar nicht daran, ob wir innerliche Fehler haben, denn sie wollten uns ja gar nicht heilen. Aber so hat er nur gesehen...so ungefähr, wie Einer aussieht und wenn der...der, der ihm nicht gefallen hat, der ist dann gleich an die Seite und geschickt...er hat ihn gestrichen von der Liste und er ist gleich nach Auschwitz gekommen. Ich hab nicht besonders gut ausgesehen, aber ich hatte Glück und ich bin...ich sage heute, ich hatte Glück, weil ich mir das alles überlegt habe und ich sehe, dass das alles zum Guten geführt hat, denn die Anderen—glaube ich kaum, dass die alles überlebt haben.-
David Boder: Erlauben Sie mir eine Frage. Sie haben zuerst gesagt, dass die ganze Einrichtung in diesem Lager, wie hat das geheißen, das erste Lager?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Markstadt.
David Boder: Markstadt,...so war, dass keiner mehr konnte als drei (3) Monate leben. Wie lange waren Sie?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich war dort ein Jahr.
David Boder: Wie erklären Sie das?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich habe zuvor bemerkt, dass wenn Einer nur von der Ration gelebt hat, hat er es nicht mehr als drei (3) Monate aushalten können.
David Boder: Und wo von haben Sie denn gelebt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich habe...ich habe so gelebt, ich habe...ich habe mit Zivilisten gearbeitet. Und, und ich habe mein Hemd verkauft einmal...manchmal habe ich geschnorrt um ein Stück Brot oder ein bisschen Suppe.
David Boder: Das heißt gebettelt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Gebettelt, einfach gebettelt. Damals war man kein Großer...und manche haben auch Mitleid gehabt. Manchmal habe ich Zigaretten bekommen, da habe ich sie umgetauscht und so habe ich...
David Boder: Die Zigaretten hat man manchmal vom Lager bekommen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also die Zigaretten, die wir gehabt haben...hatten, haben wir nur vom Lager bekommen und...
David Boder: Und wann duften Sie diese Zigaretten rauchen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Jedenfalls nicht während der Arbeit.
David Boder: Ja. Und wie hat man die an Zivilisten verkauft? Die Zivilisten haben nicht solche Zigaretten gehabt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, in Deutschland war es schwierig mit Zigaretten, sogar die Deutschen haben welche gekauft.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und dann waren Viele...Viele, die sich bei einem Meister beliebt gemacht haben und der Meister hat ihnen zu Essen gebracht. Also man hat damals nicht nach einem Juden gefragt, aber wenn man sich zusammen nimmt, wenn man ein guter Arbeiter ist, man verdient es und man bekommt. Es waren viele Solche . Und wenn man kein Glück hatte und nicht etwas daneben hatte und nur von den Rationen leben musste, die haben das nicht überlebt, das war unmöglich.
David Boder: Und wie Viele sind von Ihren sechs und zwanzig (26) über geblieben?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also das weiß ich nicht mehr. Ich habe schon damals nicht mehr gedacht an diese sechs und zwanzig (26)—hm, man hat...man denkt schon damals nur an sich.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun sind wir ins Lager rüber gekommen, man hat marschiert, jeder musste einen Sessel mit nehmen von dem alten Lager, weil dort waren keine Sessel, es war ein neues Lager. Und als wir einmarschierten, stand, stand...ein, hm, der Rapport Führer und sagt:...
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: „Ihr seid doch alle Juden, nicht wahr?“ So mit Ironie hat er das gesagt.
David Boder: Der SS Mann?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. „Ihr marschiert noch heute, aber ich garantiere Euch, in zwei Wochen werdet Ihr nicht so marschieren.“ Diese Worte hat er gesagt. Man konnte sehen auf seinem Gesicht, dass er sehr, sehr [unverständlich] war. Aber der war nicht dort lange, nur einen Tag, dann ist er in ein anderes Lager transportiert worden, nach Groß-Rosen, dort hat er eine Stelle bekommen.
David Boder: Groß-Rosen ?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, Groß-Rosen. Das Lager Fünfteichen ist unter dem Kommando von Groß-Rosen gewesen.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und dann ist ein anderer Rapport Führer an seine Stelle gekommen, aber der Rapport Führer hat nicht so eine große Rolle gespielt als die Block Ältesten.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 91. Geneva, Switzerland, August the 28th, 1946. That was Abraham Kimmelmann’s report. I think we will have to conclude tonight. I am leaving tomorrow for Milan and it is already 9 o’clock.
David Boder: Spool 92, Geneva, August the 28th, 1946, 9 o’clock in the evening. At the Rue de Prenie. Kimmelmann...Abraham Kimmelmann reporting.
David Boder: [In German] Also Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie sind in ein neues Lager gekommen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: [unverständlich; lautes Pfeifen und Lärm am Tonband] Das war so, wie wir in das Lager gekommen sind, waren dort schon einige russische Häftlinge. Das waren normale Häftlinge in Häftlingskleidung, diese gestreiften Anzüge. Es war dort...
David Boder: Wie hat das Lager geheißen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Fünfteichen.
David Boder: Fünfteichen.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, Fünfteichen. Und dort war es so. Sechs hundert (600) Juden sind noch einige Monate von Auschwitz gekommen.
David Boder: Von Auschwitz?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, von Auschwitz.
David Boder: Sechs hundert (600) Juden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie sind dorthin arbeiten gekommen in diese, in diese Hallen, welche schon fertig waren, welche wir schon gebaut haben. Sie haben gleich Maschinen hineingestellt und sie haben gleich Kanonen gearbeitet. Da man einige Häftlinge als gefährlich betrachtet hat, da hat man sie in solche...in solche Werke gesteckt, wo sie mehr sicher waren, falls...die SS war sicherer da, dass sie nicht ausreißen können, weil sie drinnen waren in [unverständlich].
David Boder: Waren das jüdische Häftlinge?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, von den Sechshundert (600) von denen ich spreche, das waren Juden. Ausserdem waren die Capos und die gesamte Verwaltung des Lagers waren Polen und Deutsche.
David Boder: Ja. Auch Häftlinge?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, auch Häftlinge. Aber das waren Berufsverbrecher oder so Verbrecher, die schon zehn (10) oder zwölf (12) Jahre in Gefängnissen gesessen waren—noch vor dem Krieg—und dann haben sie die Deutschen übernommen und sie haben sie aber zu Block Ältesten befördert. Also was kann man von solchen Leuten erwarten? Menschen, die noch vor dem Krieg Banditen waren und viel Leute ermordet haben. Und als wir herein kamen und sie hörten, dass wir Juden sind, dass jetzt ein Juden-Transport gekommen ist, nun da hatten sie doch die beste Gelegenheit ihre...ihre Moral zu zeigen und mit uns so zu machen, wie es ihnen eigentlich gepasst hat, denn sie haben die Vollmacht bekommen.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und ich bin zugeteilt worden einem Block siebzehn (17). Dort hatten wir einen Polen von der Ukraine, es war ein richtiger Bandit. Aber ein richtiger Verbrecher und gleich mit die...mit die gemeinen Ausdrücke, welche er nur vermagt hat mit seiner Intelligenz. Und das war noch nicht alles, dass er geschrieen hat, aber er hat angefangen uns gleich so zu schlagen...das ist etwas Furchtbares. Ich habe gerade Glück gehabt, ich habe damals nicht Schläge bekommen, aber...aber die Anderen haben geschlagen bekommen...ich war derselbe Kandidat, ich konnte genau so eine herunterhauen bekommen, wie der Andere. Und wir haben unsere Sessel mit gebracht. Heute musste...
David Boder: Was waren das für Sessel, ich hab gedacht, sie haben bloß auf den Betten gesessen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein. Also es war...wenn wir...wir sind auch auf Betten gesessen. Ich werde Ihnen nachher erzählen, wieso das war, dass wir sind auf den Betten gesessen. Also wir haben Sessel von dem Judenlager bekommen. In dem Judenlager wir Tische, wir hatten Betten und wir hatten Stühle. Also die Stühle haben wir mit gebracht und sagte—wir müssen sie putzen. Er hat Glaspapier gegeben, ein kleines Stücklein und damit mussten wir es ganz sauber machen, also genau wie neues Holz vom Holzwerk rausgekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Als wir zusammen saßen und putzten, hat er...hat er von Einem...von Einem den Stuhl geholt und hat es geschmissen und hat gleich zwei Leuten den Kopf geöffnet. Da hat gleich das Blut geronnen, aber man durfte nicht in das Revier gehen, denn man durfte nicht raus gehen. Es war die erste Nacht und man durfte nicht. Und was hat man gemacht? Er hat die Jacke ausgezogen und um den Kopf rum gehängt bis das Blut vertrocknet war und...und er ist schlafen gegangen. Also die erste Nacht hat er gleich drei (3) Juden tot geschlagen. Und...und morgens, als...
David Boder: Richtig tot geschlagen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Richtig tot geschlagen. Man hat sie gleich in das Krematorium geführt nach Groß-Rosen und...und ungefähr so fünfzig (50) sind in Krankenhaus gegangen.
David Boder: Nun ja, wenn nachher beim Appell drei (3) Tote waren—also drei (3) gefehlt haben, haben denn die SS nicht verlangt, wo sie waren oder was?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, im Gegenteil. Die haben sich gefreut, dass so ein Block Ältester so etwas macht.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nach ihrer Meinung sollte doch die Aufgabe der Block Ältesten, die sein.
David Boder: Hat man Jemanden tot geschlagen, haben die Block Ältesten im anderen Lager Jemanden tot geschlagen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wo meinen Sie? In dem Judenlager?
David Boder: In dem Judenlager, ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, das kam vor.
David Boder: Dass der Block Älteste Jemanden tot geschlagen hat.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, in dem Lager hat es keine Block Ältesten gegeben.
David Boder: Was waren die? Schieber?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Schieber, ja.
David Boder: Und hat es passiert, dass die Jemanden tot geschlagen haben?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein die Schieber gingen nicht so weit, aber die Drei (3).
David Boder: Oh, diese Drei (3). Die drei...was waren die
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die Henker.
David Boder: Oh, die drei Henker.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, die haben Viele tot geschlagen.
David Boder: Hat man die beauftragt sie tot zu schlagen? Oder haben sie bloß geschlagen, bis die Leute tot waren?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, es hat manches Mal so geheißen und manches Mal haben sie gewollt.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sie haben verfügt über unser Leben.
David Boder: AH hm. Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also, das ist nicht nur in unserem Block passiert. Wie ich nachher vernommen habe, das ist überall so passiert. In unserem Block war es so, es war so ein schrecklicher Mann und er hat so Vielen was gemacht. Und wenn wir schon ganz müde waren und so viel Blut auf dem Fußboden war, dann sagte er, wir sollen das ganze Blut aufwischen und den Fußboden putzen und man soll sich aufstellen in Reihen in dem Raum und so mussten wir sehen die ganze Nacht. Er hat sich einen Gehilfen genommen für den Stubendienst—da war der Vertreter des Block Ältesten und sie sind auf Abwechslung geschlafen. Der zwei (2) Stunden, der zwei (2) Stunden und sie haben Wache über uns gehalten, so dass niemand von uns sitzen sollte. Und wenn er Jemanden geschnappt hat, der gesessen hat, der, der hat schon kein...der hat schon keinen Sonnenschein mehr gesehen. Also selbstverständlich man hat nicht sitzen können, man ist die ganze Nacht so gestanden und kurz –eine halbe Stunde vorm Appell—das heißt kurz vor fünf (5) Uhr hat er uns in die Betten gejagt, wir sollen sofort in die Betten gehen. Und man ist eine halbe...es noch nicht gereicht...man ist auf den Betten gelegen, da hat man schon geweckt für Appell. Man ist raus auf den Appell, es war furchtbar kalt. Man hat uns die Mäntel zu genommen und alle Jacken. Die Jacken, die Ziviljacken waren noch ziemlich dick, die man von zu Hause hat. Das hat man uns zu genommen, manche sind nur noch in den Hemden herum gelaufen und so sind sie auf den Appell raus.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es ist kalt...von diesen Sachen will ich Ihnen schon nicht erzählen. Die Kälte hat jeder schon mitgemacht und da kann sich jeder vorstellen was Kälte ist. Und so sind wir dort gestanden, mal war es eine Stunde, mal waren es zwei (2); überhaupt am Anfang bevor wir zur Arbeit gingen, da sind sie immer länger gestanden. Man hat gezählt und dann auf die Blocks. Als wir auf die Blocks kamen, haben wir dort Frühstück bekommen. Das Frühstück war sozusagen...das Frühstück war schon besser als im Judenlager, weil wir dort heiße Suppe bekommen haben, Grießsuppe morgens und das haben wir im Judenlager nicht bekommen. Nach der Suppe musste man den Block putzen, die Betten machen. Die Betten mussten so gerade sein wie ein Tisch, wie dieser Tisch.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und wenn etwas nicht gestimmt hat, so hat er was...hat der Betreffende was zu erleben gehabt. Wenn die Betten, man hat es ihm gesagt, als die Betten fertig waren und er ist herein gegangen. Und wenn er nichts gefunden hat, dann hat er alle von dem Schlafzimmer...der Block war so geteilt in einen Eß-Saal und an beiden Seiten die Schlafsäle, das waren Schlafräume. Am Anfang hatten wir noch jeder ein Bett. Da hat Jeder ein einem Bett geschlafen, eine Decke—es war Winter, es war trotzdem kalt und ein Bett...hm, die Betten mussten zur besten Ordnung hergestellt werden. Und wenn er nichts gefunden hat, wenn jeder sein Bett in Ordnung gehabt hat, dann hat er von die Schlafsäle alle rausgejagt. Und hat dort in einem Bett etwas gemacht. Dann hat er uns herein gerufen und gesagt: „Schaut, was für Betten ihr macht!:“ Wenn man auch gewusst hat, dass er das gemacht hat, durfte man sowieso nichts sagen. Und darunter haben auch alle gelitten. Man hat uns so geschlagen, man hat uns doch nicht geschlagen für etwas, weil man gewollt hat. Und ich wunderte mich, dass er nachher so einen Trick machen musste. Er konnte doch so einfach Jemanden schlagen, es hat sich überhaupt niemand...es hat sich auch niemand gewehrt. Schon war man fertig mit den Betten, Gott sei Dank, muss man die Schränke putzen. Dann muss man den ganzen Tag stehen. Ein Schrank, der schon nicht so ganz sauber ist, da muss man stehen...
David Boder: Mit was hat man die geputzt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Mit Glaspapier oder mit einem Lumpen.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und dann sagte er so...wir haben damals noch verschiedene Geschirre von dem Judenlager mitgebracht. Da hat er da alles rausgeschmissen auf den Misthaufen und hat gesagt so: „Wenn ihr zur Arbeit geht, ihr müsst Teller organisieren, ihr müsst Farbe organisieren für den...für den Block zu malen. Ihr müsst alles organisieren.“ Ich hab damals noch nicht gewusst, was heißt organisieren. Also man hat es einfach stehlen müssen. Der Block Älteste hat von uns verlangt, dass wir von der Baustelle stehlen sollen und auf der Baustelle, wenn man uns geschnappt hat, ist diese Meldung zum Block Ältesten gekommen und er hat uns dafür geschlagen. Also Sie können sich vorstellen in was für eine Situation wir waren. Und so hatten wir die erste Zeit mitgemacht. Wir haben dafür...wir haben auf dem Block geschlagen...Schläge bekommen für das, was wir nicht gebracht haben und wir haben auch bekommen, wenn wir gebracht haben. Also was man auch gemacht hat, man hat Schläge bekommen. Und ich will...ich will erzählen ein Fall, der auf mich einen großen Eindruck gemacht hat und zwar einen guten Eindruck. Es war dort in unserem Block ein Vater mit einem Sohn.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Der Vater war schon fünfzig (50) Jahre alt und er ist auch...ich weiß nicht wieso...nach Fünfteichen gekommen. Er hat...er war schon ein bisschen geschwollen. Und der Sohn, den er hat gehabt, der war sehr kräftig. Er hat eine gute Firma gehabt in dem Judenlager und er hat sich sehr gut geholfen. Er hat zwischen den tschechischen Baracken gearbeitet und die Tschechen haben noch am Anfang sehr viel essen gehabt, sie haben das...ein bisschen verschimmeltes Brot haben sie auf den Misthaufen geschmissen und davon hat man sich gut ernähren können. Man war glücklich, wenn man so etwas gefunden hat. So war er genug kräftig. Und der Vater, weil er schon alt war und er konnte sich nicht so schnell bewegen, der ist immer das erste Opfer gewesen. Er hat so viel Schläge bekommen, dass er es schon mal nicht mehr aushalten konnte.
David Boder: Aha, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun den selben Tag hat passiert, dass der Vater...hat der Vater die ersten Schläge bekommen und der Sohn konnte es schon nicht mehr aushalten. Er hat irgend eine...er hat irgendwo...er hat den Mut geholt und hat sich hingestellt als, wie der wieder einmal auf den Vater zugehen wollte und ihm eine runter hauen und hat gesagt: „Herr Block Ältester, warum schlagen Sie meinen Vater?“ Wie er hat gehört hat, er hat aufgehoben den Stock, aber er hat ihn noch nicht geschlagen und er sagt ihm: „Was, Du wagst mir so eine Frage zu stellen? Weißt Du nicht, dass ich über Dein leben, Deines Vater’s Leben und das Leben von hundert fünfzig verfluchte Juden, was auf diesem Block sind, verfüge und ich kann doch machen, was ich will. Ja, und Du hast mir was zu sagen?“ Sagt er: „Ja, Herr Block Ältester, mich können Sie schlagen, wieviel Sie wollen, ich kann nichts sagen und ich werd nicht weinen auch, aber meinen Vater sollen Sie in Ruhe lassen!“ Und ich weiß nicht wieso, das hat auf ihn gewirkt, er hat den Vater nicht mehr berührt. Im Gegenteil er hat ihm mehr Suppe gegeben und dem Sohn hat er eine Mission gegeben im Block und...und er hatte die...er hat das Haus, den Fußboden immer geputzt und hat mehr Essen bekommen. Also ich meine, man kann nicht sagen, dass wenn jeder Eine das gemacht hätte, dass es ihm gelungen wäre,...
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . denn es haben Viele, hm, bestimmt so gemacht und sie sind dafür tot geschlagen worden. Man hat nicht solche Sachen toleriert in jedem Lager, denn man war nicht so moralisch. Aber gerade ihm ist es gelungen, gelungen und es hat auf mir einen sehr, sehr guten Eindruck gemacht. Vom Block—von die hundert siebzig (170) Mann, wo ich war, sind tagtäglich weniger geworden. Es sind tagtäglich mehr auf das Revier gegangen. Manche sind schon nicht mehr zurück gekommen, Viele sind gestorben und dann haben sie wieder angefangen da...
David Boder: Was haben sie mit den Toten da gemacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Mit den Toten das war so. Ein Krematorium—in diesem Lager war keines, sondern jeden Mittwoch und Samstag ist ein Auto gekommen, man hat die Toten nach Groß-Rosen geschickt...genommen und dort hat man sie verbrannt.
David Boder: Und wo sind die Toten gelegen bis Mittwoch und Samstag?
Abraham Kimmelmann: In ein...in einen Totenraum hat man sie geholt; ein spezieller Raum für die Toten.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun das Schlagen war noch nicht alles, man hat uns nicht schlafen lassen. Jeden Abend als wir nach Hause kamen, hat er uns aufgehalten in dem Eß-Saal—man durfte nicht raus gehen, in die Toilette durfte man nur gruppenweise gehen und zwar nur, wenn Einer die Verantwortung übernommen hat und jeden Abend sind wir auf gewesen bis ein, zwei (2) Uhr in der Nacht und um fünf (5) Uhr mussten wir aufstehen.
David Boder: Und wo war die Toilette?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Die Toilette war weit entfernt von dem Block.
David Boder: Für jeden Block?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Da war ein spezieller Block mit Toiletten—also der Baderaum und die Toiletten waren zusammen.
David Boder: Sind die Leute von verschiedenen Blocks zur selben Toilette gegangen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, die sind zur selben Toilette gegangen. Der Block, welcher nahe an den, an den Toiletten war, die hatten schon Glück.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber wir waren sehr weit weg, wir haben an dem Zaun gewohnt.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun ein Mensch—wenn man, wie man ihn zwingt, es gibt aber überall Grenzen. Wenn man sich schlagen gelassen hat, man hat uns so viel geschlagen und man hat uns wenig zu essen gegeben und man hat keine Kraft zu arbeiten. Und als wir zur Arbeit kamen, sind wir einfach bei der Arbeit eingeschlafen. Wenn man nicht schläft...und schlafen muss man doch...also die Meister haben ein bisschen Verständnis gehabt für uns. Am Anfang haben sie uns geschlagen und gesagt: „Ihr wollt nicht.“ Aber dann haben sie gesehen mit dem Schlagen machen sie nichts. Die Leute haben einfach geschlafen. Sie haben eine Meldung abgelegt auf die Bauleitung.
David Boder: Und wo hat man geschlafen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Bei der Arbeit...man hat die Schaufel gehalten und man ist dabei eingeschlafen. So haben sie eine Meldung abgelegt bei der Bauleitung, sie können es nicht verstehen, denn wenn wir im Judenlager waren, haben wir mehr geleistet, wir haben gut geleistet und jetzt können wir nicht mehr arbeiten. Entweder die SS soll uns ganz vernichten, so sollen sie uns...so sollen sie Juden auf die Baustelle nicht schicken, denn wir können solche Arbeiter nicht brauchen.
David Boder: Das hat die Bau...
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, die Bauleitung hat das verlangt. Also sie haben das...sie haben interveniert bei dem Lagerführer und haben gesagt: „Entweder behältst Du die Leute im Lager und Du machst mit ihnen was Du willst. Und wenn Du sie auf die Baustelle schicken willst, so musst Du sie so herrichten, dass sie mindestens das Minimale leisten können.“ Also damals ist ein Befehl raus gegeben worden vom Lagerführer, dass um neun (9) Uhr müssen alle im Bett liegen und man durfte keinen mehr schlagen. Oh, als wir nach Hause kamen, da haben wir die Nachricht gehört und das war etwas. Wir haben uns gefreut und wir haben gedacht, Messias ist gekommen.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie das gehört? Hat man Sie wissen lassen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hat es schon gemerkt. Es waren...es waren dort nicht nur Block Älteste, es war, zum Beispiel, Küchenpersonal und die haben doch das alles vernommen, denn sie waren ja den ganzen Tag im Lager und sie haben es uns erzählt. Es waren auch von den Auschwitzer Juden waren auch Einige im Küchenpersonal und die haben es auch erzählt. Von den sechshundert (600) Juden...die sind...da sind keine hundert (100) mehr geblieben, als wir kamen. Es hat nur drei (3) Monate gedauert und...
David Boder: Von den Auschwitz Juden?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, den Auschwitz Juden...da sind mehr als fünf hundert (500) vernichtet worden und die, die schon beim Leben...am Leben geblieben sind, die haben sich irgendwie durch geschlagen. Auch deswegen weil sie gedreht haben, sie haben gleich Bekanntschaft gemacht in der Halle und sie haben mehr zum Essen bekommen. Oder Manche haben sie in das Küchenpersonal rein bekommen und so haben sie das überlebt.
David Boder: Die Leute, die in der Küche gearbeitet haben, die haben gut gegessen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Sehr gut; überhaupt das ganze Lagerpersonal. Ich habe Ihnen schon gesagt, das war, das war die Politik der Deutschen. Sie müssen doch Jemanden zufrieden stellen müssen, sonst werden sie doch kein Interesse haben, den Zweiten zu unterdrücken.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ich meine speziell zu unterdrücken.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun als wir das hörten, da waren wir überglücklich. Wir gehen nach Hause, man hat niemanden geschlagen, aber er sagte so—also im Polnischen hat er damals gesagt: „Ja, schlagen darf ich nicht—das muss ich selber zugeben, schlagen darf ich nicht mehr. Aber ich werde Läuse Appell machen, das heißt, der der Läuse hat, der wird nicht schlafen gehen, bis er keine Läuse mehr hat.“ Also hier haben wir Tausende gehabt, sie können sich das nicht vorstellen.
David Boder: Sie haben Läuse in die Tausende gehabt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wir haben Tausende gehabt und bis man das alles wegholt, das...das hätte noch eine Ewigkeit gedauert.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gemacht mit diesen Läusen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hat sie tot gemacht—mit den Fingern einfach. Und das hat er uns gelassen. Es war doch niemand, der das nicht gehabt hat. Also trotzdem, dass wir um 9 Uhr schlafen gehen müssen, hat er das gemacht und wir sind wieder bis zwei (2) Uhr auf gewesen und dann hat er sich erbarmt und hat uns schlafen gelassen...um zwei (2) Uhr erst. Dann sind wir morgens wieder zur Arbeit gegangen und wir morgens wieder zur Arbeit gegangen und wir sind wieder eingeschlafen und haben das erzählt und dann ist wieder eine Meldung gekommen, er soll das auch nicht machen, wir sollen schlafen gehen. Das hat eine Woche angehalten. Wir waren...hm, wir hatten schon mehr Ruhe auf dem Block und die Block Ältesten, die haben das schon nicht mehr aushalten können.. Sie müssen schlagen. Das war ihr Bedürfnis so wie...wie jeder Mensch essen muss. Und da haben sie eine Klage eingelegt aufs Schreibbüro, dass wir uns der Ordnung des Lagers nicht zupassen.
David Boder: Von welchem Büro?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Vom Schreibbüro, vom Schreibbüro, so hat es geheißen, das Schreibbüro. Also dort sind alle Rapporte...
David Boder: Schreibbüro?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Schreibbüro.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und sie haben sich beklagt, sie haben keine Ordnung mehr, da ist Schmutz und so weiter und man verlangt von sie, dass ist Ordnung in den Blocks sein soll. Also das haben sie so gemacht, dass man schlagen darf, aber nicht totschlagen und auch nicht, also man darf nur trockene Schläge geben, dass man nachher keine Zeichen hat. Dann wenn man schon schlagen...wenn das Schlagen schon wieder erlaubt wird, und als wir nach Hause kamen, hat er gleich vor der Tür zwei (2) Stocks schon vorbereitet. So wenn die ersten Zwei herein kamen, gleich auf den Stuhl hingelegt und hat sie geschlagen. Hat wieder die Wut, seine Wut ausgelassen. Also es ist so tagtäglich gegangen...drei (3) Monate lang haben wir nicht mehr gesehen als schlagen, totschlagen, noch einmal totschlagen, gar nichts zu essen und schwere Arbeit. Die Appells morgens waren etwas Furchtbares. Wir haben...wir haben angetreten jeden Tag zum Appell. Also für die Blockführer haben wir angetreten Blockweise. Und als das abgenommen wurde, ist man wieder Arbeitskommandoweise angetreten, das heißt, je nach Kommandos, wie die auf der Baustelle zusammen gearbeitet haben. Ausmarschiert haben wir Hundertschaftsweise. Für jede hundert (100) Mann ist Einer verantwortlich gewesen, dass sie gerade in der Reihe gehen sollen und dass sie sich anständig auf der Strasse benehmen sollen. Also sind angestellt worden drei (3) Reihen. Wir waren damals achtzehn hundert (1 800) Mann, also zu sechs hundert (600) in einer Reihe. Wenn die das in Ordnung...in Ordnung ge...ge...
David Boder: Gemacht.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . gemacht hätten und wenn das eigentlich ihr Ziel wäre, so hätten sie das gemacht, dass gleich von dem Block raus marschiert, wie wir angestellt waren und dann zu sechs—Jeder hat dann angefangen zu laufen und haben sich hingestellt, wo es ihnen gepasst hat. Denn Jeder wollte in die erste Reihe gehen, denn es ist so, wenn eine große Reihe geht, wenn acht hundert (800) Mann gehen und man geht nicht mit einem Militärschritt, so kommt aus, dass man, das wenn Einer ein bisschen langsamer geht, dann muss der Hintere sich aufhalten.
David Boder: Aufhalten.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aufhalten, ja. Und wenn er es nachher mit einem schnelleren Schritt macht, so kommt es, dass einige hundert...einige hundert Personen in den Reihen später, muss man, muss man ganz wieder nachlaufen. Also man war einfach schon ganz müde bis man auf die Baustelle gekommen ist, so dass es das Beste war mit den ersten Hundert in die Shops zu gehen. Also jeder Einer hat sich gedrückt, um zuerst in die Shops zu kommen. Es war eben keine Ordnung. Und das wollten sie, denn wenn keine Ordnung war, dann haben sie gearbeitet, dann konnten sie schlagen. Also man hat jeden Tag Tote gefunden, die nicht mehr zur Arbeit gehen konnten, weil man sie einfach tot geschlagen hat. Es hat so drei (3) Monate, die ersten drei (3) Monate was man von uns mit, hm, hm,...acht hundert (800) Mann ins Krematorium geführt.
David Boder: Und das war kein Vernichtungslager?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Es hat geheißen Arbeitslager.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Also es war ein Vernichtungslager, aber ein Inoffizielles, der Namen hat anders gelautet.
David Boder: Nun und ?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun hat man sich wieder gewöhnt dazu. Wenn man schon wieder zusammen lebt und wir haben schon eine Zeitlang auf einer anderen Baustelle gearbeitet, wir haben schon Bekanntschaft mit dem Meister gehabt und haben wir wieder angefangen zu handeln. In diesem Lager war es wieder das Gute, dass wir mehr Zigaretten bekommen haben. Und zwar haben wir bekommen auf diese Weise, dass gute Arbeiter haben Prämienscheine bekommen. Prämien. Also Jeder nach seiner Arbeit, es war aber auch abhängig von dem Meister, da haben wir eine oder zwei bekommen und zu diesem war eine Kantine und mit diesen hat man Zigaretten gekauft. Also für die Zigaretten hat man wieder auswechseln können und es ist so weit gegangen, dass Manche haben Geschäfte mit dem, mit dem Meister gemacht und die haben für einige hundert Mark Prämienscheine bekommen und dafür konnten sie viel Zigaretten haben. Die Zigaretten haben sie wieder dem Meister gegeben und der Meister hat ihnen Schokolade gebracht oder Alkohol. Das haben sie wieder ins Lager gebracht für die Block Ältesten und so haben sie Bekanntschaft gemacht.
David Boder: Der Meister war kein Häftling?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, der Meister war kein Häftling, der war von Zivil. Und so haben sie Bekannt...und so haben sich zusammen gelebt mit den Block Ältesten und man hat angefangen mit den Juden zusammen zu leben, weil die Juden nützlich schon waren und haben gute Sachen gebracht. . Es ist schließlich dazu gekommen, dass im Detail sind...fast die Hälfte waren jüdischen Block Älteste, in der Küche war mehr als die Halben Juden, in der Schreibstube war das ganze Personal Juden. Also das Lager haben fast die Juden übernommen und damals war es...für das ganze Lager ganz leicht. Wir waren schon nicht mehr so bedroht, wir waren nicht mehr so unter Gefahr. Man hat geschlagen, denn die jüdischen Block Ältesten haben auch geschlagen, aber doch nicht speziell als Jude. Verstehen Sie? Man hat geschlagen, wenn man hat gesehen, dass man sich irgend auf eine Weise der Disziplin unterwirft, obwohl das war unmöglich, aber man hat mindestens ein Quantum von Schläge...hm, hm, nicht bekommen. Und man hat es aushalten können. Also...dort war ich wieder bis neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944). Neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944)—zu dieser Zeit habe ich auch etwas angefangen zu handeln. Ich habe auch Prämienscheine bekommen, weil ich gut gearbeitet habe. Ich hab es Ihnen schon erzählt, auch die Meister haben mich ein bisschen gern bekommen, manchmal haben sie mir Brot gegeben und schließlich haben sie mir Prämienscheine gegeben.
David Boder: Und was haben Sie da gearbeitet?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Damals habe ich gearbeitet in einer Firma Hell und Keder, das war eine Wiener Firma für Dachdecken. Wir haben so spezielle, solche Kalt- und Wärme Isolierungsplatten gelegt und aus solche Platten haben wir Dächer gemacht. Die Arbeit war eine sehr gefährliche Arbeit. Das waren Asbest Platten. Die Platten waren von Holzabfall und Gips gemischt. Darauf durfte man nicht steigen, wen sie frisch gelegt waren. Wenn man drauf gestanden ist, so ist man runter gestürzt.
David Boder: Sie habe also aktuell die Dächer gemacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wir haben die Dächer gemacht.
David Boder: Wofür?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Für die Hallen, für die Krupps Werke.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war die einzige Firma.
David Boder: Haben Sie damals auf dem Dach gearbeitet?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Auf dem Dach gearbeitet. Und zwar waren sehr öfters Fälle, auch im Judenlager, viele Juden sind vom...hm, hm,...
David Boder: Vom Dach runter.
Abraham Kimmelmann: . . . vom Dach runter gefallen und waren gleich tot. Also man hat schon gewusst, wenn man Jemanden während des Tages zum Lager zurück gebracht hat, vom Judenlager rede ich, hat man gleich gewusst, es ist von der Firma Hell und Keder. Also ich hab mich dazu gewöhnt, man kann sagen, ich habe Glück gehat und ich habe mich dazu gewöhnt, hm, hm,...auf den Dächern zu laufen. Und wir durften nicht auf den Platten laufen, sonder nur auf den Spannern, das heißt, auf Holzbrettern, die gelegt waren. Das war ungefähr eine Breite von dreißig (0) Zentimeter und auf diesen durften wir laufen. Ich hab mich dazu gewöhnt und ich habe zwei (2) Jahre für die selbe Firma gearbeitet. Ich war dort sehr beliebt und schließlich letztlich habe ich viele Prämienscheine bekommen. Ich habe dafür Zigaretten eingekauft in der Kantine und habe ich manches Mal dafür ein Brot gekauft und das Brot habe ich wieder verkauft im Lager für teurer und ich habe so verdient.
David Boder: Für wofür?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Für teurer. Zum Beispiel, wenn ich für ein Brot...sagen wir mal ich habe gegeben dreißig (30) Zigaretten, dann hab ich im Lager vierzig (40) genommen.
David Boder: Ah hm!
Abraham Kimmelmann: So habe ich mir meine Ration Brot verdient. Und dann bin ich einigermaßen zu Mark gekommen, denn in diesem Lage hat das Geld Wert gehabt, weil viele Zivilisten auf der Baustelle gearbeitet haben und sie das Geld gebraucht haben. Also wir haben...es war schon so ein großer Handel, kann man sagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Man hat schon gewusst, da kann man Brot bekommen, da kann man Speisen bekommen. Man hat gehandelt. Schließlich ist es dazu gekommen, dass ich hundert (100) Mark verdient habe und diese hundert (100) Mark habe ich gegeben einem Bekannten, der in der Küche gearbeitet hat, dass er dort bei dem Küchenchef intervenieren soll, dass er mich als Gehilfe zunehmen soll. Das heißt, abends, als ich von der Arbeit zurück kam, bin ich raufgegangen in die Küche. [Pause—allem Anschein nach überspringt das Tonband einige Sätze]...als sie schon näher kamen—nahe von uns—mussten wir evakuieren.
David Boder: Hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war Januar 1945. Januar, ja. Es hat doch keinen Sinn, wenn ich wieder von Einzelfällen erzähle, wo man Juden geschlagen hat. Ich habe Ihnen da schon einen Einblick gegeben, wie es in diesen Lagern ausgesehen hat. Also der Schluss ist, dass letztens war es schon ziemlich gut für uns. Wir haben uns schon an die...die, die kleineren Sachen haben wir uns gewöhnt und so also konnte man durch kommen und wir haben gelernt und uns auf diese Weise geholfen. Januar ist gekommen der Befehl, dass wir evakuieren müssen und da fängt wieder an eine neue Periode. Man hat uns auf den Weg gegeben fünf hundert (500) Gramm Brot und ein Stück Wurst, jeder hat zwei (2) Decken mit genommen und so sind wir gelaufen.
David Boder: Sie sind zu Fuß gelaufen?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Zu Fuß. Ob jemand Schuhe gehabt hat oder nicht, da hat sich niemand darum gekümmert . Im tiefsten Schnee so sind wir gelaufen. Wir sind um drei (3) Uhr nachmittags an einem Sonntag sind wir raus, bewacht von der SS und sind gelaufen bis zwei (2) Uhr nachts ohne zu schlafen, wir haben alles schon schlafen gewollt, aber die SS war schon müde und da haben sie uns in eine Scheune quartiert. Also eine Scheune wo höchstens fünf hundert (500) Mann rein gehen können, sind wir zwei tausend fünf hundert (2 500) Mann hinein. Wir waren zusammen fünf tausend (5 000) in diesem Lager, da haben sie uns zwei (2) Scheunen zur Verfügung gestellt. Also, Sie können sich vorstellen, morgens als wir aufstanden, da hat man die Toten gestapelt, wie Bohnen auf die Bahngeleise. Also haben Sie schon gesehen, wie man das stapelt?
David Boder: Bahngeleise.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Bahngeleise...auf die Schwellen. So hat man die Toten gestapelt und liegen lassen. Also wir haben so fünf (5) Nächte marschiert und wir haben nichts mehr zu essen gehabt, als das was wir auf den Weg bekommen haben, fünf hundert (500) Gramm Brot.
David Boder: Vor der Reise?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Vor der Reise. Also, es war keine Reise, wir haben ein [unverständlich; beide sprechen].
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ein Ausflug.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Und wir sind so marschiert. Viele sind unterwegs gefallen und der, der nicht mehr mitmachen konnte, der hat sich hingestellt und hat erwartet den Tod.
David Boder: Wie hat er den Tod erwartet?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das war etwas, was man nicht...was man nicht im Stande zu erzählen ist. Ein Mensch, der noch voll bei seinen Sinnen ist, bei dem noch...noch alles funktioniert, der aber schwach ist, er kann nicht mehr laufen. Er stellt sich an einen Baum hin, die Augen glänzen wie, wie...wie Reflektoren. Und er wartet auf den Moment bis die ganze Reihe durchgehen wird, bis die letzte Wache kommen wird mit dem Blockführer, der ist auch ein SS Mann, der ihn erschießt. Können Sie sich das vorstellen, was das ist. Ein Mensch, der noch seine ganzen Gedanken hat, der noch weiß, was sich mit ihm tut und er wartet auf den Tod. Und solche hat man...jede zehn (10) Meter hat man gesehen Einen stehen unter einem Baum oder hingesetzt und so...man hat so einen Mann erschossen und in den Graben geschmissen. Also wir sind zwölf tausend (12 000) Mann von Markstadt weg und unser Ziel war nach Groß-Rosen zu gehen. Wir sind nach Groß-Rosen nicht mehr als vier tausend (4 000) gekommen. Acht hundert (800) sind unterwegs gestorben und erschossen worden. In Groß-Rosen...also jede Nacht sind wir in eine Scheune und haben einige Stunden geschlafen...jede Nacht war das.
David Boder: Groß-Rosen ist bei Auschwitz?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein Groß-Rosen ist in der Nähe von Breslau, drei (3) Kilometer von Breslau.
David Boder: Oh ja, Birkenau ist bei Auschwitz.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja. In der Scheune war es damals etwas Furchtbares. Die Menschen haben einander tot geschlagen, also um nachher auf ihm schlafen zu können. Also wenn er noch so viel von seinen Kräften gefühlt hat, hat er den Anderen tot geschlagen, um nachher auf ihm schlafen zu können, um mehr Platz zu haben. Es war nicht einmal Platz zum Stehen, Sie können sich vorstellen, wenn man fünf hundert (500) Mann nur rein stecken kann und man hat zwei tausend fünf hundert (2500)—also fünffach so viel.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Schließlich sind wir...also ich hab noch das alles mit gemacht, also ich weiß doch selber nicht wieso. Also, wenn Sie mir diese Frage stellen werden, bin ich gar nicht im Stande zu antworten, ich weiß noch bis heute nicht, wie ich das überlebt habe und das ist mehr Glück als Verstand, wie man sagt. Ich bin nach Groß-Rosen gekommen, also alle sind wir nach Groß-Rosen gekommen und da hat man uns auf das sogenannte neue Lager geführt. Das war ein Lager, wo man neue Baracken hin gestellt hat, das heißt, die waren noch nicht außen fertig und das war im Winter. Da hat man uns in die Keller, und oben wo noch keine Türen waren.
David Boder: In die Keller?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, in die Keller.
David Boder: Haben denn die Baracken Keller gehabt?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Ja, die haben Keller gehabt, ja.
David Boder: Wozu?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Auch um zu wohnen. Sie haben den Platz ausgenutzt und oben waren die Fenster, es waren noch keine Scheiben drinnen und die Türen waren offen.
David Boder: Kein Platz.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Kein Platz. Und so haben wir geschlafen.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Aber es war warm, weil man uns so zusammengepresst hat, dass nur Derjenige, der am Fenster oder bei der Türe geschlafen hat, nur der hat es gefühlt. Die Anderen haben viel zu viel heiß gehabt. Manche...
David Boder: Viel zu viel was?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Viel zu viel heiß gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Manche sind sogar von Groß-Rosen nicht mehr aufgestanden. Also man, es ist sozusagen, da waren keine Betten, keine Pritschen, es war nur der Fußboden. Also auf einem Fußboden von ungefähr fünf und zwanzig (25) Meter die Länge und zehn (10) Meter die Breite haben...hat man zwei tausend (2 000) Mann rein...rein gestoßen. Also können Sie sich das vorstellen, wie das war?
David Boder: Hm, nein! Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nun so war die erste Nacht. Es war noch eine Unordnung. Man hat noch nicht gewusst über den Zustand, man hat nicht gewusst zu welchem Block man gehört. Man hat noch keinen Namen aufgenommen, wir hatten damals schon keinen Namen, sondern Nummern. Im KZ haben wir Nummern bekommen. Mein Name war, meine Nummer war vier und zwanzig sieben tausend drei und neunzig (247093). Und wir sind...dort haben wir die erste Nacht geschlafen. Wir haben nichts zu essen bekommen. Morgens haben sie uns gesagt, man muss zum Appell antreten. Es war fünf (5) Uhr, stock finster und wir sind hier am Appell gestanden bis zwölf (12) Uhr mittags...im Winter. Um fünf Uhr...
David Boder: Warum?
Abraham Kimmelmann: So einfach, weil es ihnen so gepasst hat. Dann sind endlich die Blockführer gekommen, die haben Appell gemacht und haben uns verteilt auf die Blocks. Man hat die...
David Boder: Haben die aufgeschrieben, wenn jemand auf dem Weg gestorben ist? Oder was haben sie gemacht?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Gar nichts war aufgeschrieben. Damals hat man sogar...[unverständlich; beide sprechen].
David Boder: Wenn sie einen Appell gemacht haben, haben sie gewusst , wer da sein soll...[unverständlich; beide sprechen].
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, das war der Grund warum sie Appell gemacht haben, der Appell war eben um zu wissen, wie viele noch am Leben geblieben sind und dass niemand wieder ausreißt.
David Boder: Ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Um die Toten brauchen sie sich nicht mehr kümmern. Ein Toter wird schon nicht mehr lebendig werden, aber eben die Lebendigen...vielleicht fällt noch Jemandem was ein oder das Ausreißen. Deswegen müssen sie Kontrolle haben. Deshalb haben sie alles beim Appell aufgenommen und verteilt auf die Blöcke. Und in Groß-Rosen hat sich etwas abgespielt.
David Boder: Sind Frauen auch mit gewesen oder nur Männer?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Nein, bei uns war ein Männerlager, aber nach Groß-Rosen sind auch Frauen nachher hingekommen. Sie haben in extra Baracken gelebt und ich hab sie nicht gesehen. Das Lager war ungeheuer gross. Das Lager konnte—bei normalen Bedingungen—konnte es auch nicht mehr aufnehmen wie fünf tausend (5 000) Mann. Und damals waren hier fünf und zwanzig tausend (25 000). Denn von überall von den kleineren Lagern hat man evakuiert nach Groß-Rosen.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Dort war etwas, was nicht zu erzählen ist. Denn im letzten Jahre neunzehn hundert vier und vierzig (1944), wie ich schon erzählt habe, hat man schon bei uns im Lager nicht mehr so geschlagen. Und da—da haben sie schon niemanden mehr gekannt und da haben die Block Ältesten gemacht, was sie wollten. Sie haben das Ganze—sie haben das beste Essen raus geholt und uns haben sie nichts zu essen gegeben. Übrigens in Groß-Rosen hat man fast nichts zu essen bekommen.
David Boder: Nun?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Wir haben zwei hundert (200) Gramm Brot bekommen, schwarzes Brot und einen halben Liter Steckrüben Suppe, welche man nicht in den Mund nehmen konnte.
David Boder: Was für eine Suppe?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Steckrüben
David Boder: Was ist das?
Abraham Kimmelmann: Steckrüben, also ich weiß nicht, wie ich Ihnen das erklären kann. Steckrüben.
David Boder: Ja. Steckrüben, ja.
Abraham Kimmelmann: Das hat man uns um zwei (2) Uhr in der Nacht gebracht, wenn wir schon geschlafen haben, denn die Küche konnte nicht nach kommen, sie haben tags und nachts gearbeitet. Verstehen Sie?
David Boder: Ein Moment.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool 92, and we have to conclude the interview, we have no more reserve of spools. This is Kimmelmann’s report, which stops at Gross-Rosen. He will continue for me when I return. Geneva, August the 28th, 1946 at the home for boys maintained by the Swiss Government. [unintelligible]